WELCOME. TO THE A COMMITTEE ON
ENERGY UTILITIES AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
I THINK IS OUR FINAL COMMITTEE
HEARING OF THE EAR.
OUR FINAL SCHEDULED.
SCHEDULED A HEARING OF THE EAR.
THAT IS ON THIS YEAR'S CALENDAR
SO WE WILL SEE.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD.
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATOR SCIENCES --
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TWENTY SIX I'D
LIKE TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE AND STAKEHOLDERS FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL AND
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENT IN
THE ANALYSIS.
REGARDING CORPORATION
APPROPRIATE TRIGGER FOR THE
EIGHTEEN MONTH CLOCK TO BEGIN
THAT ADDRESSES THE VERY
APPROACHED APPROACHES OF EACH
UTILITY.
CALIFORNIA'S CONTINUING TO
SUFFERS FROM THE WORST HOUSING
CRISIS IN THE STATE'S HISTORY IF
WE ARE TO SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
THE RATE AT WHICH NEW DWELLINGS
ARE CONSTRUCTED.
AND REDUCE THE COMMA ACOSTA
CONSTRUCTION WE NEED TO REDUCE
OR ELIMINATE COSTLY AVOIDABLE
THE DELAYS. FOR OVER THIRTY
YEARS STATE LAWS REQUIRED
BUILDERS TO COMPLY WITH FIRE AND
SAFETY BUILDING STANDARDS THAT
ARE IN EFFECT ON THE DATE THE
APPLICATION FOR A BUILDING
PERMIT IS SUBMITTED TO A LOCAL
BUILDING DEPARTMENT.
AB TEN TWENTY SIX MERELY SEEKS
TO ESTABLISH THE SAME LEVEL OF
CLARITY IN THE DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION OF UTILITY LINE
EXTENSIONS.
AS AS WELL AS THAT WHICH
CURRENTLY EXISTS FOR THE FIRE IN
LIFE -- LIFE SAFETY BUILDING
STANDARDS THIS BILL WOULD MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT ONCE AN ELECTRIC
OR GAS CORPORATION APPROVES THE
CONSTRUCTION DESIGN AND
SPECIFICATIONS.
THEY HAVE DETERMINED THE RULES
TO GO TO WHICH THE CONSTRUCTION
MUST COMPLY.
HERE TESTIFIED SUPPORT ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS RAW
ROB ROB RHYMER OF WITH C. B. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BOURZAT BOB BREMER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL -- WE'VE BEEN WORKING
VERY DILIGENTLY WITH THE
INDIVIDUAL UTILITIES -- UNLIKE A
BUILDING STANDARDS AND LOCAL
BUILDING DEPARTMENTS THE
ADMINISTRATION OF UTILITY LINE
EXTENSION RULES OF FOR EACH OF
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES IS
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT.
OF WHAT WE'RE SEEKING HERE IS TO
TRY TO FIND SOME A GENERIC
LANGUAGE THAT -- BASICALLY
ADDRESSES EVERYBODY'S ISSUES --
VERY QUICK SOLUTION OFFER SAN
DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC WOULD
POSSIBLY BE TO HAVE A A SEPARATE
PARAGRAPH REFERENCING THERE'S WE
SEEM TO HAVE AGREEMENT AMONGST
THE OTHERS WERE FINE WITH THAT.
SO WITH THAT THAT'S MY DESTINY.
VERY WELL ANYBODY ELSE --
SPEAKING IN FAVOR.
DO WE HAVE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU RICHARD DISABILITIES
VERY LOGICAL SO -- I WILL BE
OPPOSED [inaudible]
BOB.
BILL WHEN THE TIME IS IT WHEN
THE TIME IS GONNA COME WE HAVE
AN A A QUORUM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU WANNA MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS DISTURB RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I. BUT WHEN THE TIME
COMES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
A CERTAIN.
WHEN I WAS THE CHIEF OVERCOME
THEM I CALLED A FEW MINUTES AGO?
WE NEED AT ALL.
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
IT [inaudible]
WILL.
HEY GOOD MORNING THIS IS THE
SERGEANTS AND THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ABLE TO COME OVER THEN WE
DON'T HAVE AN OFFER
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY
.
IF YOU COULD JOIN.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING.
CARA MEMBERS.
GOOD MORNING TO TURN MEMBERS.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THAT WILL
ASSIST IN PROVIDING DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF HOMES DESTROYED BY WILDFIRE.
NUMEROUS FIRE SAFETY EXPERTS AND
ADVOCATES FOR NON COMBUSTIBLES
OWNED WITHIN FIVE FEET SORRY
ADVOCATED FOR THE NON
COMBUSTIBLE SO WITHIN FIVE FEET
OF A STRUCTURE.
AS AN EFFECTIVE WAY TO PROTECT
STRUCTURES SUCH AS YOU THE UC
DIVISION OF AGRICULTURAL NATURAL
RESOURCES.
A FORMER STATE FIRE MARSHAL AND
THE NATIONAL FIRE PROTECTION
ASSOCIATION.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY MORE PHASE AND
A NON COMBUSTIBLES ON ONE OF THE
THINGS WE LEARN FROM THE MOST
RECENT FIRES WAS THAT.
HAVING NON COMBUSTIBLE MATERIAL%
RIGHT AROUND THE STRUCTURE RIGHT
AROUND THE PERIMETER STRUCTURE.
IS ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
AREAS TEND TO KEEP CLEAR --
THERE WERE NUMEROUS EXAMPLES
WHERE ENTIRE LANDSCAPES DIDN'T
BURN NOTHING WAS WRONG WITH THE
TREES.
THE GRASS WAS INTACT BUT BECAUSE
SOMEONE HAD A PILE OF WOOD RIGHT
NEXT TO THEIR HOUSE FOR INSTANCE
OR THEY HAD VINES PLANTS ALL
OVER.
THERE BUILDING. ONE NUMBER.
HIT THAT COMBUSTIBLE AREA AND
WILL CAUSE THE LOSS OF THE
STRUCTURE SO WHAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THIS BILL DOES IT'S
IMPORTANT IS SET UP THIS NEW ONE
TO ZERO TO FIVE FEET NOT
COMBUSTIBLES ON WILL STILL
DETERMINE KIND OF WHAT WE THINK.
CAN BE PLANTED IN THAT AREA AND
WHAT COULDN'T BUT IT'LL GIVE
HOMEOWNERS A LOT MORE DIRECTION
AS TO THE IMPORTANCE OF KEEPING
THAT AREA CLEAR OF COMBUSTIBLE
MATERIAL TO THOSE PROPERTIES AT
BURNED A LOT OF THEM THOSE
HOUSES.
IT WASN'T A WALL OF FIRE THAT
TOOK THEM DOWN IT WAS NOT HAVING
THAT BEARD A FIVE FOOT NON
COMBUSTIBLE SOON SO THIS WILL
GIVE GUIDANCE TO PROPERTY OWNERS
AND ALSO TO INSPECTORS -- TO
HELP WITH THAT -- AB FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN WILL ALSO REQUIRE CAL
FIRE TO MEET ITS GOAL OF
INSPECTING EVERY KNOWN STRUCTURE
ONCE EVERY THREE YEARS.
EVEN FLLOWING IN THE PRESS HAS
BEEN A LOT OF REPORTS ABOUT HOW
FEW OF THESE STRUCTURES AND HIGH
HAZARD ZONES ARE CURRENTLY BEING
INSPECTED.
AND ONE OUT OF COMPLIANCE HOUSE
CAN PUT AN ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOOD
AT RISK SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE GET PEOPLE OUT IN THE
FIELD TO INSPECT. TO NOTIFY
HOMEOWNERS WHEN THEY HAVE
DANGEROUS CONDITIONS AND WE
CAN'T ASSUME THAT HOMEOWNERS NOW
I'M A HOMEOWNER AND A HIGH
HAZARD ZONE AND UNTIL IT SORT OF
DOING THIS WORK I HAD NO IDEA
THAT I HAD DANGEROUS CONDITIONS
ON MY OWN PROPERTY.
ACCORDING TO A NEW KQED
INVESTIGATION ONLY 70% OF
PROPERTIES IN THE TERRITORY WERE
CAL FIRE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
MONITORING DEFENSIBLE SPACE WERE
ACTUALLY CHECKED BY THEIR
INSPECTORS IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AB FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN WILL REQUIRE THE USE OF
RIGHT TREE RIGHT PLACE FOR
FUTURE PLANTING UNDER ELECTRICAL
LINES AND HIGH FIRED.
HAZARD AREAS THIS WILL REDUCE
UTILITY BUDGET SAY VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT COSTA WILDFIRES THIS
INCLUDES REQUIRING CAL FIRE TO
DEVELOP A GUIDE BOOK TO PROVIDE
LANDOWNERS I'M OPTIONS OF
VEGETATION.
THAT WILL NEVER GROW GROW INTO
ENERGIZED CONDUCTORS AND CAUSE
FIRES.
THE UTILITY ENFORCEMENT
PROVISIONS HAVE BEEN NARROWED TO
JUST A PILOT IN SDG ANY
TERRITORY.
AND WILL BE EVALUATED IN THEIR
WILD FIRE MITIGATION PLAN.
AND THE OTHER SERVICE
TERRITORIES UTILITIES CAN STILL
DO OUT REGION EDUCATION UNDER
THE LAW AND LOCALS AND CAL FIRE
CAN STILL IN FORCE IT.
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD I
SUPPORT CLARIFYING THAT THE GUY
WILL WILL BE DEVELOPED AS A
PUBLIC PROCESS.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS THE
SUPPORT OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY THE SIERRA CLUB --
THE RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS I
INDUSTRY THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY
AND S. T. G. ANY.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS MICHAEL DELEO SYSTEM
FORRESTER FOR SDG ANY I'M BOB
ROEMER.
SENIOR ENGINEER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
CENTERS ON BOB ROEMER -- WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED
TO DO A ME TOO FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.
THE FIRE HARDING BUILDING
STANDARDS -- WHICH WE PUT
TOGETHER BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT ARE INCREDIBLY AND
EFFECTIVE -- BUT THAT
EFFECTIVENESS DROP SIGNIFICANTLY
THEN THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE IS NOT
MAINTAINED AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN IS
ADDRESSING THAT ISSUE.
IT ALSO DIRECTS CALIFORNIA STATE
FARM MARSHALL A TO DEVELOP RULES
FOR THE NON COMBUSTIBLE ZONE
WHICH IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
THIS IS A FIVE FOOT PERIMETER.
AROUND THE STRUCTURE ITSELF AND
THIS IS EASILY ACCOMPLISHED ODD
ALSO PROHIBITS THE PLANTING OF
TREES UNDER POWER LINES AT WILL
WHEN THEY MATURE -- COME IN
CONTACT WITH THOSE POWER LINES I
REALIZE THAT MAY SEEM OBVIOUS
BUT IT IT HAPPENS QUITE
REGULARLY OUT THERE.
LASTLY THE BILL DIRECTS CAL FIRE
AND A HOST OF OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
A TO DEVELOP A RISK ANALYSIS
TOOL.
THIS CONCEPT IS SOMEONE AND NOW
JUST TO THE HOME ENERGY RATING
TOOL THAT'S ALREADY OUT THERE
AND WILL BE INCREDIBLY HELPFUL --
IN HELPING US TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO MITIGATE FAR RISK IN BOTH NEW
AND ESPECIALLY EXISTING
DEVELOPMENTS.
LASTLY AB FIFTEEN SIXTEENS VERY
COMPLEMENT OR DO A HOST OF OTHER
BILLS -- ICLUDING SENATOR --
DODDS -- SP -- ONE NINETY THE
TRAINING AND EDUCATION BILL
THAT'S OUT THERE SO WITH THAT AS
MUCH AS ANY QUESTIONS -- MORE
MATURE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MICHAEL DELAY ON THE SYSTEM
FORSTER FOR SENEGAL GAS ELECTRIC
UP AN EMPLOYEE. FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS I MAY ASSIST HER FRONT
ARBORIST AND UTILITIES
SPECIALIST -- I WILL BRIEFLY
SPEECH ABOUT TODAY ABOUT THE
CONCEPT OF RIGHT TO REPLACE ITS
BENEFITS AND HOW THIS MEASURE
WILL HELP.
CALIFORNIANS WE ALL ARE LIVE IN
THE NEW NORM OF EXTREME WILDFIRE
RISK AND WE ALL HAVE A ROLE TO
PLAY WITH THAT -- NOT ONLY THE
UTILITIES BUT ALSO LOCAL
AGENCIES -- STATE AGENCIES AND
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS SO ONE VERY
HELPFUL THING THAT CUSTOMERS CAN
DO WHEN THEY'RE CONSIDERING
TREES TO PLAN A LANDSCAPE.
IS THE APPROPRIATE TREES
RELATIVE TO POWER LINES SO THIS
MEASURE WILL DEVELOP OF GUIDE
BOOK THAT WILL HELP ASSIST
CUSTOMERS AND MAKING THOSE
CHOICES -- THIS POLICIES CALLED
THE RIGHT TO REPLACE THIS IS
CERTAINLY NOT A UNIQUE CONCEPT
TO SD GINNY.
IS A A CONCEPT IN A POLICY
THAT'S FOLLOWED BY ALL THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND A D. THROUGHOUT THE NATION
AND INTERNATIONAL.
SB GINNY CURRENTLY ENCOURAGES
CUSTOMERS TO FOLLOW THIS CONCEPT
OF RIGHT TREE RIGHT PLACE
THROUGH ONE ONE CONTACT.
THROUGH OUR CONTRACTORS AND
INTERNALLY.
AND ALSO THROUGH OUR WEBSITE AND
THROUGH COLLATERAL LIKE HANDLES.
SO PLANNING DIRECTOR IN OUR
PLACE IS -- PROVIDES MANY MANY
BENEFITS ONCE BRIEFLY GO OVER
THOSE INCREASES WORKER SAFETY
AND PUBLIC SAFETY -- BY NOT
HAVING SOMEONE IN THE TREE
PRUNING TREES NEAR POWER LINES.
IT ALLOWS THE TREES TO REACH
THEIR FULL MATURE HEIGHT AND ALL
THE ANCILLARY BENEFITS.
CARBON SEQUESTRATION OXYGEN
RELEASE SHADE AND ALSO -- THE
JUST THE BEAUTY OF THE TREES ARE
THE AESTHETICS SKEWS ME.
THE PRESERVES THE HEALTH OF THE
TREE BY ELIMINATING UNNECESSARY
PRUNING IT REDUCES THE FUEL
CAPACITY IF THERE'S A FIRE.
IT ALSO REDUCES REPAIRS EXPENSE
PLAN NECESSARY TRIMMING. TWENTY
SIXTEEN WOULD CREATE THIS RIGHT
TREE RIGHT PLACE GUIDEBOOK AGAIN.
GIVE CUSTOMERS GUIDANCE ON HOW
TO DO THE TRIMMING OF THE PROPER
TREES TO PLAN YOUR POWER LINES
THERE ALSO WOULD ESTABLISH A
STATE WHAT POLICY.
THAT CUSTOMERS WOULD NEED TO
FOLLOW JUST TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE REDUCING THE CHANCE OF FIRE
WERE FROM WHENEVER POSSIBLE.
FOLLOWING RIGHT YOU'RE RIGHT
PLACE GUIDELINES IS VERY
POSITIVE PROACTIVE ACTIVITY.
THE PRIVATE LANDOWNER CAN ENGAGE
IN TO ASSIST WITH MEDICAID
WILDFIRE RISK.
MESSAGING USING COMPLETE SUPPORT
OF ESTABLISHING THIS NEW STATE
POLICY THROUGH A. B..
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU -- SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT PLEASE -- JULIE ALLEN
OWSKI BALL IN THE HALF OF THE
MID PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS YOU SO
ELEVEN SALAS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AS NOTED BY THE
AUTHOR WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN WE THINK
HER FOR HER ONGOING WORK ON THIS
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS KAREN MILLS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION JUST HERE TODAY TO
CLARIFY THAT ALL THE WAY IT
ADDED -- OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL THAT WERE
NEUTRAL NOW AND APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS WORKING WITH THIS TO
RECOGNIZE THE DIFFERENT CATEGORY
THAT WELL MAINTAINED ORCHARDS.
FALL INTO IN CONSIDERING FIRE
SAFETY AND VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE AUTHORS RECOGNITION OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF DEVELOPING THE
GUIDE BOOK IN A PUBLIC PROCESS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU. TO HAVE
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER I WANT TO THANK
SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC.
FOR SETTING THE TONE.
SETTING THE MODEL I WANT TO
THANK YOU.
MISTER VALLEJO -- I'M JUST
CURIOUS ARE RE GOING TO ASSUME
THAT CAL FIRE AND THE CPUC
YOU'RE GONNA.
FINISH YOUR KEEP UP TO DATE THE
FIRE MAPS.
SO I I'VE I THINK THE FOR THE
FARM MAPS WERE DEVELOPED IN
CONJUNCTION.
WITH -- THE DEVELOPING A VHF TV
ARE CERTAINLY THE MOST LATEST
AND I THINK UP TO DATE.
THEY TAKE INTO ACCOUNT A
SPECIFIC METRICS THAT WERE USED
TO DEVELOP A STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA.
THAT IS LOOKING AT FIRE HISTORY --
FUELS ACROSS THE LANDSCAPE AND
THE PROPENSITY OF VEGETATION TO
BURN SO YES I WOULD EXPECT THAT
THAT.
THAT MEASURE WILL CONTINUE -- WE
HAVE OUR OWN SPECIFIC
NEUROLOGISTS AND AND FAR CORNERS
ON STAFF IT ACTUALLY HELPED IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE MOST
LATEST.
FIRE BOUNDARIES AS IT PERTAINS
TO THE HEART OUR THIRD DISTRICT
WHICH THE CPC ADOPTED.
MY AS OF BEFORE THE TWO MAJOR
FIRES THEY DIDN'T WORKING FOR
EIGHT YEARS AND HAD NOT
COMPLETED THEM SO WAS.
REALLY FRUSTRATING SO.
I'M JUST HOPING CEBU SEEING CAL
FIRE CAN BE HELPFUL.
IN THIS FIRE HAZARDS SEVERITY
ZONE -- IT WOULD MOVE WE HAVE
TEARS IS IS THIS A UNIQUE.
TOP TIER OR IS IT.
NORMAL NOMENCLATURE SO THE SO
THE APPLICABILITY OF AB FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN WOULD BE. FOR THE STATE
HIGH FIRE THREAD DISTRICTS WHICH
WAS A DETERMINED BY CPC IN
CONJUNCTION WITH CAL FIRE IN THE
FIRE EXPERTS.
AND THIS THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA WHICH SHOWS
FOR DICTATES THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR IF YOU WOULD
LOOK AT A MAP.
THOSE TERRITORIES ESSENTIALLY
OVERLAY AND EIGHT THE SHARE
ALMOST COMPLETE -- A BOUNDARY OF
COMMONALITY BOUNDARY WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF SOME PORTIONS OF
THE STATE RESPONSIBILITY AREA
THAT FALL OUTSIDE THE H. OF TV.
AND WE WE WOULD HAVE A CONCERN
THAT THIS BILL WOULD NOT INCLUDE
THE STATE RESPONSE VERY BECAUSE
THERE ARE.
PORTIONS OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY
THEY JUST HAVE THE THE
DEFINITION OF A STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA BUT ARE
EXTREMELY HIGH FIRE THREAT AREAS
AND WHAT COMES TO MIND TO ME IS.
A RANCHO SANTA FE WHICH IS ONE
OF THE MOST -- A DENSELY
EUCALYPTUS GROVE ENCLAVES AND
SEND YOU A SAN DIEGO -- AND IT'S
SOME OF THE HIGHEST PROPERTY
VALUE IN OUR COUNTY SO WE WOULD
ENDORSE RETAINING THE HF TV AND
THE US ARE A WITHIN THIS BILL.
YET YES SENATOR AL IN RESPONSE
DIRECTLY TO YOUR QUESTION -- SB.
ONE EIGHTY TWO DIRECTS THE FIRE
MARSHAL CALIFORNIA UPDATE THE
MAPS.
ANA END -- THERE ALREADY IS
ALREADY THE AUTHORITY FOR A
LOCAL JURISDICTION TO APPLY A
MORE RIGOROUS STANDARDS -- AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR CLIMATIC
GEOLOGICAL TOPOGRAPHIC FIRE
SAFETY IS ONE THE MOST COMMON
LOCAL MODIFICATIONS -- TO CITY
CODE.
THERE WAS SB ONE EIGHTY ONE SB
ONE EIGHTY TWO JACKSON.
A LOOK OF THAT -- RANCHO SANTA
FE -- WE REALIZE THAT EUCALYPTUS
TREES DON'T MAKE GOOD RAILROAD
TIES [inaudible]
BUT I'M NOT CONCERNED ABOUT A
NEIGHBORHOOD LIKE THAT BUT I'M
CONSIDER ABOUT IN A NEIGHBORHOOD
THAT MIGHT BE.
LOWER IN THE ECONOMIC -- CYCLE
OF THE CIRCUITRY OR WHATEVER YOU
KNOW.
THE GRASS AND THEY WOULD SAY
WAIT A SECOND CAN YOU CHANGE OUR
RATING.
BECAUSE WE CAN'T AFFORD TO MAKE
THESE CHANGES IT.
IS THAT IS OUR POTENTIAL THERE
FOR SOMEONE SO.
WE CAN AFFORD TO BE IN THIS EVEN
THOUGH WE ARE IS OUR OR OR IS
THIS IS JUST COMPLETELY SET BY
THE CPUC AND AND CAL FIRE.
NOT NOT REALLY -- AND THAT'S ONE
OF THE BEAUTIES OF THE RISK
ANALYSIS TOOL THAT'S BEING
DEVELOPED HERE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
SORT OF A ONE DIMENSIONAL Là
MAP IT SAYS YOU'RE IN A GOOD
PLACE OR BAD PLACE -- THE RISK
ANALYSIS TOOL TAKES THAT SORT OF
INTO A THREE DIMENSIONAL
THRESHOLD WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING
AT THE FIRE HARDING OF THE
BUILDING THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
AND THEN LOOK AT JURISDICTION
LAWYERS ISSUES.
OF FIRE RESOURCE -- PERSONNEL
MANAGEMENT -- BASICALLY -- IT
WILL FINALLY BE A TOOL WHERE
INSURANCE AND AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS VARIETY REASON AND
THE HOMEOWNERS CAN BASICALLY
COME AND USE THAT TOOL AND
FIGURE OUT HOW TO INCREASE THE
FIRE PROTECTION OF THE DWELLING.
FOR THE LEAST COST THE BIGGEST
BANG FOR THE BUCK IS OW THIS
TOOLS CAN WORK GREAT.
THANK YOU FOR LET ME FLEX SOME
OF THIS OUT BUT YOU REALLY THINK
THE CPUC IS GOING TO GET.
THAT HANDBOOK OUT IN A
REASONABLE AMOUNT OF TIME IT.
I'M SORRY BUT I CYNICAL BUT I I
I I UNDERSTAND THAT -- IN THE
SECTOR IS THE LOCAL FIRE SERVICE
WILL HAVE ACCESS TO ALL THIS
WHICH MEANS LOCAL CITIES --
COUNCILS AND THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS AS WELL.
AND SO -- I I THINK WITH THE
INDUSTRY'S INPUT -- EVERYBODY'S
HAPPILY LOOKING AT AT MOVING
THIS INTO PLACES BROAD SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL AND SO I I THINK
WITH THAT IN MIND THAT THE PC IS
PROBABLY GOING TO RUN INTO VERY
LITTLE.
OPPOSITION TO DO SOMETHING WHICH
QUITE FRANKLY SO OBVIOUS AND
WE'RE PROBABLY GOING TO ASK YOU
HAVE CAL FIRE COME BACK TO US IN
A FEW MONTHS AND WE NEED MORE
STAFF.
I'M JUST WONDERING CAN CAL FIRE.
CONTRACT OUT THIS REVIEW SAID
HAVE YET YES ALL PLEDGE
FIREFIGHTER.
I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT THAT UP IN
THE ANSWER IS YES -- RIGHT NOW
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THERE'S A
SYSTEM OF FIRE SAFE COUNCILS
THROUGH I'M THERE'S DOZENS AND
DOZENS OF THESE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
ALREADY MAKING GOOD USE AND
INDEED THE STATE CAN CONTRACT
OUT AND DOES -- WITH THESE LOCAL
FIRE SAFE COUNCILS.
I WILL ADD THAT MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE ADEQUATE MONEY.
IN THE BUDGET AS A AS THE
GOVERNOR PRIORITIZES WILDFIRE
ACROSS THE STATE -- PUTTING
MONEY INTO THESE AREAS INTO THE
FIRE SAFE COUNCILS AND ALL OF
THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS IS
ESSENTIAL SO WE WOULD LOVE TO
SEE.
MORE RESOURCES AGO TOWARDS THIS
WORK RIGHT I JUST DON'T WANT TO
SEE HIGH POWERED FIREFIGHTERS
YOU KNOW.
DOING NEIGHBORHOOD YEAH YEAH NOW
THAT THIS IN BACKYARD REVIEWS
AND SO THERE'S OTHER GROUPS THAT
CAN HANDLE THANK YOU MISTER
ROEMER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I'LL MOVE THE BILL.
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU WANT TO MAKE IT.
JUST I APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE ROOM.
I'M SO SORRY [inaudible]
YEAH
.
HOW DID I MISS YOU? ONE IS YOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT THEIR PROBLEM.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU -- AND
MEMBERS -- THIS MEASURE.
WAS INTRODUCED IN RESPONSE TO
THE PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC.
JANUARY TWENTY NINTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN FILING FOR
CHAPTER ELEVEN BANKRUPTCY.
LAST SESSION IN COLLABORATION
WITH MEMBERS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SB NINE A ONE SENATOR DODD'S
BILL ENTITLED THE WILDFIRE
PROTECTION ACT WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW.
SB NINE OH ONE SET INTO MOTION A
SERIES OF CRITICAL ACTIONS THAT
ARE THE PUBLIC UTILITY
COMMISSION.
HAS BEEN MANDATED TO UNDERTAKE
INCLUDING OVERSEEING THE
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
WHILE FIRE MITIGATION PLANS.
NOT LONG AFTER THE PASSAGE OF
THAT MEASURE DEVASTATING AND
DEADLY FIRE CONSUME THE TOWN OF
PARADISE.
AND OTHER NEARBY COMMUNITIES
LEAVING A PATH OF DESTRUCTION
AND DEATH.
CALIFORNIA HAS NOW CONFIRMED
THAT THE CAP WAS IN FACT CAUSED
BY ELECTRICAL TRANSMISSION LINES
OWNED AND OPERATED BY PACIFIC
GAS AND ELECTRIC.
P. GENIES BANKRUPTCY HAS CAUSED
UNCERTAINTY AROUND THE FUTURE.
OF THE UTILITY AND IMPORTANTLY
THE ABILITY OF WHILE FOR
SURVIVORS AND THE FAMILIES OF
THOSE WHO LOST LOVED ONES. TO
RECEIVE THEIR JUST RECOMMENDS.
EMPLOYEES AND RETIREES WHO ARE
FINANCIALLY RELIED UPON THE
STABILITY OF A UTILITY OF HAD.
THAT REALITY SHATTERED.
CONTRACTS FOR RENEWABLES THAT
ARE ENABLING CALIFORNIA TO REACH
OUR CLIMATE GOALS ARE THREATENED.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT IT WILL
LIKELY BE APPROXIMATELY TWO
YEARS FOR PGA A REORGANIZATION
PLAN TO BE FINALIZED BY THE
COURT.
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA RELY
UPON THE CPUC TO REPRESENT OUR
BEST INTERESTS AND REGULATORY
REFORMS AND NOW IN THIS
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDING.
ACR SEVENTY EIGHT CALLS UPON THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND FILINGS WITH THE
UNITED STATES BANKRUPTCY COURT.
TO ENSURE THAT SURVIVORS AND
RATE PAYERS ARE TREATED FAIRLY.
STRICT COMPLIANCE WITH WHILE
FIRE MITIGATION PLAN.
SUPPORT RANK AND FILE EMPLOYEES.
MAINTAIN STABLE AND RELIABLE
ELECTRICITY MARKETS.
ARTICULATING THE LEGISLATURE'S
PRIORITIES TO THE CPUC THE CPUC
WILL MORE CLEARLY BE POSITION
THROUGHOUT THAT LEGAL PROCESS TO
REPRESENT.
THE BEST INTERESTS OF CALIFORNIA.
FOR THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON ACR.
SEVENTY OKAY VERY WELL DO WE
HAVE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR SERVICE
WE'RE GOOD.
GOODBYE.
YOUR HUESO MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE
I'M JANICE BUT THE JONES WITH
THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS
ASSOCIATION -- WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES -- REPRESENT
THE REAL ENERGY -- AS WELL AS
RELIABILITY -- THE PROJECTS TO
KEEP THE LIGHTS ON AND HAVE
REACHED SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE
CARBON IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- THE IMPORTANCE OF
WILL BE -- OF HONORING THE
CONTRACTS FOR THOSE PROJECTS IS --
A VERY IMPORTANT BOTH FOR THE
BENEFIT OF WILDFIRE VICTIMS --
AT THE REJECTED THAT CREATES A
PROBLEM THERE AND ALSO FOR US TO
MEET OUR FUTURE GOALS SO WE
WOULD URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS TO MANY
HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE SOLAR
ENERGY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION A
LARGE SCALE SOLAR ASSOCIATION.
AND THE AMERICAN WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CAUCUS
INSTRUCTS SUPPORT WE THANK
CHAIRMAN HOLDEN FOR HIS
CONTINUED EFFORTS ON OUR BEHALF.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO MOVING
THIS ISSUE THROUGH AN AND
ACTUALLY GETTING THROUGH THE
BANKRUPTCY PROCESS SAFELY THANK
YOU.
MELISSA CORTEZ ROB ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT ONE ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES.
MARK.
MARK TONY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
TURN UTILITY REFORM NETWORK.
WE WANT TO AVOID A REPEAT OF THE
TWO THOUSAND AND ONE BANKRUPTCY.
WERE RATE PAYERS WERE FORCED TO
PAY SEVEN BILLION EXTRA DOLLARS
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OF A FEW ARE.
SEVENTY VERY WELL ANY OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
YES SIR THANK YOU MEASURE I
THANK YOUR SUMMER HOLDEN -- BEEN
A CRAZY WEEK -- SO I SPENT TIME
OVER THE WEEKEND JUST POURING-OVER THE P. JEANNIE FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS JUST TO SEE.
HOW THEY OPERATE WHERE WE CAN
FIND CASH?
KNOW WHAT THIS BANKRUPTCY JUDGES
GUY GO THROUGH.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT I'VE BEEN
THROUGH A BANKRUPTCY WITH ORANGE
COUNTY AND I WAS THE CREDITOR
COMMITTEE CHAIR FOR EDISON.
TWENTY YEARS AGO WHEN ALL THIS
FUN HAPPEN WHEN P. JEANNIE DID
FILE FOR THE FIRST CHAPTER.
ELEVEN SO.
PLAYING A LITTLE BIT.
DATE THEY GENERATE SEVENTEEN
BILLION IN REVENUES A YEAR.
THEY HAVE NET INCOME OF TWO
BILLION.
HALF OF THAT ONE BILLION GOES TO
BONDHOLDERS HE'S STILL HAVE ONE
BILLION LEFT TO PLAY WITH.
AND THEY HAVE TO DO ABOUT THREE
BILLION FOR HARDENING THEY HAVE
TO DO ABOUT ONE AND A HALF
BILLION MINIMUM. TO PAY OFF THE
VICTIMS IF THEY FINANCE THAT --
WHICH MEANS OBVIOUSLY NO
DIVIDENDS SO GRANDMOTHERS WILL
BE AFFECTED BECAUSE THEY BY
UTILITY STOCKS -- AS A SIMPLE
COUPON CLIPPING KIND OF THING --
AND IT'S GONNA BE REAL DIFFICULT
FOR THEM TO ISSUE MORE STOCK AND
AND AND DEBTS OVER WE'RE NOT OUT
OF THE WOODS.
BUT THERE'S VERY FEW AREAS FOR
THEM.
TO TRY AND SQUEEZE OUT SOME CASH
SO -- ARE OMINOUS SUPPORT.
THIS [inaudible]
RESOLUTION BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT
A FEDERAL JUDGE'S GONNA DO WITH
THE RESOLUTION BECAUSE THIS IS
CERTAINLY -- ACCORDION NOT.
AND THE ONLY THING WE REALLY
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT IS IF WE GET
ANOTHER CONFLAGRATION AND THEN
EVERYTHING GOES CRAZY.
THEY WERE REALLY STUCK SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR RESOLUTION
AND NOT FROM A COMMOTION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR [inaudible]
VERY WELL [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
DID YOU WANNA MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS.
I JUST WANTED TO CONCUR WITH --
WITH THE SENATOR OUTLINED THIS
IS A A SITUATION WHERE A WE HAVE
LIMITED ABILITY TO INFLUENCE THE
COURT.
AND IT'S ONLY THROUGH THE PC AS
OUR LI CREDIT AS OF THE THE LEAD
FOR THE STATE AND REPRESENTING
OUR INTERESTS THAT WE CAN GIVE
SOME CLARITY -- TERMS OF HOW
THIS LEGISLATURE BELIEVES THE
PRIORITY SHOULD BE ESTABLISHED
IN THE CONVERSATION.
ULTIMATELY THE THE COURT IS
GOING TO DO IT IT'S GOING TO DO
BUT WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT.
THE PRIORITIES THAT WE BELIEVE
ARE IMPORTANT TO MOVE FORWARD ON
AND SUPPORTING A VICTIMS IN
SUPPORTING OUR RATE PAYERS --
AND THEN -- ALL OF THE
PRIORITIES THAT WE THINK ARE
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE.
THAT THOSE BE HELD -- HI IN AND
VOICE VIGOROUSLY IN THE
PROCEEDINGS.
AND WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
VERY WELL OF WE DON'T HAVE A
COMMIT BUT AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME [inaudible] ONE MORE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE.
WHAT WAS THAT -- I YEAH IT WAS
TOUGH LAST NIGHT BUT WE MADE IT
RIGHT THROUGH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING THE TERROR AND
CENTERS I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT ON PAGE FOUR OF THE
ANALYSIS AND I LIKE TO THINK
THAT CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE.
A STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
MEASURE.
AB TENNEY THREE AUTHORIZED
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
REQUEST AN ANALYSIS BY THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON SCIENCE
AND TECHNOLOGY ARE CCSD.
ON THE ON PROPOSED MEASURES
DEALING WITH ENERGY PROCUREMENT
AND INFRASTRUCTURE MANDATES.
CCSD WOULD PROVIDE A WRITTEN AND
ONLY REPORT THAT SHOWSTHE
POTENTIAL EFFECTS THAT RELEVANT
LEGISLATION CAN HAVE ON REPAIRS.
THE ECONOMY JOB MARKET THE
ELECTRICAL GRID OR GAS
DELIVERING SYSTEMS AND WHETHER
THE LEGISLATION IS THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE MEANS TO ACHIEVE THE
DESIRED OUTCOME.
THE AMENDMENT SUGGESTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES ONE
CORPORATE BENEFITS INTO THE
REPORT PROVIDED BY CCS HE WHICH
CAN INCLUDE BENEFITS R. COSTA
COMMUNITIES DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED.
BY ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION AND
HAZARDS AS WELL AS BENEFITS
AROUND PUBLIC HEALTH
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY AND CLAIM
INSTABILITY.
THE NOW SAYS BY CCS TIãU WILL
BE COMPLETED WITHIN SIXTY DAYS
OR WITHIN AN AGREED UPON TIME
FRAME BETWEEN THE COUNCIL AND
THE REQUESTER.
CCS HE WILL ESTABLISH A PRIVATE
FUND TO COLLECT MONEY TO FUND
THE ANALYSIS THEY WOULD
UNDERTAKE AND UTILITY REPAIRS
WOULD NOT BE ASSESSED A FEE. TO
CARRY OUT THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
MEASURE.
I AM COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE CSE TO HELP FIND FUNDING
SOURCES TO PAY FOR THE REVIEWS
REQUIRED BY THIS BILL EIGHT AB
TEN EIGHTY THREE WILL PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL TOOL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE DETERMINE POTENTIAL
IMPACTS TO REPAIRS.
AS BILLS MOVE THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
ON THIS BILL IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TONIGHT.
CINNAMON AND YOU MENTIONED YOU
ACCEPT THE MAN YES.
VERY WELL -- YOU HAVE SPEAKERS
THAT ARE PART OF YOUR
PRESENTATION.
YEAH CAN HOUSE WITH SAN DIEGO
GAS ELECTRIC IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL -- CURRENTLY WE COLLECT
ABOUT NINE HUNDRED SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FROM
CUSTOMERS TO SUPPORT MANDATED
PROGRAMS THAT'S ABOUT 25% OF OUR
TOTAL REVENUE THAT COMES IN.
WE THINK THIS BILL IS VERY
IMPORTANT IN SHEDDING SOME LIGHT
ON THE COST OF THE MANDATES THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CONTINUES TO
DISCUSS.
AND WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
OKAY.
I ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
WE NEED SOME SOUND.
GOOD MORNING TESTING AT THE IS
THERE ARE THERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT.
PATRICK WELL TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
IN THE MODERN HAVE THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER THIRTY
IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE A QUORUM CLICK WITH YOUR
STYLISH -- COULD YOU.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
HUESO HERE WITH SO HEAR MORE LOT
PRESENT MORE LIKE PRESENT
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE CHIANG DIED
HERTZBERG HILL MCGUIRE RUBIO.
THE HERE SKINNER STERN.
STERN HERE STONE.
DOWN HERE WINNER.
WIENER HERE.
OKAY VERY WELL A DO WE HAVE
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
DID A COMMITTEE MEMBERS WANT TO
MAKE ANY COMMENTS THANK YOU MR
PRINGLE JIMMY JUST ONE QUICK
QUESTION IS THE FIRST TIME I'VE.
ADD A TOUCH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL ON SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY SO.
TO DO WE DO A BILL FOR THEM
EVERY YEAR [inaudible]
FIRST KNOWN.
NO NO WE DON'T DO A BILL FOR
THEM WHAT KIND OF BILL I DON'T
KNOW I KNOW BUT I JUST HAVEN'T
SEEN IT BUT OUR SO I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT IF WE NEED A CAN TO
RENEW THE HE FACT THAT.
SOMEHOW WE STARTED THIS
ORGANIZATION THIRTY YEARS AGO
AND I I DON'T THINK SO I THINK
THEY'RE HAPPILY EXISTING.
USING YOUR VOLUNTEER TO RAISE
THE MONEY FOR THIS FOR THIS AND
HOW DO YOU PLAN ON DOING -- WORK
WILL CONTINUE TO TALK TO THE TO
LADIES AND TO BUDGET.
AND TO SEE CSU TO FIGURE OUT THE
BEST WAY TO DO THAT ARE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OF THE THANK YOU [inaudible]
WITH SINISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU A SEVEN MEMBER I WAS
HOPING CAN YOU RESPOND TO SOME
OF THE THE COMMENTS IN OUNCES I
I KNOW STATE LATER ABOUT YOUR
BENEFITS ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
THE YEAH YEAH IF IT'S QUESTION
THIS YEAR CLUB AND AND C. B. D.
RAZOR SO WE ARE CLEAR TO ME. TWO
WEEKS AT LEAST.
I'M TIRED WEEKS AFTER THE MOMENT.
A MOMENT SINGER I KNOW I'M THE
MAN AND SUGGESTED AND WE'RE
INCORPORATING THE BENEFITS ON
WHICH WILL INCLUDE -- BENEFITS
R. COSTA COMMUNITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION AND
HAZARDS AS WELL AS BENEFITS
AROUND PUBLIC HEALTH
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY AND CLIMB
INSTABILITY.
THERE IT IS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
BUT I NEED TO HEAR.
I'LL BE SUPPORT THANK YOU YEAH.
WELL TO YOU ON MY CLOSING
COMMENTS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I HAVE A VERY.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER STONE.
AND CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL --
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR WEST SO I WAS SO I MORE
LOT.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
CHIANG DODD HERTZBERG HILL
MCGUIRE RUBIO.
I RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN STERN
AYE STONE.
I'VE DONE AYE WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER AYE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YES.
THAT BILL WILL BE HELD ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HAVE A GREAT DAY --
WE'RE GONNA NOW THAT WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
CAN I ENTER HAVE A COULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON ITEM THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD A. B.
TEN TWENTY SIX WE HAVE A MOTION.
BY US CENTER MORE LARK A CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL I DIDN'T
UNDER NUMBER THREE AB TEN TWENTY
SIX WOULD DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
WEST SO.
I WAS SO I MORE LOT MORE LIKE
AYE BRADFORD CHIANG DIED
HERTZBERG HILL MCGUIRE RUBIO
[inaudible]
SKINNER STERN STERN ICE DOWN.
DOWN AYE WIENER -- BUT WITH HER.
LIFE.
WIENER AYE [inaudible]
RUBIO AYE [inaudible]
THAT'S ONE SEVEN WHEN.
MIKE MADE A MOTION LAST TIME
WITH SEPARATE ON ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN OKAY ON ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
MOORE Là.
CLARK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN FRIEDMAN DO PAST
APPROPRIATIONS WEST SO.
I WAS SO I AM MORE LOT MORE LIKE
AYE BRADFORD CHIANG DIED
HERTZBERG HILL MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN.
STONE.
STONE AYE WIENER I'M SORRY WHICH
ONE IS. SEVEN FIVE ASTRONOMICAL
I'M SORRY.
STERN AYE.
WIENER AYE.
AND THEN WE HAVE NUMBER.
NINE ON THE NUMBER.
ON ITEM NUMBER NINE ACR SEVENTY
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDER WITH A
MOTION BY CENTER MORE LUCK.
CLERK PLEASE CALL [inaudible]
THE ROLE. TO BE ADOPTED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WEST SO.
I HUESO ARMAR LOT MORE LIKE AYE
BRADFORD CHIANG DIED HERTZBERG
HILL MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN.
EARN ICE DOWN STONE AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
CASE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
I PROMISE I WON'T PLANET
[inaudible]
VIDEO GAMES
WITH [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH
.
THE MORNING AS CHAIR NAP
SENATORS.
HERE TO PRESENT AB.
FIFTY SIX WE FIFTIES THE FIFTY
SIX ON THE CURRENT LAW.
PC HOLDS IT ALREADY TO ORDER
BACKSTOP PROCUREMENT FOR
RESOURCE ADEQUACY AND INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLANNING BY THE I USE
ON BEHALF OF THE ENTIRE SYSTEM.
AB FIFTY SIX SIMPLY ALLOWS A PC
TO RELY ON PUBLIC ENTITY TO
SERVE AS A BACKSTOP.
INSTEAD OF THE I. O. USE.
THIS PUBLIC ENTITY WOULD
FUNCTION JUST LIKE OTHER
UTILITIES AND WILL PROVIDE A
STABLE TRANSPARENT BACKSTOP FOR
PROCUREMENT.
IN TIMES OF NEED.
A STATE ENTITY WILL PROTECT RATE
PAYERS WHILE ALSO ENSURING WE
STAY ON TRACK WITH OUR POOR
RELIABILITY STANDARDS AND
CLIMATE GOALS.
WE'VE HEARD FROM A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS THAT THIS IS AN
ANTI CC A BILL.
THAT WILL ELIMINATE THEIR
ABILITY TO SELF PARK HERE.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR THIS IS
NOT.
A VALID WHAT THE BILL IS --
WRITTEN TO DO.
IN FACT THE BILL DOES NOTHING TO
EXPAND CURRENT PC OF FORTY TO
DIRECT A PROCUREMENT AND DOES
NOT CHANGE THE CURRENT RIGHTS
CCA'S HAVE.
THE SELF PROCURE.
AND NOT PASSING THIS BILL TODAY
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR -- MEANS
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE USING THE
I USE AS A BACKSTOP ENTITIES
SOMETHING THAT MANY RATE PAYERS
ENVIRONMENTAL AND CONSUMER
CHOICE ADVOCATES WOULD ALSO
OPPOSE.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
CONCEPT BEHIND THIS BILL FOR
ALMOST A YEAR.
AS THE GOVERNOR STRIKE FORCE
REPORT CONCLUDES THE TIME TO ACT
IS NOW.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL
[inaudible] TO WITNESS. TO MY
RIGHT.
NICE CAMPAIGN.
I MEAN YOU COREGONUS PRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MATT
FRIEDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK.
WE'RE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT AS
A ONE OF THE SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY
POLICY IS CURRENTLY AT A
CROSSROADS WITH THE RISE A
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATION AND
INCREASES IN DIRECT ACCESS.
THIS IS GOING TO MEAN A SMALLER
ROLE FOR THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES GOING FORWARD BUT
EXISTING LAW PLACES THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES IN THE ROLE OF
CONDUCTING FAX STOP PROCUREMENT.
FOR BOTH RELIABILITY AND
RESOURCE PLANNING PURPOSES UNDER
EXISTING LAW THE P. YOU SEE CAN
DIRECT THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES TO FILL DEFICITS UNDER
THE RESOURCE ADEQUACY AN
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
PROGRAMS.
AND TO CHARGE CUSTOMERS.
ACROSS THE ENTIRE SYSTEM FOR
THAT PROCUREMENT INCLUDING THOSE
SERVE BY CCA'S AND DIRECT ACCESS
PROVIDERS.
ON THE NEED FOR ACTION TODAY ON
LET ON BACKSTOPS CHAIRMAN IS NOT
HYPOTHETICAL OR SPECULATIVE.
THE P. YOU SEE HAS RECENTLY
BEGUN TO IMPLEMENT THE BACKSTOP
PROCUREMENT MECHANISM AUTHORIZED
BY THE LEGISLATURE AS PART OF SB
THREE FIFTY THAT APPLIES TO THE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
PROGRAM.
I'M ABSENT THE TOOLS PROVIDED IN
AB FIFTY SIX THE E. INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES WILL BE THE ONLY
UTILITIES THE ONLY ENTITIES.
THAT CAN BE DIRECTED TO PERFORM
THESE BACKSTOPS FUNCTIONS.
BUT THE I'LL USE ARE FACING
CREDIT CHALLENGES AS EVERYONE
HERE KNOWS ALL TOO WELL AND
SOMEONE TO GET OUT OF
PROCUREMENT ENTIRELY.
OTHER LOAD SERVING ENTITIES SUCH
AS THE CCA'S HAVE STRONGLY
OPPOSED EFFORTS TO SIGN ANY
BACKSTOP PROCUREMENT TO THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES.
THE NEED FOR COORDINATED
RESOURCE AND RELIABILITY
PLANNING IS GREATER THAN EVER
AND THE FAILURE TO MAINTAIN
STATE OVERSIGHT AND HAVE A
RATIONAL STRATEGY COULD SET THE
STAGE FOR THE NEXT ENERGY CRISIS.
IN RESPONSE AB FIFTY SIX WOULD
CREATE A PUBLIC STATE
JURISDICTIONAL BACKSTOP THEY CAN
BE USED TO ASSIST IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF KEY POLICY
OBJECTIVES.
SPECIFICALLY THE MECHANICS OF AB
FIFTY SIX WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE ENERGY
AND ADVANCE TRANSPORTATION
FINANCING AUTHORITY TO SERVE AS
THE BACKSTOP PROCUREMENT IT FOR
SPECIFIC RELIABILITY AND
RESOURCE PLANNING PURPOSES.
ALREADY DEFINED IN EXISTING LAW.
IT ALLOWS KATE FOR THE SANITY TO
SERVE AS A VOLUNTARY PROCUREMENT
ENTITY UNDER THE OUR PS PROGRAM
WHICH OPERATIONALIZE IS ANOTHER
BACKSTOP MECHANISM ALREADY IN
CURRENT LONG.
VICE FOR PC OVERSIGHT OF THE
PROCUREMENT ADVANCED DIRECTION
AFTER THE FACT APPROVING OF
CONTRACTS AND FAIR COST RECOVERY
FROM CUSTOMERS.
ON AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA HAS
POINTED OUT THEIR SUPPORT FOR
THIS APPROACH IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OWN STRIKE FORCE REPORT IN THE
P. UC'S OWN GREEN BOOK REPORT
WHICH IT PUBLISHED LAST YEAR.
IDENTIFYING GAPS ASSOCIATED WITH
EMERGING COMPETITIVE MARKETS --
AND ABSENT EFFORTS TO DEVELOP A
ROBUST STATE BACKSTOPS THE
CALIFORNIA I SO MAY BE REQUIRED
TO INTERVENE MORE FORCEFULLY IN
CALIFORNIA'S MARKETS.
THERE BY GETTING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MORE INVOLVED IN
CALIFORNIA'S RELIABILITY AND
RESOURCE PLANNING POLICIES.
ON I WANT TO ALSO JUST EXPLAIN
WHAT THE BILL DOES NOT DO.
THE BILL DOES NOT MODIFY THE
RULES PRACTICES OR REQUIREMENTS
OF THE EXISTING RESOURCE
ADEQUACY INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLANNING OR RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARD PROGRAMS.
IT DOES NOT TRANSFER ALL
RESPONSIBILITIES WITH CENTRAL
BUYER ONLY RESIDUAL
RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND IT DOES NOT CREATE A NEW
STATE AGENCY THAT IS VESTED WITH
ITS OWN POLICY MAKING POWER.
THE IDEA HERE IS TO CREATE A
TOOL THAT CAN BE USED BY THE PC
TO PERFORM THIS BACKSTOPS IN
LIEU OF THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES.
IT ALSO DOES NOT HARM RETAIL
COMPETITION OR COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATION.
THE BILL STATES EXPLICITLY THAT
CCA'S AND YES PLEASE REMAIN
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROCURING TO
MEET 1100% OF THEIR CUSTOMER
LOADS.
AND THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE PROPOSED IN THE
ANALYSIS.
REINFORCE THIS PRINCIPLE BY
PROVIDING EXPLICIT RIGHTS FOR
CCA'S TO PROVIDE ANY PORTION OF
IDENTIFIED NEEDS PURSUANT TO THE
STATUTORY PROVISIONS.
GOVERNING THE RESOURCE ADEQUACY
AND INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
PROGRAMS.
ON WE NEED TO TAKE ACTION NOW.
WE'RE URGING THE COMMITTEE AND
THIS LEGISLATURE NOT TO WAIT
UNTIL THE NEXT ENERGY CRISIS
ARRIVES WE CAN'T AFFORD TO WAIT
UNTIL OR IS A BONA FIDE
EMERGENCY TO DEVELOP THE
MECHANISMS NEEDED TO STABILIZE
ELECTRICITY MARKETS. FOR THOSE
WHO WERE HERE IN TWO THOUSAND
ONE YOU MAY REMEMBER THAT THERE
LEGISLATURE WAS FORCED TO
AUTHORIZE STATE INTERVENTION.
ONLY AFTER WHOLESALE MARKETS HAD
MELTED DOWN WE CAN'T AFFORD TO
WAIT FOR ANOTHER EMERGENCY FOR
THE STATE TO ACT THE GOAL IS TO
BE AHEAD OF THE CURVE.
AND MAKE SURE THE STATE HAS ALL
THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO ADDRESS
ANY DEFICITS ARE GAPS THAT
EMERGE AS PART OF THE STATE'S
ENERGY POLICY PROCESS.
THANK YOU WE SUPPORT THE BILL
AND ASK FOR SUPPORTING ABOUT
THANK YOU.
THE ONE SPEAK YES I AM GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KATIE BALANCE WHILE I'M WITH
THAT CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BELL AND
APOLOGIES FOR NOT GETTING THE
LETTER.
IN TIME TO BE REFLECTED IN THE
ANALYSIS THEY HOW IS A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF COMMUNITY CHOICE
AND COMMUNITY BASED ENERGY
PROJECTS.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS NOT
ABOUT CHANGING THE WAY CCA'S DO
BUSINESS TODAY NOR IS THIS ABOUT
CHANGING THE WAY BACK THOUGHT
PROCUREMENT AS IDENTIFIED.
THIS BILL IS SIMPLY ABOUT WHO
DOES BACKSTOP PROCUREMENT IN THE
CASE A NEED IS IDENTIFIED AND IN
THIS CASE WE BELIEVE THAT MOVIE
NOT AWAY FROM I USED TO A STATE
ENTITY.
IS A VERY STRONG POLICY MOVE AND
WE SUPPORT THAT.
HAVING A BACKSTOP ENERGY IS
CRITICAL TO ENSURING WE WE BOTH
MAINTAIN RELIABILITY AND ACHIEVE
OUR CLEAN ENERGY GOALS AND WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR FOR BRINGING FOR THIS
REALLY TIMELY ABOUT.
WE ALSO JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS HAS BEEN
UNDERWAY SINCE FEBRUARY ON THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORED ACCEPTED
ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS WE'VE
OFFERED TO DATE AND WE ARE
CONVINCED THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
WORKING OUT.
SOME OF THE TECHNICAL CHANGES
THAT ARE IN THE BILL AND WE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO MOVE
THIS FOR TODAY THANK YOU.
HI -- GOOD MORNING LORD AS HE
MENACE WITH SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL --
REALLY AGREE WITH -- MATT AND
KATIE'S POINTS OUT WITH RESPECT
TO THIS BILL WE FEEL THAT THE
FRAGMENTATION.
OF OF THE ENERGY INDUSTRY
REQUIRES REALLY A BILL LIKE THIS
AND HAVING YOU ALL ON THE
FOREFRONT TO HELP US COORDINATE --
THE CHANGES IN THE INDUSTRY IS
GOING TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT --
WE FEEL THAT -- AGAIN GIVEN THAT
THE ENERGY SUPPLIES BECOMING
INCREASINGLY DECENTRALIZED AND
AS A STATE MOVE FOR MOVE SOARED
WITH THE DECENTRALIZED
PROCUREMENT.
A KEY ISSUE FACING LEGISLATORS
ARE REGULATORS AS COORDINATION
OF THAT PROCUREMENT TO MEET
SINGLE GOAL -- EITHER BE IT G.
H. G. H. G. REDUCTION OR
RELIABILITY AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY TO ENSURE THAT WE
CONTINUE MOVING FORWARD
EXPLORING WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN --
IMPROVE RELIABILITY AND I
RESOURCE ADEQUACY THE STATE.
THANK YOU AND AND SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT YES THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
RUSSELL NOVAK ON BEHALF OF TE
CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE -- IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
I DO WE HAVE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
AND IF WE CAN MAKE SOME ROOM IN
FRONT. FOR TWENTY MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS JEFF
CIPHERS WITH CINEMA CLEAN POWER
IN THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
CHOICES ASSOCIATION HERE IN
OPPOSITION AB -- FIFTY SIX WE
BELIEVE THE BILL STARTED WITH
THE GOAL OF ENSURING GREATER
RELIABILITY AND PROVIDING A
MECHANISM POTENTIALLY FOR
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES TO EXIT
FROM PROCURING ENERGY.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT MADE SENSE --
BUT SOMEHOW THE BILL VEERED INTO
A VEHICLE TO REDEFINE BACKSTOP
PROCUREMENT INSTEAD OF JUST
IMPLEMENTING A CENTRAL BUYER TO
DO IT.
THE BILL SAYS THE BACKSTOP
PROCUREMENT SHOULD NOW INCLUDE
THE ADVANCE PURCHASE OF ENERGY
UP TO TEN YEARS AHEAD OF ANY
ACTUAL NEED AND THAT'S BECAUSE
AB FIFTY SIX WOULD GIVE THE P.
YOU SEE NEW POWER. TO ORDER A
CENTRAL AGENCY TO BUY ENERGY FOR
CCA'S ON THE BASIS OF A LONG
RANGE PLANNING DOCUMENT CALLED
AN INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLAN.
NOT ON ANY ACTUAL SHORTFALL OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY OR RELIABILITY
BUT ON THE SPECULATION THAT THE
CCA MIGHT NOT PURCHASE ENOUGH
ENERGY YEARS BEFORE IT'S NEEDED.
THIS ARRANGEMENT COULD MAKE
SENSE IF IT WAS PART OF
RESTRUCTURING P. GINNY.
BUT IT MAKES NO SENSE TO TAKE
AWAY PLANNING AND PROCUREMENT
FROM CCA'S.
TODAY THE P. YOU SEE AS THE
POWER TO ORDER PROCUREMENT ONLY
WANT TO SEE CA HAS FAILED TO
MEET ITS COMPLIANCE OBLIGATIONS
FILING AN INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLAN IS A COMPLIANCE OBLIGATION
OF A CCA.
BUT DISCLOSING A RISK FOR
EXAMPLE THAT A WIND POWER
PROJECT MIGHT NOT BE COMPLETED
IN TWENTY TWENTY NINE IS NOT A
COMPLAINTS VIOLATION IT'S A
PLANNING TARGET.
THIS BILL WOULD CHANGE THAT AND
MAKE ANY RISK AT ALL OF THE
FUTURE SHORTFALL A REASON FOR SO
CALLED BACKSTOP PROCUREMENT.
EVEN FOR RISKS IT CANNOT BE
AVOIDED.
KELSEY CA SUPPORTS A TRUE
BACKSTOPS BILL THAT WOULD
PROTECT GRADE RELIABILITY AND WE
PROVIDED AMENDMENTS TO THE
AUTHOR THAT WOULD DO THAT BUT SO
FAR THE AUTHOR HASN'T TAKEN ANY
OF OUR AMENDMENTS.
IN FACT CAL CC IS LEADING A
BROAD STAKEHOLDER PROCESS MANY
OF THOSE STAKEHOLDERS ARE HERE
TODAY TO PROVIDE AN ALTERNATE
PROPOSAL TO CONCERNS ABOUT
RESOURCE ADEQUACY PROCUREMENT.
WE ALREADY CONVINCED THE QC TO
ADOPT A THREE YEAR MANDATE FOR
PROCUREMENT OF RESOURCE ADEQUACY
INSTEAD OF THE PREVIOUS ONE YEAR
MANDATE.
AND TO TAKE AWAY OUR ABILITY TO
BUY CLEAN ENERGY RISKS THE VALUE
OF COMMUNITY CHOICE PROGRAMS AND
THE TEN THOUSAND MEGAWATTS WE
PLANNED A BILL BY TWENTY THIRTY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR NOTEBOOK
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
CAROL WE'D WITH THREE FIFTY BAY
AREA ACTION A STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
CAN MEMBERS REBEKAH LEE ON
BEHALF OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON WE HOP MUCH CONCERNS WITH
THIS BILL WOULD BELIEVE ADDING
ANOTHER STATE AUTHORITY TO THE
ALPHABET SOUP OF EXISTING
SIXTEEN STORY IS NOT GOING TO
RESULT IN.
MINIMIZE REPAIR IMPACT AND COST
OF SO URGE THAT THIS
CONVERSATION BE MOVED TO A TWO
YEAR CONVERSATION WILL HAPPILY
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR.
AND THE COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS
MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT RACE BY
THE SUPPORT COALITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MELISSA CORTES ROTH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL.
IN PRINT ON HOW ARE WE DO SEE A
ROLE THAT THIS AGENCY COULD PLAY
SPECIFICALLY -- ON DEFAULT A
CONTRACT FOR THE RESULT OF
BANKRUPTCY BUT OUTSIDE OF BEING
SICK NEVER A TO THAT SCOPE WE DO
OPPOSE.
MR TERM MEMBERS ONLY HUNTER ON
BEHALF OF THE SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION THE LARGE
SCALE SOLAR ASSOCIATION AND THE
AMERICAN WIND ENERGY ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA CAUCUS.
WE HAVE A A LETTER OF
CONSIDERATION INTO COMMITTEE WE
DO BELIEVE THIS CONVERSATION
SHOULD CONTINUE BUT A TWO YEAR
EFFORT WOULD BE EASIER AND
BETTER FOR US.
TO CONTEMPLATE ALL THE ISSUES
AND QUESTIONS THAT ARE RAISED BY
THE BILL WE THINK RIGHT NOW IT
WEIGHS MORE QUESTIONS AND
PROVIDE ANSWERS AND WE ASK FOR
THE BILL TO BE HELD.
THANK YOU.
HENCE THE BAKER WITH THEIR NAY
DISSOCIATES FOR SILICON VALLEY
CLEAN ENERGY IN OPPOSITION FOR
THE REASONS CAL SINCE HE IS
ALREADY REFERENCE.
EMILY PAPPAS ON BEHALF OF M. C.
E. ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
ALICIA PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF STAND
AS A CLEAN ENERGY IN OPPOSITION.
THERE DAHLE HIM HAPPILY A
CALIFORNIA CITIES JUST ONE ECHO
THE COMMENTS MADE BY KELSEY CA
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MORE TOP ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
IN OPPOSITION.
MR MEMBERS VINCENT WERE OUT MUCH
OF WHAT THE WYOMING ON BEHALF OF
EAST BAY COMMUNITY ENERGY ALSO
IN OPPOSITION.
NOT CLUB AND SEE NOW WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR IN STORE
DISSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
LIKE IT IS HERE WE HAVE THE CITY
OF SANTA MONICA AND OUR CONCERNS
ALIGNED WITH KELSEY CA.
BUT SHEPHERD ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN OPPOSITION.
KAREN MILLS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MARK FENSTER MAKER
FOR PENCIL CLEAN ENERGY AND
VALLEY CLEAN ENERGY IN
OPPOSITION.
YOUR CHAIR MEMBERS DON GILBERT
FOR SFPUC WE OPPOSE AND WANT.
TO KNOW THE REFERENCE IN THE
ANALYSIS TO THE TREASURES LETTER
INDICATING A MUCH CONCERNED WITH
THIS AGENCY THAT WOULD BE
CREATED THANKS.
KAREN PERKINS AS A MEMBER OF
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA OPPOSED.
JOHNSON CLAIMED BY THE CITY EVEN
SENATORS IN OPPOSITION.
AUDREY RETIRED CHECK ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN MATEO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN OPPOSITION.
ELIZABETH HAS BEEN -- SOME
BEHALF OF THE VENTURA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ALSO
OPPOSED -- MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
OR TWO WINNERS OR ANYBODY ELSE
IN THE PUBLIC WHICH TO COMMENT
ON THIS.
OKAY FIRST OF ALL OF I WANT TO
REMIND.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WHEN WE
HAD A HEARING HERE A FEW MONTHS
AGO.
RELATED TO THE BANKRUPTCY OF
PEACH IN THE END WE WENT OVER
THAT PROCESS -- THEY WERE VERY
SPEAKERS.
AND STAKEHOLDERS FOR
REPRESENTING ALL THE INDUSTRIES
THAT WE HAD HERE TODAY AND SOME
THAT ARE CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL.
I POSED THE QUESTION I ASKED
ABOUT HOW WE WERE GOING TO
RESOLVE -- SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES FACING OUR GRID AND
OF ASKED IF IF -- THEY BELIEVE
THAT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO HAVE --
SOME CENTRO PROCUREMENT.
MECHANISM -- FOR THE STATE AND
EVERYBODY ALMOST SANG IN CHORUS
A GREEN THAT SOMETHING HAD TO BE
DONE AND I THINK.
GENERALLY FROM WHAT I'M HEARING
FROM THE OPPOSITION IS THERE'S
NO REAL OPPOSITION TO THIS
PROCESS BUT CONCERNS ABOUT.
THIS BILL DOING THINGS.
THAT I'M EVERYBODY HAS A THEORY
THAT THIS BILL IS GOING TO DO
SOMETHING SPECIFICALLY TO HURT
THEM AS AN INDUSTRY EVERYBODY
[inaudible]
HAS.
ON SOME -- INDIVIDUAL GOALS
WHETHER IT BE -- ONE INDUSTRY OR
ANOTHER ST I WANT THIS PROCESS
TO YIELD MORE FOR ME
SPECIFICALLY.
AND THAT'S THE PROBLEM THAT
WE'RE HAVING WITH THIS CURRENT
BILL.
THAT EVERYBODY WANTS A PROVISION
IN THERE. TOO TO INFLUENCE A
NEUTRAL.
AND AN IMPARTIAL PROCESS.
AND GIVE THEM SOME LEVEL OF OF
OF OF POLITICAL BENEFIT.
AND AND THAT THAT'S WHY BILLS
LIKE THIS ARE VERY DIFFICULT.
SOME PEOPLE ARE ARE YOU IN IS
GOING TO PUT THEM OUT OF
BUSINESS SOME PEOPLE'S ARGUING
IT'S KINDA YOU KNOW -- HOW
CREATE OF?
OF A BUREAUCRACY WITH NEW POWERS
NOTHING IN THAT IN THAT IS IN
THE BILL AND AND I JUST WANTED --
TO COME BACK TO THIS FRIEDMAN
BECAUSE I THINK YOUR COMMENTS.
ADEQUATELY APPROPRIATELY
DESCRIBE WHAT THE BILL DOES WHAT
IT DOESN'T DO.
AND OUTSIDE OF THAT I MEAN.
OUTSIDE OF HAVING TO WRITE.
A LITTLE BENEFIT FOR EVERYBODY'S
SAKE OR YOU'RE GONNA GET THIS
YOU'RE GOING TO GET THE I DON'T
KNOW HOW WE HOW WE RIGHT THE
BILL.
THAT ACCOMPLISHES WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE
BECAUSE OF THEIR SOME REAL
THREATS TO OUR GREAT WE'RE
TRYING TO RESOLVE THOSE.
AND THEN WE'RE GET WEEK WE GO
THROUGH THE SAUSAGE MAKING
PROCESS EVERYBODY WANTS THEIR
LITTLE CARVE OUT -- I WANTED YOU
TO MAYBE -- MADE.
OF ADDRESS -- IF YOU COULD
RESPOND -- TO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS RELATED.
TO THIS BILL HAVE IN.
NEW BROAD POWERS AND THIS BILL.
BE IN A SPECIFIC TOOL.
TO PUT OTHER.
ENTITIES OUT OF BUSINESS I MEAN
I HEARD OF SOME.
SOME SOME ARGUMENTS THAT.
WERE ABOUT A BILL THAT I THAT I
THAT I HAVEN'T SEEN I HAVEN'T
I'VE READ THIS BILL AND DOESN'T.
SPECIFICALLY STATE OUT ALL THIS
STUFF SO HOW DO WE HOW DO WE
CALM THE FEARS HERE OF ALL THE
PEOPLE HERE THERE ARE.
CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL HAS AN
ULTERIOR MOTIVE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN IF I MADE --
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I'M
I'D LIKE TO OFFER A COUPLE
THOUGHTS FIRST OF ALL THERE WAS --
A COMMENT MADE THAT THIS BILL
HAS EXPANDED FROM ITS ORIGINAL
PURPOSE THAT IT STARTED OUT
SMALL GOT REALLY BIG IN FACT IT
HAS MOVED IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION.
SINCE THE BILL WAS INTRODUCED
AND PLACED INTO PRINT -- THE
AUTHORITY TO PROCURE HAS BEEN
pREDUCED RELATIVE TO THE INITIAL
VERSION WHICH PROVIDED MUCH
BROADER POWERS NOW THE BILL AS
IT EXISTS IN PRINT TODAY.
LINKS THE ABILITY OF THIS
COMMUNITY TO OPERATE ONLY TO
AUTHORIZATION ALREADY PROVIDED
IN EXISTING LAW FOR THE RESOURCE
ADEQUACY PROGRAM UNDER SECTION.
THREE EIGHTY FOR THE INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLANNING PROGRAM UNDER
SECTION FOR FIFTY FOUR POINT.
FIFTY ONE FOR THE RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD PROGRAM ON A
VOLUNTARY BASIS WHICH IS IN
SECTION THREE NINETY NINE POINT
THIRTEEN ALL EXISTING LAW
PROVISIONS.
THERE'S NO NEW PROCUREMENT
AUTHORITY PRESENTED HERE --
THERE'S BEEN CONCERNS RAISED AT
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW -- THE
STATE WIDE ENTITY TO GO FORWARD
AND SIGN LONG TERM CONTRACTS FOR
NEW RESOURCES IN THAT THAT
RESULT WOULD ONLY OCCUR.
IF THIS BILL WERE PASSED IN FACT.
EXISTING LAW UNDER THE RESEARCH
UNDER THE INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLANNING PROGRAM AUTHORIZES THAT
EXACT RESULT AND JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ISSUED A RULING IN
THAT CASE -- DIRECTING COMMENTS
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF
PROCUREMENT TO OCCUR OF BRAND
NEW RESOURCES IN THE STATE.
AND IF SO IF ANY LOW SERVING AND
HE DIDN'T SATISFY THEIR SHARE OF
THAT NEED WHETHER THEY SHOULD
USE A BACKSTOP MECHANISM.
AND THE BACKSTOP MECHANISM
THAT'S THE UTILITIES SO.
THIS BILL DOESN'T CHANGE ANY OF
THAT IT'S ALREADY HAPPENING THE
QUESTION BEFORE THE COMMITTEE IN
THE LEGISLATURE IS DO YOU REALLY
WANT THE UTILITIES TO DOUBLE
DOWN ON THEIR ROLE.
AS THE PROCUREMENT AND EIGHTY OF
LAST RESORT FOR THE STATE.
WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S MORE
APPROPRIATE TO TRANSPORT THAT
RESPONSIBILITY TO A STATE ENTITY
BECAUSE WE ARE RECOGNIZING THE
REALITIES ON THE GROUND TODAY
WHICH IS THAT THE UTILITIES ARE
GETTING SLIMMER NOT BIGGER WE
WANT THEM TO FOCUS ON THEIR CORE
FUNCTIONS.
MAINTAINING SAFETY AND
RELIABILITY THIS BILL DOES NOT
CONSTRAIN THE ABILITY OF ANY CCA
OR DIRECT ACCESS PROVIDER. TO
SERVE THEIR OWN CUSTOMERS AND TO
BUILD THEIR OWN PORTFOLIO ON AND
IT DOES NOT PROVIDE NEW WITH
FORTY FOR THE COMMISSION TO
REGULATE CCA'S IN FACT IT'S
EXPLICITLY WE HAVE A PROVISION
IN THE BILL THE COULD NOT BE
MORE EXPLICIT ON THIS POINT SO --
I DO SHARE YOUR FRUSTRATION
MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT -- SOME OF
THE CRITICS THAT HAVE BEN MADE
ABOUT THE BILL ARE ACTUALLY
ABOUT THE BILL AND PRINT THEY
SEEM TO BE ABOUT SOME OTHER
CONCEPT.
WE'LL GO TO CENTER STONE CENTER
RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND FIRST
I'D LIKE TO FIND OUT THE
OPPOSITION LIKE TO RESPOND TO
WHAT THE PROPONENTS ARE SAYING
AND THEN IF THE S. C. E. REP
WOULD MIND COMING BACK UP I DO
HAVE A QUESTION FOR HER.
WE WE CERTAINLY DO DISAGREE WITH
MR FRIEDMAN'S ANALYSIS -- IT IS
NOT CURRENTLY LAW THAT THE CPUC
MAY ORDER PROCUREMENT THROUGH
THE I. R. P. PROCESS ON A LONG
TERM BASIS WITHOUT.
PROVIDING THE CCA'S WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY OPPORTUNITY TO BURKE
HERE.
AND EXCEPT FOR RELIABILITY
PURPOSES FOR A COMPLIANCE
VIOLATION THE I. R. P. ITSELF IS
NOT A COMPLIANCE PROCUREMENT --
PROCESS IT IS A PLANNING
DOCUMENT AND WHEN THERE'S A
DEFICIENCY IN AN INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLAN THE CBC CAN ORDER
THAT DEFICIENCY TO BE FIXED TO
BE CURED.
AND CAN ORDER THAT PLAN TO BE
REFILED -- IT DOES NOT HAVE THE
POWER TO GO OUT AND BUY LONG
RANGE ENERGY FOR A CCA TODAY --
ON THE BASIS OF AN INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLAN -- PROCESS OF THE
TWO THOUSAND MEGAWATTS MENTIONED
AT THE CBC I MIGHT ALSO MENTION --
THE THE JUDGE IN THAT CASE
RECENTLY NOTED THAT THAT WAS
BASED ON NO DATA AND NO ANALYSIS
AND WAS JUST.
AN IDEA THAT THEY WERE
DISCUSSING SO I MIGHT NOTE THAT
AS WELL.
THANK YOU AND GOD TO THIS ESSIE
RIP IT IS I READ TO THE BILL IT
SEEMS TO BE MORE.
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT RATHER
THAN A BACKSTOP FOR PROCUREMENT --
THIS BILL IS AUTHORIZING CAP
COUGH -- TO UNDERTAKE BACKSTOP
PROCUREMENT BUT THIS PROCUREMENT
SEE THE FOCUS MORE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL REQUIREMENTS NOT A
SHORTAGE OF ELECTRICITY IT LIKE
YOU.
TO COMMENT ON THAT ALSO -- WHEN
BE SURE THAT THE POWER THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS NOT?
REQUIRED TO KEEP THE LIGHTS ON
BUT RATHER TO MEET OUR CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS NUMBER TWO AND THE
THIRD QUESTION THE MOST
IMPORTANT ONE FOR ME.
IN A ECONOMICALLY DISTRESSED
AREA THAT I REPRESENT -- WILL
THE WILL THIS IF IT BECOMES LAW
HAVE A PROPENSITY TO INCREASE
RATES OR WILL HAVE A PROPENSITY
TO DECREASE RATES TO OUR REPAIRS.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA EDISON HAS
SOME FUNDAMENTAL CONCERNS WITH --
TO INTRODUCTION OF A STATE
GOVERNMENT ENTITY INTO THE WHOLE
CELL PER KERMAN.
THE ROLE OF THE LAST TIME DURING
THE IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE
ENERGY CRISIS WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
AND FOR INTO THESE LONG TERM
CONTRACTS THE STATE'S.
UNDERSTANDABLY WAS ARE YOU A
WITH CONTRACTING AND AGO SHADING
UNDER A VOLATILE AND UNSAVORY
MARKET CONDITION AND THAT THAT
DURING THAT TIME HOWEVER THE
STATE LACK THE ABILITY A TO TO
REALLY CAREFULLY NEGOTIATED
CONTRACT WHICH RESULTED IN MANY
HIGH PRICE CONTRACTS SIGNED.
THOSE CONTRACT COSTS ARE STILL
BEING PAID FOR TODAY BY A
CALIFORNIA REPAIRS SO THERE IS
SOME IMPLEMENT ABILITY
IMPLEMENTS ABILITY PROBLEMS THAT
WE SEE IN ALLOWING A STATE
ENTITY TO BE FORMED -- THAT IT
THAT.
GET A WITH THIS THE STATE AND IF
YOU HAVE THE ABILITY.
TO NEGOTIATE WELL FOR REPAIRS OF
THIS IS A STATE ENTITY HAVE THE
ABILITY.
TO DO THE ONGOING CONTRACT
ADMINISTRATION WORK THAT WOULD
RESULT IN PERFORMANCE OF THESE
CONTRACTS AND THE RESOURCE THAT
MAKING SURE THE RESOURCES
DISPATCH CORRECTLY AND
FINANCIALLY SETTLED.
AND THAT -- AND THAT DIGITAL ART
OUR CUSTOMERS WHAT THE BRACE
THAT THEY MAY PAY THROUGH THIS
AUTHORITY WOULD THAT BE FAIR AND
JUST AND REASONABLE.
THAT SO SO THAT'S THE THAT'S
ADDRESSES SENATOR YOUR SECOND
QUESTION ON THE FIRST QUESTION
ON THIS.
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL I
UNDERSTOOD WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE WHERE THE AUTHOR AND THE
SUPPORT.
COMES FROM IS THAT THIS ENTITY
WHAT PURPOSE DO PROCUREMENT FOR
BOTH RELIABILITY BASED
RESOURCES AS WELL AS POLICY
DRIVEN CLEAN ENERGY RESOURCES
FOR THE REALIZED BUT REALIZABLE
RELIABILITY FOCUS RESOURCE THAT
ARE NEEDED -- THINK HIGH SO THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATOR ALREADY PERFORMS THAT
BACKSTOPS FUNCTION FOR ALL LOOSE
HAVING ENTITIES GENERALLY WE DO
AGREE US UP AMONG MANY
STAKEHOLDERS THAT.
IT IS NOT IDEAL TO HALF.
EXPANSION OF THIS YOU KNOW THE
BACKSTOP NEED THAT EVERY LOW
SERVING ENTITY OUGHT TO BE DOING
THEIR FAIR SHARE TO MAKE SURE
THE SYSTEM.
OPERATES RELIABLY ON THE MATTER
OF POLICY DRIVEN CLEAN ENERGY
DRIVEN.
BROKER MEN WELL THAT'S THE
REASON THAT'S THE REASON THAT CC
IS OUR FORM TO PROVIDE A CLEAN
OPTION WE TO UNDER PAUL THAT'S
BEEN PASSED BY THIS BODY UNDER
SB TWO FIFTY AND TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AS WELL AS AS THE ONE
HUNDRED ALSO HAVE TO MEET THOSE
CLEAN.
ENERGY OBJECTIVE ARE WE BELIEVE
THAT WE DO A GOOD JOB OF THAT
RIGHT NOW AND THAT IF THERE ARE
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED IN THIS
MARKET WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
MORE EQUAL OVERSIGHT OF ALL
THOSE THINGS AND LOW SERVING
ENTITY TO MAKE SURE THAT.
ALL PROVIDERS.
ART BRING OUR DELIVERING WHAT
THEY ARE HERE THEIR PROMISE TO
DELIVER THANK YOU OKAY SO AGAIN
BUT BUT MY MY MY AUNT LAST
QUESTION ANSWERED.
IF THIS BILL IS SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR IS THERE A HIGHER
PROPENSITY THE ELECTRICAL RATES
ARE GOING TO GO UP.
WHERE THEY CAN SAY THE SAME ARE
THEY GONNA GO DOWN?
GENERALLY WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
THAT THIS WOULD HAVE A PORT
PRESSURES ON ON RATES OKAY AND
THEN THE LAST QUESTION.
HOW IF YOU ARE DOING THAT
PROCUREMENT HOW DO YOU BALANCE?
THE ENVIRONMENTAL MANDATES THAT
THE STATE CALIFORNIA'S PUT INTO
A FACTOR SB THREE FIFTY ETCETERA.
VERSUS FINDING THE THE LOWEST
COST ELECTRICITY.
TO PROVIDE -- LOW COST -- ENERGY
AS MUCH AS WE POSSIBLY CAN TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE PACE OF THE
HIGHEST UTILITY RATES IN THE
COUNTRY.
WE WOULD DO THAT THROUGH THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
EVERY CONTRACT EVERY LONG TERM
CONTRACTS WE SIGNED A SUBJECT TO
THE REVIEW AND APPROVAL OF THE
STATE AUTHORITY.
AND WE GO THROUGH A RIGOROUS
PROCEEDING PROCESS MISTER
FREEMAN HAS PARTICIPATED IN MANY
OTHERS PRECEDING AND CHALLENGE
THE COSTS REASONABLENESS OF
THOSE CONTRACTS SO I EXPECT THAT
IF WE CONTINUE IN THIS ROLE THAT
HE NONETHELESS WILL BE A VERY
COMPELLING VOICE AND AND
CHALLENGING.
BUT AT THE COST REASON WHEN THIS
OF VARIOUS CONTRACT WE ENTER
INTO ON BEHALF OF REPAIRS THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU FOR
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS.
AND JUST TO FIVE COULD.
BEEN SOMEWHAT FAMILIAR WITH THAT
LAST INSTANCE.
THOSE ARE THE VERY ARGUMENTS WHY
PEOPLE AGREE THAT WE NEED SOME
AGENCY THAT ITS EQUIPPED TO
HANDLE ANY CASE WHERE SOMEBODY
GOES INTO BANKRUPTCY OR OR IF
SERVICES INTERRUPTED.
HER ARGUMENTS WAS.
THEY TREAT IT RIGHT THEY ENTERED
THE WORKFORCE INTO CONTRACTS
THAT WERE NOT GOOD FROM THEIR
PERSPECTIVE.
BY PEOPLE THAT WERE NOT WELL
EQUIPPED TO HANDLE THAT.
AND SO.
WHAT THEY'RE BY SAYING THAT
THERE ARE YOU IN FOR THE STATUS
QUO? TO REPEAT THAT PROCESS
AGAIN.
AS OPPOSED TO HAVE THE IN AN
AGENCY THAT'S EQUIPPED THAT'S
EXPERIENCE THAT.
HAS A SPECIFIC MISSION
ACCOMPLISHED THIS.
THERE ST WERE AFRAID THAT I
MIGHT THAT MIGHT RESULT.
IN LIKE WHAT WE WE HAD IN THE
PAST [inaudible]
HONESTLY.
I I JUST DON'T BUY THAT I DON'T
THINK THAT'S A VALID ARGUMENT
BECAUSE THE WHOLE POINT OF THIS
IS TO PREVENT.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT [inaudible]
CENTER RUBIO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELL FIRST OF ALL I THINK THE
AUTHOR I MEAN I AT DEATHLY
UNDERSTAND WHY WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD WITH THIS SPELL AND I
THINK THE AUTHOR AND THE
ADVOCATES THAT NOR MY OFFICE
SHARON AND I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH THEM.
FOR A BRIEF MOMENT BUT SOCAL
EDISON IS IN MY DISTRICT AND SO
THEY HAD SOME CONCERNS AND I'M
JUST.
MIGHT RIGHT NOW I'M.
KIND OF CONCERNED HOW WE GOT SO
FAR AWAY FROM YOU KNOW WHERE YOU
ARE AND THE OPPOSITION IS AND
THERE'S SO MUCH MISINFORMATION
AND I JUST WANNA.
SEE BECAUSE FOR A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOW DID YOU.
COME TO THE TABLE WERE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS LIKE I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
PEOPLE WERE ENGAGED IN THIS
PROCESS.
CAN YOU SHARE.
YEAH I'M GOING TO DEFER -- TO
KATIE WITH SALES BEEN PART OF
THE PROCESS FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
AT GOOD MORNING CENTER I'M THE
PROCESS BEGAN IN FEBRUARY
EVERYBODY WAS INVITED TO THE
TABLE AND A SERIES OF MEETINGS
AND ASK FOR IMPACT ON THE
GENERAL STRUCTURE.
AND FEEDBACK ON AMENDMENTS -- WE
PARTICIPATED IN ALL OF THOSE
MEETINGS WE MET WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE PROBABLY FOUR OR FIVE
TIMES AT THIS POINT SUBMITTED
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ACHIEVE THE
GOALS OF THE BELL AND ALL THOSE
AMENDMENTS WERE ACCEPTED -- I DO
THINK THAT AND WE AS I SAID WE
ARE CAN CONSUMER CHOICE
ADVOCATES WE DO BELIEVE THAT YOU
KNOW HAVING COMPETITION AND ALL
THAT IS GREAT AND IMPORTANT IN
SUPPORT THAT -- IF WE THOUGHT
THIS BILL WAS ABOUT FREDDIE NOT
DOWN WE WOULD NOT BE SUPPORTING
IT AND I DO BELIEVE THAT.
A LOT OF FOLKS HAVE HEARD THAT
THIS BILL WILL SHUT DOWN CCA --
AND SO THEY'RE REACTING TO
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD REACT TO
AS WELL WHICH IS WELL NO WE
DON'T WANT THE CA TO SHUT DOWN --
BUT WHEN YOU ACTUALLY LOOK INTO
THE BILL THE TEARS MENTION AND
YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL WE DO
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE SUFFICIENT
LANGUAGE. TO ELIMINATE THE
AMBIGUITY AND HOW THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO BE IMPLEMENTED TO
ENSURE THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN SO
THE PROCESS IS ON GOING I THINK
WE ASK THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE
MEETING OVER SUMMER RECESS SINCE
WE DO HAVE A FEW WEEKS. TO KEEP
WORKING ON LANGUAGE.
ECONOMIC ASSET POSITION TO
ADDRESS -- HOW YOU GUYS CAME TO
THE TABLE AND DISCUSS THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU SO I WILL NOTE THAT AS
THIS BILL MOVES THROUGH THE
ASSEMBLY -- EACH VOTE WAS --
BREAKFAST ON THE THE BASIS THAT.
THE CONCERNS THAT CCA'S WERE
BRINGING UP WOULD BE ADDRESSED
WE DID PROVIDE -- AMENDMENTS AND
THROUGH THAT PROCESS NONE OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS WERE ACCEPTED.
AND IT HAS BEEN A DIFFICULT
PROCESS SO I JUST WANT TO HEAR
THAT.
CAN WE ADDRESS SOME.
THOSE AMENDMENTS BECAUSE I UNITE
NON THE AUTHOR AND I KNOW THAT
HE'S BEEN REALLY GOOD IN THE
PAST IN IN TERMS OF ALWAYS COME
TO THE TABLE AND TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT HE ENGAGES EVERYONE.
AND I JUST WANNA ADDRESS THOSE
AMENDMENTS WHAT AMENDMENTS DO
YOU THINK WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
TO SOLVE YOUR CONCERN WITH WE
BEGAN.
BY ADDRESSING THE THAT THE
AUTHORS STATEMENT ABOUT THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL BEING A
BACKSTOP FUNCTION -- FOR
RELIABILITY AND PROVIDE
AMENDMENTS TO THAT EFFECT --
THAT WOULD NARROW THE BILL TO
DOING THAT AS OPPOSED TO DOING
LONG RANGE ENERGY PROCUREMENT
PLANNING ON BEING AND PURCHASING
ON BEHALF OF ALL.
ELECTRIC PROVIDERS -- WE ALSO
PROVIDED AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT THE CHARGES
ASSOCIATED WITH ANY CENTRAL --
BUYER FLOW TO THE GENERATION
SIDE OF THE BILL -- AND WE ALSO
PROVIDE AMENDMENTS WHICH WE NOW
SEE IN THE COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDATIONS SO WE APPRECIATE
THIS THAT IT BE CLEARER THE CCA
HAVE THE RIGHT -- TO SELF
PROVIDE AND AND SO THOSE OF THE
THE THE PRIMARY AMENDMENTS THAT
WE WERE ADDRESSING -- AS THE
BILL IT BECAME MORE OBVIOUS THAT
THE BILL WAS A VEHICLE TO DEAL
WITH EITHER A SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC WISHING TO EXIT FROM
GENERATION OR RESTRUCTURING OF
THE P. GINNY -- WE ESSENTIALLY
SAID WELL HOW DO YOU NOT APPLY
THE SAME STANDARD FOR LONG RANGE
PLANNING OF A UTILITY WHICH IS
NECESSARY FOR POWER PURCHASES.
TO SCCA WHICH ALREADY HAS A LONG
RANGE PLANNING BODY WHICH IS
IT'S GOVERNMENT.
ENTITY.
AND AND SO ESSENTIALLY THIS BILL
IS APPLYING A STANDARD IT IT'S
DOING TWO THINGS IT'S DOING
BACKSTOP RETIREMENT AND IT'S
ALSO DOING LONG RANGE PLANNING
AND PROCUREMENT.
AND THOSE TWO THINGS.
ARE DIFFICULT TO PUT INTO ONE
BILL AND HAVE IT APPLY TO
EVERYONE IN THE SAME WAY BECAUSE
CCA'S ARE VERY DIFFERENT THAN
FOR PROFIT UTILITIES -- WE
ALREADY HAVE RATE PAYERS WHO
APPROVE OUR PROCUREMENT -- PART
WERE OWNED BY RATE PAYERS ARE
BOARD IS ELECTED BY RATE PAYERS
AND ARE IN A GREAT RESOURCE PLAN
IS PRIMARILY APPROVED BY THE
GOVERNING BODY -- IT GOES TO THE
CBC FOR INFORMATION SHARING AND
FOR A COMPLIANCE CHECK THAT IT'S
COMPLETE -- BUT IT DOESN'T GO
THERE -- TO SEE IF -- WE'VE
PROCURED EXACTLY WHAT THE PC
WANTS US TO PREPARE YOU KNOW
EIGHT YEARS OUT -- SO I THINK --
I THINK THAT'S THE THE PRIMARY
CONCERN.
IF I MAKE SENATOR AND THAT I
JUST TO CORRECT SOMETHING THAT
WAS JUST STATED IT WAS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE INTENT OF
THIS BUT WAS NEVER TO BE JUST
ABOUT RELIABILITY WAS ALSO ABOUT
ENSURING.
THAT THE STATE HAD THE TOOLS TO
ENSURING THAT THE CLEAN ENERGY
TARGET WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT
SAY HI MANY OF OUR PARTNERS
FIRMLY BELIEVE IS VERY CRITICAL.
WE THINK THAT THIS BILL SO I
JUST WANT TO SAY AS WELL THAT I
BELIEVE THE CCA'S HAVEN'T MET
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE -- SINCE
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR VOTE AND
THAT'S A CONVERSATION THAT WE'VE
REALLY BEEN LOOKING FORWARD TO
HAVING HOW DO WE RECTIFY WHAT'S
IN THE BILL AND WHAT THEIR SCENE
IS WRONG WITH THE BILL WITH WHAT
CAN HAPPEN WITH THE BELL WHAT WE
THINK IS IMPORTANT WHICH IS AT
THE STATE.
HAVE A STRONG BACK UP BOTH FOR
THE RELIABILITY AND FOR THE
CLEAN ENERGY AND MOVING OUT AWAY
FROM THE I. O. U.'S
WE DID MEET WITH THE OFFICE
SINCE THAT BUT SO WELL.
EARLIER I HEARD THOUGHTS ON NONE
OF THE AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN BUT
I ALSO HEARD THAT.
THERE AND THE CURRENT SUGGESTED
AMENDMENT CRAZY IN THE BILL
CORRECT AND SO -- I JUST HOPE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE FOR ME MY
CONCERN WAS THAT I KNOW THAT WE
ARE FOCUSED ON GREAT RELIABILITY
MAKING SUE THERE'S ANOTHER BACK
WITH BANKRUPTCY WE HAVE THE
ABILITY. TO TO HANDLE SOMETHING
OF THAT MAGNITUDE AND I KNOW
THAT.
THE MAJOR PLAYERS IN MY PERSONAL
OPINION IS P. JEANNIE WILL WHO
IS IN BANKRUPTCY BUT THEN WE
HAVE SEND HICKEL WHO IS HAS BEEN
VERY VOCAL ABOUT JUST STEPPING
AWAY FROM PROCUREMENT.
AND THEN WE HAVE THE THIRD.
ONE IN MY OPINION WHICH IS -- I
THOUGHT COUNT MEDICINE WHO
HAPPENS TO BE MY DISTRICT AND SO
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE TAKING.
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION WE HAVE
ONE IN BANKRUPTCY THE OTHER ONE
WHO DOESN'T WANT TO FOR CARE AND
THEN WE HAVE THAT.
PERSON IN THE MIDDLE SO I'M VERY
OPEN TO AND I GUESS THAT I KNOW
THE AUTHOR HAS BEEN REALLY.
GRACIOUS AND STOPPING BY TALKING
TO ME AND WORKING THROUGH SOME
OF THESE ISSUES I I WANT TO BE
SUPPORTIVE BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS CONVERSATIONS.
MOVING FORWARD IN TRYING TO AT
LEAST YOU KNOW SELL SOME OF
THESE CONCERNS OUT HERE -- BUT
WITH THAT I GUESS I JUST WANT A
CLARIFICATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
I YEAH I APOLOGIZE FOR BEING
LATE MISSING MOST THE TESTIMONY
I'VE READ -- YOU KNOW THE
ANALYSIS -- I GUESS IS SOMEBODY
THAT'S BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF OF
THIS TYPE OF BILL RESOURCE
ADEQUACY THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT.
MUCH TO THE CHAGRIN OF THE CCA'S --
IN MY DISTRICT -- I LOOK AT THIS
IN -- BUT I DO HAVE.
SOME SERIOUS CONCERNS ID
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND WHY WE
SHOULD BE PLANNING A LOOKING OUT
AHEAD.
OF FOR RESOURCES BUT I'M REALLY
CONFUSED WE WE'VE HAD SEX LAST
NIGHT MR GARCIA YOU AND I TOO
LATE IN THE EVENING ACTUALLY BUT
NEVERTHELESS IT'S THE IDEA THAT
WE WOULDN'T.
THAT WE'RE GONNA MAKE OR OR THAT
WE WOULD HAVE THE P. YOU SEE --
PURCHASING FOR LET'S JUST SAY
CCA'S OR ANYBODY ON CONTRACTS
TEN YEARS OUT.
YEAH MAYBE.
I I I I DON'T.
I THINK THE THIRD SHOULD BE LIKE
A PROVISION THAT WOULD SAY OKAY
IN YOUR SEVEN THROUGH TEN WE
DON'T THINK THAT YOUR DO WITH
THE WAY THIS THING IS GOING TO
YOU'RE GOING TO MEET YOUR NEEDS --
YOU SHOULD GIVE THAT.
THEY SHOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROCURE.
THEIR OWN ENERGY INSTEAD OF
HAVING TO BE YOU SEE DO IT AND
IF I MAY NOT HAVE -- YEAH THIS
EXACTLY CORRECT BUT I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ENOUGH FLEXIBILITY
FOR THE CCA'S THE WAY THIS BILL
READS TODAY.
SENATOR -- BY MAY ON THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
SPECIFICALLY THAT ARE IN THE
ANALYSIS TODAY -- CROSS
REFERENCE THE RIGHTS OF CCA'S TO
SELF PROVIDE THEIR SHARE OF ANY
IDENTIFIED LONG TERM NEED UNDER
SECTION FOR FIFTY FOUR POINT.
FIFTY ONE THAT SECTION ALLOWS
CCA'S ONCE IN NEED AS BEEN
IDENTIFIED TO PROPOSE HOW THEY
WOULD MEET THEIR SHARE OF THAT
NEED.
IF THERE PROPOSAL IS SUFFICIENT
THEN THE CCA WOULD NOT BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ANY LONG TERM
PROCUREMENT THAT IS DONE ON A
BACKSTOPS BASIS THAT SAID THAT'S
THE PROPOSAL IN THIS BILL IS TO
GIVE CCA'S.
AS THEY HAVE UNDER SECTION FOR
FIFTY FOUR POINT FIFTY ONE THAT
RIGHT TO MAKE THEIR OWN CHOICES
IF THE NEED IS IDENTIFIED IT'S
ONLY IF THE CCA FAILS TO MEET
THAT NEED AFTER IT'S BEEN
IDENTIFIED.
THAT BACKSTOP PROCUREMENT WOULD
BE INVOKED AND THAT'S CURRENT
LAW WE'RE LINKING IT REALLY TO
THE EXISTING PROCESS WE'RE NOT
CREATING ANY NEW MANDATES HERE.
THIS FEATURE CAN I PROCEED
ABSOLUTELY.
THIS SITE FIRST COULD YOU.
COMMENT ON THAT PLEASE.
YES SO.
THE PROCESS TODAY DIDN'T WORK
WERE WERE KIND OF SPLITTING
HAIRS HERE BECAUSE I OUR P. IS A
PLANNING PROCESS THAT'S USED
TODAY AND IT IS USED FOR
PROCUREMENT BASIS FOR I'LL USE
TO DO LONG RANGE OF PROCUREMENT.
IT'S ALSO USED BY DIRECT ACCESS
PROVIDERS AND CCA'S TO INFORM
THE QC THE I SO AND OTHERS ABOUT
WHAT LONG RANGE -- PROCUREMENT
THE CCA'S AND DIRECT ACCESS ARE
DOING AND THERE IS A CHECKPOINT
THERE WERE THE CPUC CAN SAY WHAT
YOU'RE DOING IS INSUFFICIENT OR
YOU NEED TO MAKE A CORRECTION
YOU NEED TO REFILE YOUR PLAN YOU
NEED TO GO OUT AND DO ADDITIONAL
PROCUREMENT -- WHAT HAPPENS AT
THAT POINT IS THAT YOU SEE ONLY
HAS THE RIGHT TO ORDER BACKSTOPS
RETIREMENT FOR THOSE RESOURCES?
IF THERE IS THE ACTUAL
COMPLIANCE DEFICIENCY -- THIS
BILL CHANGES OUT AND SAYS THE I.
R. P. ITSELF BECOMES A
COMPLIANCE PROCUREMENT DOCUMENTS
AS OPPOSED TO JUST A PLANNING
DOCUMENT.
AND AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE WE
HAVE A DISAGREEMENT HERE THE
STABLE.
THAT.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THE WHAT
I'VE HEARD SO I MAY I DON'T KNOW
HOW HOW YOU GUYS ARE GONNA.
COME TOGETHER ON THIS BUT THAT
SEEMS TO BE THE BONE OF
CONTENTION I NAY -- ACTIVE.
I REALLY THINK THAT THE LAST
STATEMENT MISREPRESENTS CURRENT
LAW -- AND A REVIEW OF THE
STATUTORY PROVISION THAT I
MENTIONED WHICH IS PART OF THE
I. R. P. CODE SECTION FOR FIFTY
FOUR POINT.
FIFTY ONE DIRECTS THE PC IF IT
IDENTIFIES A DEFICIT RELATIVE TO
THE PORTFOLIO IS ADOPTED. TO
ALLOW CCA'S TO SELF PROVIDE
THEIR SHARE OF ANY IDENTIFIED
NEED AND IF THAT CHAIR OF
IDENTIFIED NEED IS NOT SELF
PROVIDED.
IT DIRECTS THE COMMISSION. TO
AUTHORIZE THE UTILITIES TO DO
LONG TERM PROCUREMENT AND TO
CHARGE ALL CUSTOMERS IN THE
SYSTEM THAT'S THE LAW AS IT IS
TODAY AND THE P. C. HAS ALREADY
BEEN MOVING FORWARD TO IMPLEMENT
THAT PROVISION.
THIS BILL DOESN'T CHANGE THAT AT
ALL IT DOESN'T ADD TO IT DOESN'T
SUBTRACT FROM IT.
SO I UNDERSTAND THE CCA'S HAVE
AN IDEOLOGICAL OPPOSITION TO PC
OVERSIGHT OF THEIR INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLANNING PROSPER AUNTS
AND THEY'RE AND THEY'RE AND
THEY'RE PROPOSALS THAT HAVE COME
IN HAVE BEEN REVIEWED BY THE
COMMISSION.
THEY HAVE BEEN APPROVED REJECTED
MODIFIED THERE IS A WHOLE
PROCESS UNDER WAY AS WE SPEAK --
THIS BILL DOESN'T TOUCH THAT
PROCESS AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
BRIGHT LINES THAT AS SPONSORS WE
FELT THIS VERY IMPORTANT IN THIS
BILL.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO CHANGE THE
DETAILS OF THE EXISTING PROGRAMS
THAT ALREADY HAVE THESE
MECHANISMS WERE SIMPLY CHANGING
THE IDENTITY OF THE BACKSTOP
PROCURE.
AND RATHER THAN BEING THE
UTILITY WERE PROPOSING TO HAVE A
STATE ENTITY BE THAT THAT --
PROCUREMENT ENTITY [inaudible]
SENATOR [inaudible]
SKINNER.
AND THEN WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
CENTER RUBIO -- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR [inaudible]
I'M.
JT EFFORT.
THAT THE AUTHOR IS AN WHAT THE
INTENTION TO TRY TO NOT TRY BUT
TO HAVE A BACKSTOP PROCUREMENT
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE GRADE
RELIABILITY.
AND I'VE MET WITH THE AUTHORIZED
MET WITH -- SPONSORS -- I STILL
FEEL LIKE THIS BILL NEEDS -- IT.
I AM ESPECIALLY CONCERNED ABOUT
OUR TREASURERS LETTER.
BECAUSE IF WE'RE ASKING THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE THROUGH CAPE
DEATH TO PLAY SUCH A SIGNIFICANT
ROLE.
IT IT JUST IT SEEMS LIKE THIS
BILL WOULD BENEFIT FROM BECOMING
A TO YOUR BILL SO THAT THE WORK
COULD BE DONE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE DOING THIS CORRECTLY AND
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT WE JUST
TOOK.
VERY SIGNIFICANT ACTION
AFFECTING OUR UTILITIES -- I
KNOW THE ASSEMBLY HASN'T YET
APPROVED THE BILL BUT THE IT'S
OVER TO THE SET ASSEMBLY NOW.
THE SENATE IS ALSO GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT BUDGET COMMITTEE
TODAY A SECOND BILL.
NOW WELL THOSE ARE COUCHED
AROUND WILDFIRE THEY REALLY ARE
ABOUT STABILITY FOR UTILITIES
NOW THERE MAY BE THE ARGUMENT
THAT IT DOESN'T.
DEAL WITH ENSURING THAT OUR
UTILITIES CAN PROCURE ADEQUATELY
BUT I THINK THE STABILITY OF THE
UTILITIES IS THE THING THAT WE
FIRST AND FOREMOST HAVE TO DEAL
WITH WHICH WE ARE DEALING WITH.
AND THEN I THINK IT GIVES US
SOME TIME TO LOOK AT ALL RIGHT
WHAT ELSE NOW DO WE NEED. TO
GIVE OUR GREAT THE RELIABILITY
THAT WE NEED SO I'M NOT READY TO
VOTE AFFIRMATIVELY FOR THE BILL
TODAY [inaudible]
CENTER RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OF I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE STATE AGENCY THAT'S
GOING TO BE CREATED -- IS A NOT
LIKE I SAID I'VE EXPRESSED MY
CONCERNS AND I DO SHARE --
SENATOR SKIN IS CONCERNED THAT --
IT SEEMS TO BE A LIVE A FAST
ESPECIALLY WITH THEIR SO MANY
INTERSECTIONS IN TERMS OF THE
WILDFIRE INSURANCE EVERYTHING
THAT'S HAPPENING BUT IN TERMS OF
THAT AGENCY I MEAN.
I WOULD IMAGINE IT NEEDS TIME TO
BE.
SOLIDIFY PUT TOGETHER AND SURE
THAT IT'S FUNCTIONAL CAN YOU
SHARE A LITTLE BIT OF HOW WE'RE
GOING TO DO THAT AND DOT WILL IT
HAVE THE EXPERTISE HOW ARE WE
GONNA SELECT.
THE BOARD CAN YOU.
EDUCATE ME SO WE ARM.
WERE ASKED TO CONSIDER THIS
ENTITY IN THE ASSEMBLY UTILITIES
A COMMITTEE.
ORIGINALLY WE HAD PROPOSED.
OF PUTTING TOGETHER A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION -- MADE UP OF THE
EXPERTS THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO
OVERSEE -- THIS TASK.
WE SPOKE TO AFTER YESTERDAY AND
BELIEVE THAT THERE COULD BE A
PATH -- CLEARLY THE LETTER THAT
DAVE -- SENT -- RAISES CONCERNS
SIMILAR CONCERNS THAT WE HAD
WHEN ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT IN
THE ASSEMBLY TO EASE COMMITTEE.
BUT WE HAVE. SIX PLUS WEEKS OF A
WORK STILL TO DO IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION AND I'M
COMMITTED TO TAKE IN YOU KNOW
EVERY.
HELP ENSURE THAT. TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS AND WORK
TOWARDS A PATH -- FOR THIS
ENTITY OR IF WE CAN GET SOME
DIALOGUE.
GOING AGAIN WITH SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY
PLEASE COMMITTEE A CONSIDER --
ANOTHER ENTITY THAT MAY HAVE.
THE EXPERTISE TO DO SO -- ONE
ENTITY THAT WE DON'T BELIEVE
SHOULD BE -- OVERSEEING THIS IS
THE CAL I SAW -- BECAUSE OF THE
OVERSIGHT THAT THE EXISTE ARE
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND SO THAT'S ONE ENTITY THAT
WE'VE -- COMPLETELY SAID DOT
WILL NOT WORK FOR US SO -- LOOK
I I REALIZE THAT FOR SOME FOLKS
THE BILL IS NOT FULLY.
THAT QUOTE UNQUOTE COOKED IT
ISN'T -- THIS IS THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND WE'RE LOOKING TO
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE EVEN THOSE
WHO ARE OPPOSING -- THE BILL
TODAY -- TO WORK WITH US I THINK
NO ONE DISAGREES THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE.
A CENTRALIZED A PROCESS HERE TO
ENSURE THAT -- ONE WE DON'T SEE
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS AND NUMBER -- TWO
GIVEN THE NATURE OF THE I. O.
U.'S.
INSTABILITY ON THAT THAT DOES
NOT -- IMPACT.
UP RATE PAYERS IN CALIFORNIA OR
FOR THAT MATTER THE LIGHTS NOT
BEING ABLE TO TURN ON FOR FOLKS
IN THE STATE.
THANK YOU FOR FOR ADDRESSING
THAT THAT YOU KNOW AS I BEGIN.
YOU NEAR MY CONCERNS COMING IN
HERE AND DOC AND I FEEL A LITTLE.
UNCOMFORTABLE.
MOVING FORWARD OF THE BILL
THAT'S NOT.
AS YOU PUT IT FULLY COOKED I
KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT OF LOOSE
ENDS BUT I AM FULLY I AM
ENCOURAGED.
BY WHAT I JUST HEARD IN THAT IS
THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH NOT ONLY.
AS IT PERTAINS TO THAT THAT
COMMITTEE OR COMMISSION BUT ALSO
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND AND I
WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR THAT I
STILL FEEL THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
TO BE DONE.
AND YOU KNOW I WILL RESERVE
TODAY I WILL SUPPORTIVE BECAUSE
I KNOW THAT YOU CAN GET THERE
BUT I NEED TO KNOW.
WHEN IT COMES TO US THAT ALL
THOSE ISSUES HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED
THANK YOU?
THANK YOU I I JUST WANTED ALSO
MENTION THAT I I THINK THAT
THERE IS.
ALSO A PATH TO ADDRESSING -- THE
PROCUREMENT -- OPTION THAT
EDISON HAS RAISED THAT THEY WANT
TO CONTINUE TO BE IN THE
DRIVER'S SEAT NOW WE KNOW TWO
YEARS AGO.
THAT WAS A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
THAT THE SHARED IN THEIR
BUSINESS MODEL -- BUT THE TODAY --
THAT'S CHANGED IN AND SO WE'RE
WILLING TO ALSO EXPLORE HOW THAT
OPTION MAY BE.
INTEGRATED INTO THE OVERALL --
BILL AS WELL.
THANK YOU FOR THAT THANK YOU MR
TRUMP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SIR WIENER I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU THE AUTHOR AS
WELL -- FOR SITTING DOWN WITH US
AND AND FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
AND FOR A MANY OTHER HIGH ENERGY --
ISSUES -- SUPPORTED YOUR OTHER
ENERGY BILLS SAY YOU'VE DONE A
LOT OF GREAT WORK.
ON ON THIS ONE AS I EXPRESS TO
YOU I DO HAVE -- OUR CONCERNS
THIS IS A BILL THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO GET TO A POINT THAT I CAN
SUPPORTER BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD -- IN THIS
BILL FOR WHATEVER REASON I'M NOT.
I'M NOT EXPRESS ANY OPINIONS ON
THIS OR SEEMS TO HAVE BEEN A OF
THE BREAKDOWN IN COMMUNICATION.
OR WHAT BUT I I'M HOPING THAT --
IF THIS BILL GETS OUT OF
COMMITTEE ON THAT THERE CAN BE A
REINVIGORATION OF OF YOU KNOW.
AND I'VE BEEN THERE AND WE'VE
ALL BEEN THERE ON BILLS BEFORE
WHERE THEY'RE JUST YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES SOMETHING IS NOT
CLICKING WITH THE COMMUNICATION
AND SOMETIMES.
NEWS HAS TO HAVE THE RESET
BUTTON AND START OVER AGAIN --
I'M NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO GO UP
ON THE BILL TODAY -- IF IT -- IF
IT GETS OUT OF COMMITTEE OR IF
IT'S TO YOUR BILL OR WHATEVER
HAPPENS WITH THAT -- I DO HOPE
TO BE ABLE.
TO ABLE TO VOTE FOR WHEN I GUESS
OF FLORIDA'S I EXPRESS TO YOU
ALL TAKE A FRESH LOOK AT IT --
BUT THAT'S WHERE I AM TODAY.
RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS MEASURE AND I SORRY I
MISSED MOST YOUR TESTIMONY BUT I
KNOW THE GIST OF THIS BILL AND
IT'S ABOUT.
RELIABILITY I MEAN AND THIS IS
WHAT THIS BILL IN A NUTSHELL IS
TRYING TO ASSURE THAT WE HAVE --
POWER WHEN NEEDED AND CURE MADE
BE A LONG TERM OR SHORT TERM IS
IS CRITICAL AND AGAIN I I WORK
FOR UTILITY COMPANY DURING THE
ENERGY CRISIS.
AND IT WAS DUE TO OUR FAILURE.
TO PLAN AND PREPARE IS DO WITH
OUR FELLOW YOUR TO ENTER LONG
TERM CONTRACTS THAT WE FOUND
OURSELVES BUYING POWER ON THE
SPOT MARKET WHEN THE DA AT
MARKET AND IT LED TO A DISASTER.
THIS IS ONE OF THE SAFEGUARDS
IT'S GONNA AVOID US DOING THAT
BY MAKING SURE WE HAVE ADEQUATE
RESOURCES WHEN NEEDED.
AND IF YOU'RE POLLS THIS BILL
THEN YOU'RE OPPOSED.
TO SYSTEM RELIABILITY AND
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT SYSTEM RELIABILITY.
AND IF YOU'RE POLLS THIS BILL IS
ABOUT PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS.
BUT IF YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL
IT'S ABOUT WHAT WE ALL SAY WE
CONCERNED ABOUT A RELIABLE
SYSTEM AND THAT'S NUMBER.
ONE HERE IN CALIFORNIA WILL NOT
BE THE FIFTH LEADING ECONOMY AND
WE HAVE A SPOTTY ELECTRICAL AND
UTILITY SYSTEM AND THIS IS ABOUT
SYSTEM RELIABILITY NOT BE HAPPY
TO MOVE THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- DID YOU
WANNA YEAH.
YOU KNOW I AM I AM GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
BUT I LOOK AT THIS THING AND THE
IDEA THAT THE TWO OF YOU COULD
NOT EVEN AGREE OR DON'T.
HAVE IT IT'S LIKE YOU'RE.
ON TWO DIFFERENT SEPARATE PAGES
ON THE R. P..
YOUR ISSUE AND I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT -- YOU
GUYS GET ON THE SAME PAGE
BECAUSE THAT IS.
REALLY DISCONCERTING TO ME THE
IDEA OF THIS NEW ORGANIZATION OF
THE TREASURES LETTER.
ALSO REALLY WORRIES ME AND I
THINK A LOT OF WORK NEEDS TO BE
DONE I KNOW THIS IS GOING TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
BUT I TO AGREE WITH -- BOTH MY
COLLEAGUES -- IN IN IN TERMS OF
THE WHERE WHERE WHERE WE'RE
GOING BAD.
THIS BILL HAS A LOT OF WORK IN I
DON'T THINK MY OTHER COLLEAGUES
ARE WRONG.
IN THEIR POSITION THAT MAYBE
THIS SHOULD BE A TO YOUR BILL
BUT I'M WILLING TO GIVE YOU THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO THE FLOOR TODAY IF
THESE ARE WORKED OUT.
I'M NOT A BILL SUPPORTED.
THANK YOU EN.
YOU KNOW ON ON THE QUESTION OF A
TO YOUR BILL -- WE STILL HAVE TO
GET GET THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO
WEIGH IN ON THIS AND AND THAT'S
PART OF THIS PROCESS.
AND MAKING IT WORK IS GOING TO
BE.
OF PART OF THE PART OF MAKING IT
WORK IS MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD --
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL
pMEMBERS -- YOU KNOW I KIND OF
MENTION THAT -- IN OUR IN OUR
HEARING ON BANKRUPTCIES.
WHEN WE ASKED ALL THE SPEAKERS
THATWERE BEFORE US EVEN THE
PEOPLE THAT CAME TO SPEAK --
JUSTICE TESTIFY WE WE ASK THEM
THIS QUESTION ABOUT.
OUR SYSTEMS RELIABILITY WHETHER
WE NEEDED CENTRAL PROCUREMENT
AGENCY AND THERE WAS A CHORUS OF
YESES.
THIS IS THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO MOVE FORWARD
WE NEED IT -- KEEP THIS
CONVERSATION ALIVE.
I DON'T THINK THE GOVERNOR WHAT
WHAT WHAT WHAT SIGNED SOMETHING
THAT DOESN'T WORK IN AN
ESSENTIALLY I THINK THE BILL CAN
BE IMPLEMENTED.
I THINK -- IN ITS CURRENT FORM I
THINK YOU CAN BE IMPLEMENTED I
THINK EVEN IN THE FUTURE WE CAN
HAVE CLEAN UP LANGUAGE.
I WOULD EVEN SUPPORT HAVE BEEN
KIND OF DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
DATE.
JUST SO WE KEEP THIS
CONVERSATION ALIVE AND IF WE CAN
ADD THAT AS AN AMENDMENT TO KIND
OF GIVE MEMBERS SOME.
SENSE OF OF OF OF REASSURANCE
THAT WE'RE GONNA WORK OUT
ANYTHING THAT MAY COME UP THAT
DOESN'T MAKE THE BILL
IMPLEMENTABLE FOR WHATEVER
REASON.
THAT WEEKEND TAKE NEXT YEAR'S US
SESSION TO TAKE ANY CORRECTIVE
ACTION.
THAT WOULD ALSO BE SOMETHING
THAT WAS KIND OF A LAY SOME
CONCERNS.
OF OF EVERYBODY INVOLVED SO WE
CAN SOMEHOW PROVIDE THEM SOME
INSURANCE THROUGH -- THE
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS THAT THIS
WILL BE AN OBJECTIVE PROCESS --
I I DON'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING
THAT AFFECTS -- THE CCA'S AS AS
ARE OURS OUR SPONSORS MENTIONED
I AGREE WITH THEM IN TERMS OF
THEIR POSITION.
AND AND WHERE THEY ARE AND WHAT
THEY WOULD DO AND WHAT IT DO.
AND WE CAN ADD A WHOLE LIST OF
OF LANGUAGE.
IN THE PREAMBLE OF THE BILL --
CITING KIND OF THE INTENTIONS
AND GOALS AND AND THERE'S ALL
THESE WAYS THAT WE CAN HANDLE OF
THE KILLING THE BILL TODAY -- I
THINK IS THE WRONG ACTION BY
THIS COMMITTEE IT'S OUR JOB.
TO THIS IS ONE OF OUR ESSENTIAL
JOBS TO WORK TO ACHIEVE.
RELIABILITY IN THE SYSTEM IT
WHEREVER WE CAN AND I'M JUST
ASKING THAT WE WORK TOGETHER ON
THIS THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL FROM MY PERSPECTIVE -- I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT EVERYBODY
WOULD JUST WE HAVE A
DISAGREEMENT HERE WE JUST HAVE
TO WORK THROUGH IT BUT ANYWAY
DID YOU WANNA MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU -- FOR YOUR ATTENTION
ON THIS MATTER BY WE APPRECIATE.
OF THE COMMENTS MADE EVEN BY
THOSE WHO WILL NOT BE ON VOTING
ON THE BILL TODAY -- MY HOPE IS
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS AND FIND SOME GREATER
COMMON GROUND.
AND TO CENTER DOTS POINT I THINK
CENTER WE WE HAVE A
PHILOSOPHICAL DIFFERENCE.
I BELIEVE IN AND WHAT IS BEING
DISCUSSED TODAY AND I'M NOT SURE
THAT IF THE BILL GETS.
TO THE SENATE FLOOR ON THAT ALL
OF THE ISSUES WILL BE YOU KNOW
IRONED OUT THAT THAT THAT.
ALL PARTIES WILL BE ON THE SAME
PAGE I'M NOT SURE -- YOU KNOW
HOW MANY OF YOUR BILLS EVER GET
THERE I KNOW MINE DON'T -- WHERE
YOU HAVE EVERYBODY ON THE SAME
PAGE AND THAT BECOMES THE
DETERMINING FACTOR WHETHER OR
NOT WE?
MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA.
AND SOUL FOR ME YOU KNOW MY MY
COMMITMENT IS TO CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE IN THIS PROCESS I
APPRECIATE -- MEDICINES --
COMMENTS WE WE ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH WITH THEM ON
CREATING A POSSIBLE OPTION TO
KEEP THEM THE PROCUREMENT DRIVER
SEAT -- WE'RE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH CCA'S TO CONTINUE
GIVE THEM THAT THE LOCAL
AUTHORITY AND AUTONOMY THAT THE
HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED.
FOR AND THEN ULTIMATELY -- TO A
SET A SYSTEM IN PLACE THAT THE
STATE HAS THE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY -- FOR TO ENSURE
THAT THE LIGHTS ARE ON AND THAT
RATES CONTINUE TO BE AS
AFFORDABLE AS POSSIBLE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS -- THAT'S THE GOAL.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION ON THE MATTER AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION A YES VOTE TODAY.
CLARIFY THAT YOU WE ARE
ACCEPTING INCLUDING MEDIA
MANAGEMENT SAYS CAR MAKE - ON
THE LANGUAGE TO MAKE CLEAR THE
ABILITY OF THE LOAD SEENITY
SPUR GEAR THEIR PORTION OF THE
IDENTIFIED RESOURCE NEEDS.
FOR RESOURCE ADEQUACY AND I HAVE
A MOTION ON THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB FIFTY SIXTY PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL HI WITH SO
I AM MORE LOT BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D CHIANG DIED.
DIED AYE HERTZBERG HILL MCGUIRE
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
STERN.
STONE.
STONE NO WIENER. SEVENTY THREE
OKAY WE WILL KEEP THE ROLE OF
PROPS MEMBERS THANK YOU AND NOW
WE'LL MOVE ON TO ITEM TWO A. B..
THREE EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THE THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES THE ARE GOING TO
WORKING POOR ENERGY EFFICIENT
HOUSING PROGRAM.
IMPROVE ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND
FARM WORKER HOUSING AND REQUIRED
TO TO BE ADMINISTERED.
BY DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MERRICK MEMBERS
MARIN BE NOW BEHALF LCAL BUT AT
THE AYE CAMPESINA CALIFORNIA
WHEN WE WANT TO THANK THAT
COMMITTEE AND STAFF. FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS BILL -- ON
MAKING SHORT.
LAUGH BUT AT THE A COMPASS HE
NOW SERVES THE HARD TO REACH
AREAS.
IN RURAL CALIFORNIA.
WE NEED A PROGRAM IN PLACE TO
HELP FARMWORKERS WHETHER I THEIR
HOMES AYE DADDY REDUCES THE CAR
IN PAIN ANY AND INCREASES THEIR
DISPOSABLE INCOME.
OUR RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
WILL.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE -- SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT ON THREE
EIGHTY SIX TIFFANY VAN HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FISH AND SEA AND
TO MANAGE ACCOUNTS ON SUPPORT.
ALLOW THE FOLLIES OF CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA HUMAN DEVELOPMENT
CENTRAL VALLEY OPPORTUNITY
CENTER AND PROTEUS COOPERATED IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANYONE OPPOSITION.
ALL MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND JUST WANTED -- TO INSURE
YOUR SUCCESS IN MINOR.
YES WE ARE THANK YOU -- WE'LL
MOTION CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
DID YOU THE CENTER SKINNER DID
YOU WANNA.
SPEAK.
NO I'VE TO SUPPORT THE BILL OKAY
THEY MOVED -- CENTERS -- BUT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB THREE EIGHTY SIXTY PASSES
AMENDED HER APPROPRIATIONS WEST
SO I WAS SO I'M MORE LOCK
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHIANG DIED HERTZBERG
HILL MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO ICE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN STONE STONE NO WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER AYE. FIVE VERY WELL WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OF THE PRESS
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
CENTER OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING [inaudible] ONE
RESEARCHER.
NO BEFORE YOU PRESENT I JUST
WANTED -- TO WE HAD SOME
AMENDMENTS AND WE WE'VE BEEN
KIND OF DISCUSSING THEM AND IF
YOU CAN A YOU YOU HAD A PROPOSAL.
THAT WENT AROUND THE AMENDMENTS
AND I JUST WANTED TO ASK YOU TO
PRESENT THAT FIRST REGARDING.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND AND I WANNA START BY
THANKING YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON THE BILL --
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS RAISE
CONCERNS THAT THE BILL DOES NOT
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT PAYMENT
METHODS -- I WAS SPECIFICALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE NEED FOR
NETWORK MEMBERSHIP IN ORDER TO
CHARGE AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE --
THE COMMITTEES IDENTIFIED A
VALID CONCERN AND I'M PREPARED
TO TAKE AN AMENDMENT THAT WOULD
SUBSTANTIALLY LIMIT THE BILL.
I AM PROPOSING THAT TO REQUIRE
THAT ALL CHARGING STATIONS BE
EQUIPPED WITH AN ONSIDE ON AN ON
SITE CREDIT CARD READER.
IN ADDITION TO A TOLL FREE PHONE
NUMBER TO PROCESS A CREDIT CARD
PAYMENT.
THE ONSITE CREDIT CARD READER
REQUIREMENT CAN BE SATISFIED BY
EITHER AND EMV CHIP READER OR A
CONTACTLESS.
CARD READER.
YES -- CONTACTLESS CARDS ARE OUR
CREDIT AND DEBIT CARDS IT'S
SOMETHING I'VE LEARNED A LOT
ABOUT THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS --
THAT ARE TAPPED INSTEAD OF
SWIPED THE IN THE UNITED STATES
MAJOR BANKS HAVE BEGUN ROLLING
OUT CONTACTLESS CARDS FOR
EXAMPLE CAPITAL ONE HAS AYE
CONTACTLESS CARD SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN CHASE
WILL ROLL OUT CONTACTLESS CARDS
FOR ALL OF ITS CREDIT AND DEBIT
CARD HOLDERS BY THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN MASTERCARD
EXPECTS CONTACTLESS CARDS TO
ACCOUNT FOR TWO THIRDS.
OF TOTAL PAYMENT VOLUMES WITHIN
TWO YEARS AND VISA EXPECTS ONE
HUNDRED MILLION CONTACTLESS
CARDS TO BE ISSUED BY THE END OF
THIS YEAR.
REQUIRING CREDIT CARD READERS ON
EVERY CHARGING STATION ERASES
THE CONCERN ABOUT CUSTOMERS ONLY
BEING ABLE TO PAY THROUGH MOBILE
APPLICATIONS ARE IF ID CARDS AND
OVER THE PHONE -- I THINK THIS
IS A FAIR COMPROMISE REALLY WANT
TO THINK THE CHAIR AGAIN FOR
WORKING WITH ME TO GET HERE --
IT ENSURES THAT THERE IS
ACCESSIBLE AND CONVENIENT WAYS
TO PAY FOR ALL CUSTOMERS WITHOUT
REQUIRING ANY SORT OF MEMBERSHIP.
WHILE ALSO GIVING CHARGING
STATION PROVIDERS THE
FLEXIBILITY TO CHOOSE THE TYPE
OF CARD READER THAT MEETS
CONSUMER NEEDS.
AND DOES NOT POSE NEGATIVE COST
RELIABILITY AND SECURITY
IMPLICATIONS. TO REACH OUR
STATES GOAL OF THE POINT ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE WILL NEED
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
PUBLIC CHARGING STATIONS.
RIGHT NOW RIGHT NOW WE HAVE ONLY.
TWENTY THOUSAND HOWEVER THE
EVERY THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
HAS RECENTLY ADOPTED A
REGULATION MANDATING THAT ALL
PUBLIC CHARGING STATIONS BE
OUTFITTED WITH THE EMV CHIP
CREDIT CARD READERS.
AND WHILE I APPRECIATE THE AIR
BEES INTENTIONS THE RECENT
CHANGES TO EXTENDED TIME FOR
COMPLIANCE THIS REGULATION WOULD
SLOW DEPLOYMENT AT A TIME WHEN
WE REALLY NEED TO BE REDUCING
BARRIERS.
THE EMV CHIP READER MANDATE
NEGATIVELY AFFECTS THE COST
RELIABILITY AND SECURITY OF
CHARGING STATIONS -- AN INCREASE
IN THE COST OF YOU CHARGING
STATIONS MEANS WILL END UP WITH
FEWER CHARGING STATIONS OVERALL.
AND TAXPAYER AND REPAIR DOLLARS
THE STATE IS INVESTING IN THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL NOT GO AS
FAR.
SITE HOSTS THE SMALL BUSINESSES
AND RETAILERS WHO HOST CHARGING
STATIONS WILL BE SETTLED WITH
HIGHER MAINTENANCE COSTS TO
COMPLY.
A ARBY'S ANALYSIS NOTES THAT THE
HARDWARE IN OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE COSTS OF AN EMV CHIP
READER.
AMOUNT TO APPROXIMATELY THREE
THOUSAND SEVENTY ONE DOLLARS
OVER THE CHARGING STATIONS
LIFETIME. FOR THIS INTO
PERSPECTIVE THE PRICE OF A LEVEL
TWO CHARGING STATION ITSELF
RANGES FROM THREE TO SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
OUR LIMITED RESOURCES ARE BEST
SPENT DEPLOYING INFRASTRUCTURE
EQUITABLY AND EFFICIENTLY TO
ENSURE THIS TECHNOLOGY WHICH IS
ALL COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTING OUR STATE'S AMBITIOUS.
CLINIC GOALS.
WITH THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS --
THE BILL ONE SHORE UNIVERSAL
ACCESS AND GIVE PROVIDERS
REASONABLE FLEXIBILITY TO ENSURE
THEIR PAYMENT TECHNOLOGIES
SECURE.
RELIABLE AND COST EFFECTIVE
ENABLING US TO CONTINUE
ACCELERATING THE INFRASTRUCTURE
DEPLOYMENT NEEDED TO MEET OUR
STATE SCHOOLS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE.
AND WITH ME TODAY OUR FRIEND
KNOW WHERE AN OB LA -- TRICKLE
WE CHECK CHECK CHECK OUR E. --
TO BE DESERVES WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING OF THANK YOU
CHARLIE SO AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS UP THE
RUSSIA CAN WE I WORK FOR A
COMPANY CALLED VOLT ARE CHARGING
A BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO.
WHEN I AM THE CHAIR OF THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION -- DISPOSITION IS
COMPRISED OF LEADING COMPANIES
ARE THE DESIGN MANUFACTURE --
INSTALLING OPERATING MAINTAINING
BE CHARGING STATION AND SERVICES
IN CALIFORNIA AND ELSEWHERE --
THE MAJORITY OF OUR MEMBERS
HEADQUARTERS IN CALIFORNIA --
UPON FIRST TWO THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPEN DIALOGUE -- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE MOST
IMPORTANT CONCERN HERE IS
UNIVERSAL OPEN ACCESS.
WE WANT TO READ TO READ TO THAT
OF ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE IF
ELECTRIFIED OF VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION.
ARE COMMITTED TO PROVIDING
UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO REVIEW
CHARGING ACROSS ALL REGIONS AND
INCOME LEVELS UP IN THE STATE --
THIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN OF
NOTED ON EXECUTIVE ORDER BE
FORTY EIGHT EIGHTEEN CALLS FOR
DEPLOYMENT OF FIVE MILLION.
OTHER EMISSION VEHICLES IN
CALIFORNIA BY TWENTY THIRTY AND
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND TV
CHARGERS FOR COMPARISON -- THERE
ARE CURRENTLY ON ABOUT EIGHTY
FIVE HUNDRED GASOLINE STATIONS
IN.
CALIFORNIA.
SO ACCEPTING CREDIT CARD PAYMENT
IS KEY IN ENSURING THAT THIS
LARGE DEPLOYMENT OF THE FOR
STRUCTURE ALLOWS FOR UNIVERSAL
OPEN ACCESS.
UP TO ALL THE SINGLE STATEMENT
EXPERTS.
ARM FOR US OUR MAIN CONCERN IS
IS THAT IS TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL IT --
AND AND REALLY IMPORTANT THREE
THE OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE
COSTS OF DEATH INFRASTRUCTURE
GAIL -- DMV READER KEEPS CREATE
RELIABILITY ISSUES OF ONE AS AN
EXAMPLE -- THE ENVY READERS FOR
PARKING METERS OF THE FAILURE
RATE OF ABOUT 10% PER YEAR SO.
OF A DISCO ON THE COST OF
MAINTENANCE ALONE WILL BE ON AN
UNREASONABLE BURDEN WHICH WILL
SLOW ADOPTION WHICH WE LIMIT.
THE THE SCALE AT WHICH WE CAN
DEPLOY THIS CHARGING STATION.
AND OF COURSE I MEAN DOES COST
WITH INDIVIDUAL BE INEVITABLY --
SORRY BE CARRIED ACROSS ALL TO
THE AND USERS NOT ONLY IN BACK
THE ADOPTION OF FEES -- BUT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT LOWER
INCOME COMMUNITIES -- TO AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR REQUIRES
THAT YOU BE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE BE DEPLOYS
ALLOWING UNIVERSAL OPEN ACCESS --
THROUGH UBIQUITOUS TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL CREDIT CARD PAYMENT
BEANS.
WITHOUT THE REQUIREMENT OF
PROVISIONS FOR FISHING OR
MEMBERSHIP AND SO WITH THIS
ALTERNATIVE I BE FOURTEEN TWENTY
FOUR ENSURES THAT -- THE
TECHNOLOGY PAYMENT OR PAYMENT
THE COLLISION CLEMENTA -- WILL
NOT REPRESENT A COST BURDEN THAT
WILL NEGATIVELY BACK DEPLOYMENT.
ALL IN THIS CONTEXT A HIGH
RESPECTIVELY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE'S THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS FRED NO OR REPRESENT
THE SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP AND WE WE SALUTE THE
AUTHOR IN THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
WORK BEING DONE ON A. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR VERY MUCH
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL BECAUSE
IT WILL BE OF ELECTRIC VEHICLE
SERVICE PROVIDERS THE
FLEXIBILITY TO RESPOND. TO
CONCERT CUSTOMER CHOICE.
AND PAYMENT TECHNOLOGY
DEVELOPMENTS AS THEY OCCUR -- WE
SUPPORT THE AMENDMENTS IN MOVING
IN THAT DIRECTION BECAUSE WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
THAT THERE BE A ROBUST LIST OF
PAYMENT OPTIONS SO ALL
COMMUNITIES CAN ACCESS.
THESE CHARGING STATIONS AND AND
ALSO PROVIDE OUR PLEASED TO
HINDER INTER FRAUD AND OTHER --
MEANS WHEN WHEN -- WHEN
DEPLOYING THESE TECHNOLOGIES?
I AS THE AUTHOR STATED WE HAVE
TO WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD AND DEPLOY -- TO
GET TO OUR FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
ELECTRIC VEHICLE GOAL BY TWENTY
THIRTY AS WELL AS TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND CHARGING STATIONS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE CALIFORNIA
LEADS THE NATION IN SO MANY WAYS
PARTICULARLY IN CLIMATE ACTION
WE THINK THIS BILL FITS NICELY
INTO THAT.
FUNDAMENTAL GOALS SO THANK YOU
TO THE COMMITTEE WE WOULD OUR
DRIVER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
FAMILY HAVE ASSEMBLY HAVE MC
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
CATHERINE BRANDENBURG ONS.
ON BEHALF OF CINEMA CLEAN POWER
IN SUPPORT.
MARK FENCER MAKER FOR POTENTIAL
A CLEAN ENERGY MUCH THANKS TO
THE AUTHOR IN SUPPORT.
KIM DIMITRI WITH TECHNO IN
SUPPORT.
AND SMART WOULD CHARGE PER IN
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU WANT TO STAY UP
. ONE
MISTER MY NAME IS ROCKY RUSHING --
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS ROCKY
RUSSIAN WITH COALITION FOR CLEAN
AIR THANKS SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING
ME BEARD DAY FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK GOD STAFF FOR THE VERY
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS.
BE GREATLY APPRECIATED -- WE'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR.
FOR SHOWING FLEXIBILITY IN
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE THAT
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
[inaudible]
ALLOWING.
CREDIT CARD READERS TO BE
INCLUDED ON THE IN THE THE CARD
IS STATIONED.
AT JUST ONE POINT OUT AT LAST
MONTH'S CAR MEETING -- THE BOARD
APPROVED A ESP E. S..
E. V. S. E. PAYMENT STANDARDS
THAT INCLUDES AN EMV CARD CHIP
READER.
WE SHOULD KNOW THAT THE CARBS
FINAL PROPOSED REGULATION
INCORPORATED COMPROMISES THAT
ADDRESS MANY CONCERNS USED TO
JUSTIFY THIS BILL INCLUDING.
ELIMINATING THE RETROFIT
REQUIREMENT FOR EXISTING
STATIONS CENTER CORBETT THE
AUTHOR OF FORTY FOUR TESTIFIED
AT THE CAR HERE AND SAID THAT
HER GOAL IS GETTING.
SB FOUR FIVE FOUR PASSED WHAT
COULD BE DESCRIBED IN ONE WORD
THAT ONE WORD IS ACCESS --
UNFORTUNATELY AT AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR BY THIS POINT HAS
REPRESENTED THE ANTITHESIS OF
THAT GOAL.
AS WE KNOW THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR IMAGE NEARLY HALF OF THE
STATE'S GHGS.
WE HAVE THE DIRTIEST AIR IN THE
NATION MORE PEOPLE DIE FROM
TRAFFIC POLLUTION THAN IN
TRAFFIC ACCIDENTS AND THAT I
THINK -- WE'RE WELL PAST THE
TIME WHEN.
BILLS MOTIVATED BY SELF INTEREST
SHOULD BE REJECT REJECTED -- AS
YOU KNOW.
AT SENATOR -- SB TWELVE SEVENTY
FIVE OF TWENTY FOURTEEN BY
CENTER DAILY ON AT ENVISIONED A
MARKET FOR EVEY IS THAT NOT JUST
A THAT WAS NOT JUST FOR THE TECH
SAVVY IN THE WELL HEELED BUT FOR
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES --
MODERATE PEOPLE OF MODERATE
INCOME -- AND THAT. TWELVE
SEVENTY FIVE THE STATE FOR THAT
BILL WAS SET BY.
FOUR FIVE FOUR AND THAT PROVIDED
THE FRAMEWORK FOR EVEY CHARGING
STATIONS TO OPERATE LIKE GAS
STATIONS TO BEST TO SIT ASSIST
THE STATE IN REACHING ITS ZEVON
GHG A REDUCTION.
IN AIR POLLUTION GOALS.
IN DRIVERS CAN FILL UP A AT A
GAS STATION WITH CHARGE CARDS
AND THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO SO --
AT CHARGING STATIONS.
WITH WITH THAT WE WOULD -- I
WOULD CONCLUDE MY REMARKS --
WITH THE FINAL PROVISO THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
CAN USE -- THEIR CHARGE CARDS
ADD CHARGING STATIONS AND THAT
THE EQUIPMENT SHOULD BE --
INCLUDING EMV EMV.
CHIP READER THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS STAND THEM
BLACK REPRESENTING SIEMENS
SIEMENS IS ONE OF THE WORLD'S
LARGEST TO ENGINEERING COMPANIES
IN CALIFORNIA ALONE THERE'S OVER
FOUR THOUSAND EMPLOYEES EIGHTY
TWO BUSINESS SITES.
MANY OF WHICH ARE IN MEMBERS
DISTRICTS HERE -- WE WE HAVE
BEEN IN OPPOSITION SINCE THE
BEGINNING AND WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE -- THESE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE JUST HEARD
OUR NEWS TO ALSO RESPECTFULLY
THIS IS THE KEY ISSUE IN THE
REASON WHY WE'VE BEEN OPPOSED.
THE ONE THING THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE AS WE GO THROUGH THIS
FOR THE RECORD OUR UNDERSTANDING
AND AND A BRIEF CONVERSATION
WITH THE ASSEMBLYMAN AS WERE AS
WE'RE GOING THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
IS THIS WILL THEN BE TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL THAT IS ALL TYPES OF
CREDIT CARDS WILL NOW BE
ACCEPTED ON READERS AND ALLOWED.
A R. B. AND OTHER AGENCIES CAN
AND ALLOW THAT TO BE UED YES OR
REQUIRED.
YES ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU WITHOUT TO SAID AGAIN
I'M NOT HAD A CHANCE IN THE LAST
SECONDS TO TALK TO MY CLIENT YET
BUT IT IS LIKELY THAT WERE MOVES
OFF OPPOSITION.
I DON'T KNOW THAT FOR SURE BUT
THIS IS DEFINITELY A LARGE STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THANK YOU TO THE THE THE CHAIR
AND TO THE AUTHOR FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS IF THERE ARE SOME
ADDITIONAL ISSUES OBVIOUSLY WILL
FOLLOW UP WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
UGH GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
CAPULETS REPRESENT PLUG IN
AMERICA I WALKED IN LATE SO I
JUST GOT THE TAIL END OF THAT --
BUT WE WERE THE SPONSORS OF THE
ORIGINAL -- SENATOR KERR BUT
BILL SB FOUR FIFTY FOUR AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE AIR
BOARD -- AT THEIR LAST MEETING.
AND THEY HAVE OBVIOUSLY
IMPLEMENTED THE REGULATIONS NOW
SO WE SEE THIS BILL AS
UNNECESSARY BUT HAPPY TO
CERTAINLY LOOK AT THE AMENDMENTS
AND TALK TO THE AUTHOR OF
FURTHER THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS NIKITA CROWDED
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL ALSO REGRETFULLY
POSED BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
LOOKING AT THE AMENDMENT AND THE
LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
AARON RODRIGUEZ FOR THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS -- WILL
ALSO TAKE A LOOK AT AMENDMENTS.
FOR CALLING SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA WILL TAKE A LOOK AT
THE MOMENTS BUT IN OPPOSITION
RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THE ONE DO YOU WANT.
TO CLOSING COMMENTS THANK YOU
AGAIN TO THE CHAIR -- AND YOUR
STAFF AND AND I DID WANT MAKE
SURE THEY STATE THAT A
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH YOU -- ON THE LANGUAGE OF
THE BILL AS IT MOVES FORWARD IF
IT MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CAN WE
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THE BILL
WE HAVE A LOTION -- CLERK.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR KEY
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WAS SO HIGH WITH SO I'M MORE
LACK BRADFORD.
BEDFORD I'D CHIANG DIED
HERTZBERG HILL MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO ICE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN STONE.
STONE AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE [inaudible]
NEEDS.
ONE LOOK AT THE ROLE OF THE
PRESS MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE.
GOOD MORNING SIR.
HI GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WANT TO SAY FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE AMENDMENTS.
THAT HAVE BEEN OFFERED -- I
ACCEPT THEM I COULDN'T HAVE DONE
IT BETTER SO AGAIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE AMENDMENTS.
DURING THE MINISTER COMPLEX FIRE
WHAT WAS AT THAT TIME THE
LARGEST FIRE IN STATE HISTORY --
WE HAD IT WITH MUTUAL AID
FIREFIGHTERS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE TO SEND UPON THE COMPLEX --
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN PARTICULAR
EXPERIENCED -- THROTTLING OR
SLOWING DOWN OF THEIR DATA.
THEY THEY CALL THEIR SERVICE
PROVIDER TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THROTTLING WAS LIFTED IT WAS NOT
LIFTED THEY WERE UP SOLD OR
ATTEMPTED TO BE UP SOLD TO
SOMETHING AND PUT INTO CALL THIS
OTHER NUMBER.
PORTANTINO FIX THAT MAKE SURE
THAT THIS NEVER OCCURS AGAIN TO
ANY FIRE FIRES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ANY FIRST RESPONDERS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RESPONDING TO AN EMERGENCY.
AGAIN I THINK THE AMENDMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE REALLY HELP
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THAT -- WITH ME I HAVE --
FROM THE CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION MELINDA HUNLEY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL FOR THE VERY REASONS.
THAT MISTER LEVINE JUST GAVE
FIRE FIGHTING IS A CONTINUALLY
EVOLVING PROFESSION THEY MEET
NEW CHALLENGES LARGER FIRES
LARGER NATURAL DISASTERS
EARTHQUAKES FLOODS.
THE WILD FIRES IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS AS YOU'RE WELL AWARE ARE
JUST SIMPLY UNPRECEDENTED.
AND IN ORDER TO FIGHT THESE
FIRES FIREFIGHTERS JUST LIKE ANY
OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCY OR
ANY OTHER.
PROFESSION ARE REQUIRING MORE
AND MORE ON TECHNOLOGY.
IN ORDER TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS IN ORDER.
TO PROPERLY ALLOCATE THE
RESOURCES TO THE AREAS THAT NEED
THEM THE FASTEST IN THE MOST
THEY NEED ACCESS TO REAL TIME.
INFORMATION FROM THEIR
COMMUNICATION CENTERS AND WE
RELY HEAVILY ON INTERNET
CONNECTIONS TO PROVIDE THIS.
LAST WEEK IN MY COUNTY I AM THE
EMERGENCY COMMUNICATIONS MANAGER
FOR THE KERN COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
AND ON THE FOURTH OF JULY WHICH
IS ALREADY THE BUSIEST DAY OF
THE YEAR WE HAVE.
THE FOURTH AND THE FIFTH THE TWO
LARGEST EARTHQUAKES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS.
IT HIT THE HARDEST IN OUR
COMMUNITY OF RIDGE CREST WHICH
IS IN THE HIGH DESERT AND ON THE
FAR EDGE OF OUR EIGHT THOUSAND
SQUARE MILE COUNTY.
THE ABILITY FOR THE TWO STATIONS
IN THAT AREA TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS REAL TIME INFORMATION
FROM OUR COMMUNICATION CENTER.
IN THE IMMEDIATE AFTERMATH OF
THIS EARTHQUAKE.
SAVED LIVES THEY SIMPLY WEREN'T
RESPONDING TO WHAT WAS IN FRONT
OF AND THEY WERE RESPONDING TO
THE EMERGENCIES THAT NEEDED HELP
THE FASTEST.
WHILE WE WERE WORKING TO GET
RESOURCES INTO THEIR AREA TO
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT THEY NEEDED.
WE ALSO AS PUBLIC SAFETY HAVE TO
RELY HEAVILY NOW ON THE INTERNET.
JUST LIKE ANY OTHER AGENCY IN
GETTING INFORMATION OUT TO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THE DAYS OF TUNING INTO YOUR
LOCAL NEWS AGENCY.
ARE GOING THE WAY OF WIRE LE OF
WIRE LINE PHONES PEOPLE WANT
INFORMATION THEY WANT IT QUICKLY
THEY WANTED ACCURATELY AND THEY
WANTED IN REAL TIME AND WE RELY
HEAVILY ON FACEBOOK.
AND TWITTER IN ORDER TO GET
INFORMATION OUT TO OUR CITIZENS.
WHERE DO WE EVACUATE TO WHETHER
TO SHELTER IN PLACE WHAT AREAS
TO AVOID WAREHOUSE MATT
SITUATIONS ARE OCCURRING?
AND AGAIN WITHOUT A ROBUST
INTERNET CONNECTION WE ARE
HAMPERED IN OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE THE BEST SERVICE TO OUR
CITIZENS AND YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY.
AND I HOPE THAT.
WE WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND IT WE ALSO ERNESTO FALCON
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL FOR THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
JOINING US.
THANK YOU CHAIR WHO IS.
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY HERE IS
MY MY NAME'S REST OF TALKING ON
THIS SENIOR LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
FOR THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION -- WE WERE FOUND IN
IN -- NINETEEN NINETY AND RELY
ON OUR ENGINEERS ARE LAWYERS AND
ARE ACTIVISTS TO DEFEND THE
VALUES AND FOCUS AND DEFENDER
VALUES AND FOCUS ON ENSURING
THAT OUR RATES ARE PER SERVICE
AS OUR USE OF TECHNOLOGY GROWS.
THE SUCH A PROBLEM BEFORE ALL OF
US HERE IS THE FACT THAT THE
FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION IS NO LONGER IS DOING
ITS JOB.
THE AGENCY SURRENDERED ITS
AUTHORITY OVER BRIBING PROVIDERS
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
THAT'S CAN ORDER PROMOTE
POLICIES THAT IMPACT PRIVACY
COMPETITION UNIVERSAL ACCESS NON
DISCRIMINATION AND MOST
IMPORTANT BEFORE US RIGHT NOW
PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE FCC ADMITTED TO THE COURTS
DURING ITS LITIGATION OVER ITS
DECISION TO DEREGULATE THE
INDUSTRY BUT IT DID NOT THINK
ABOUT HE ISSUE PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND THAT IT SHOULD DEAL WITH
THESE ISSUES AFTER THE FACT.
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY COUNCIL
WHO WAS A PARTICIPANT THAT
LITIGATION -- RESPONDED THAT IT
THAT IS ESSENTIALLY SAYING THE
REGULATOR SHOULD WAIT UNTIL
PEOPLE ARE DEAD BEFORE TAKING
ACTION.
THERE'S NOTHING COMPLICATED
ABOUT THIS LEGISLATION THERE'S
NOT BECAUSE THERE'S NOTHING
COMPLICATED ABOUT WHAT VERIZON
DID DURING THE SANTA CLARA FIRES.
IN FACT RISING HAS MADE VERY
CLEAR BUT THEY WERE IN THE WRONG.
WHAT HAPPENED IN SANTA CLARA IN
THE MIDDLE OF OUR STATE'S WORST
FIRE IN HISTORY HAD NOTHING TO
DO OF ENGINEERING AND NOTHING TO
DO OF NEVER CAPACITY?
AND AND NOTHING TO DO WITH
ANYTHING THAT RESEMBLED THE
TECHNICAL RATIONALE.
THERE WERE NO GOOD REASONS FOR
FIRE DEPARTMENTS BROADBAND
SERVICE TO BE THROTTLE DOWN TO
ONE TWO HUNDREDTH OF ITS
ORIGINAL SPEED IN THE MIDDLE OF
AN EMERGENCY AND THUS RENDERING
IT USELESS.
SUCH CONDUCT WOULD HAVE BEEN THE
LEGAL ADVICE HE'S RISO FEDERALLY
REGULATED COM CARRIERS AS SUCH
IT AS SUCH AND THESE ARE
PROHIBITED FROM ENGAGING IN ON
JUSTIN ON REGIONAL PRACTICES.
NOW I'M NOT SAYING THE RISE IN
PLOTTED TO DO HARM OR SCAR
SCHEME BUT I'M JUST SAYING IS
THERE'S NO GOVERNMENT ENTITY
RESPONSIBLE FOR BALANCING OUT --
PROFIT MOTIVE TO GET OTHER
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATIONS SUCH AS
PUBLIC SAFETY.
MERGE THE OBLIGATIONS OF OFF AND
I HAVE OFTEN BEEN A SHARED
BURDEN BETWEEN GOVERNMENT AND
PRIVATE INDUSTRIES THAT PROVIDE
CRITICAL AND ESSENTIAL SERVICES.
AND I DON'T SEE ANY TECHNICAL
REASON WHY WIRELESS CARRIERS ARE
ABLE TO TO MANAGER SERVICES TO
MEET THE GOALS OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
AND FIVE RISING ALREADY
COMMITTED SIMPLY BANDIT FARLEY
ALL TOGETHER FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
ENTITIES.
GIVEN AT THESE PRICES ARE
HEAVILY IN THE PROVINCE OF
ENGINEERING AND LEGAL ANALYSIS
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE IT'S A
LOT IT'S LOGICAL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO BE AN OVERSEER --
IN THIS RESPONSE AND IN IT
BECAUSE IT'S EASIER ALWAYS
QUESTIONS ABOUT REASONABLE
NETWORK MANAGEMENT.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL I URGE AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
LEGISLATION.
AND BELIEVE THAT SO LONG AS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
EFFECTIVELY ABANDONED ITS ROLE
THAT OVERSEE -- AND PROMOTE
THESE AND ADDRESS THESE ISSUES A
PUBLIC SAFETY THE THE STATE
REALLY HAS TO BE MUCH MORE
INVOLVED.
IN THESE MATTERS WHERE THE
PUBLIC INTEREST COLLIDE TO FOR
PROFIT MOTIVE.
ESPECIALLY IN AREAS OF PUBLIC
SAFETY.
I LOOK FOR TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE
OTHER -- THE PERSON'S SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION ANYONE
OPPOSITION -- IN SUPPORT MICHAEL
RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA
COUNTY.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS STEVE
CARLSON FOR A C. T. I. A LET ME
START OUT BY -- EXPRESSING OUR
ESTEEM.
FOR A FIRST RESPONDER A PARTNERS --
AND THE THERE'S FOR WHICH OUR
SERVICES HAVE -- WE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY WORK AND
WORK THE BEST WAY.
AS A AS THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT --
THIS WAS PROMPTED BY A CUSTOMER
SERVICE BLUNDER PURE AND SIMPLE
WAS A BLUNDER -- AND WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR --
AS WE MOVE FORWARD -- TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE MECHANICS OF HOW
THIS WORK WORK.
OUR MEETING WITH THE FIRE CHIEFS
TOMORROW -- AND THE AUTHOR TO
WORK ON MECHANICS THE AMENDMENTS
THAT -- HAVE BEEN -- PROPOSED BY
THE COMMITTEE REALLY MOVE MOVE
US UP IN A IN A RIGHT DIRECTION
ONE OF THE THINGS WE HAVE TO
KNOW IS WHO IS THERE.
AND THE PUBLIC SAFETY ACCOUNTS
THAT ARE THERE AT THE FIRE SO WE
MAKE SURE.
THAT THEY'RE HANDLED CORRECTLY
AND WOULD WANT TO WORK THROUGH
THOSE MECHANICS WITH.
A WITH THE AUTHOR -- AND AND
WORK ON LANGUAGE WITH THE
COMMITTEE -- LANGUAGE IS GONNA
BE IMPORTANT HERE WE WE MADE
SOME -- REQUESTS A OF OF THE
AUTHOR -- ON SOME SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE WE'D LIKE.
TO LIKE PUBLIC SAFE DESIGNATED
PUBLIC SAFETY PLANTS IS THE WAY
THAT THESE ARE CODED I'M BY THE
COMPANIES AND THAT'S THAT WAY WE
KNOW.
THE COMPANIES KNOW WHO WAS THERE
UP WE ARE.
WE ARE NOT OPPOSING THE CONCEPT
WE ARE WORKING ON OF THE
MECHANICS OF HOW TO MAKE THIS
WORK PROPIEDADES TO MAKE SURE
THAT NUMBER ONE THAT THERE'S NO
UNDUE CONGESTION IN TIMES OF
PUBLIC SAFETY RESPONSE.
AND MAKE SURE COMMUNICATIONS AT
THAT TIME SO WE WANT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK -- BEFORE THIS GETS TO
THE FLOOR HAVE THIS -- AND HAVE
THIS THE COMPLETELY COOKED AND
BAKED WE LOOK FOR TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE
STAFF ON THAT LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
COMMENTS ANYONE ELSE
[inaudible]
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
CLOSING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIR OF
THE YOU KNOW COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH THE OPPOSITION.
THOSE ARE PRETTY PRETTY PRETTY
WARM WORDS -- SO YEAH WE'RE
WE'RE IN AGREEMENT THAT THERE'S
A HUMAN ELEMENT -- AND THIS IS
WHAT THIS PROPOSED LAW SEEKS TO
ADDRESS AND AND AGAIN I'M REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE COMMITTEE ON ON
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL -- WHICH
I THINK -- REALLY DO --
SOMETHING THAT THAT WE HAD
INTENDED ALL THE ALL THE WITH
ALL THE WAY IN AND SOMETIMES A
COMMITTEE HAS TO STEP IN AND
MAKE THAT LANGUAGE WORKS OF
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I STRUCK
LAST FOR I THINK.
GOOD WE ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
WITH THE MOTION CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AB SIXTY NINETY NINETY PASSES
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR WEST
SO.
BY WITH SO I MORE LOCK BRADFORD
CHIANG.
CHING AYE DODD HERTZBERG HILL
MCGUIRE REVEAL [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
TURN.
STONE STONE AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE [inaudible]
VERY WELL.
I'VE BEEN ASKED.
FIVE WE WILL GET THE RELEVANT.
A FAKE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN CENTERS.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A FIVE MINUTE
RECESS [inaudible]
MORE MEMBERS
PUBLIC JUST A FEW
HERE FOR THE NEXT THE BILL WE'RE
GONNA WE'RE GONNA TAKE OR THE
TWENTY MINUTE RECESS AND WE'LL
BE BACK -- TO GIVE THE AUTHOR
TIME TO COME UP AND PRESENT HER
BILL.
AND WILL HAVE WILL RECONVENE IN
TWENTY MINUTES YOU CAN TAKE A
BREAK
GLAZER GERMAN WERE BACKS MEMBERS
WAKE MAKE THEIR WAY WILL GET
STARTED ON THIS PRESENTATION BY --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GO GONZALEZ ON
ITEM NUMBER FIVE ON THE CALENDAR
A. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX WELCOME.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
CHAIRMAN FIRST I'D LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
THANK THEM FOR THE WORK ON THIS
BILL AB THIRTEEN SIXTY STICK
WITH FIX WOULD EXTEND THE
PROVISION IN THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES CODE PRESERVING THE
LEGISLATURE'S OVERSIGHT OF VOICE
OVER INTERNET PROTOCOL.
AND INTERNET PROTOCOL ENABLE
SERVICES RATHER THAN LETTING
THESE POLICY QUESTIONS BE TURNED
OVER TO A CUMBERSOME REGULATORY
AGENCIES.
WOULD ALSO PROVIDE NEW
PROTECTIONS FOR CONSUMERS OF
THESE SERVICES BY ESTABLISHING A
SEVENTY TWO HOUR STANDARD FOR
RESTORATION OF SERVICES AFTER
REPORTED OUTAGE IN WHICH STEPS
TO RESTORE THE SERVICE MUST BE
INITIATED WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS.
IT CREATES AN OPTION FOR A BILL
CREDIT TO CUSTOMERS WHEN
SERVICES NOT BEEN RESTORED
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
IT REQUIRES DISCLOSURE REGARDING
BACKUP BATTERY NEEDS FOR VOICE
AND ALTERNATIVES WHICH EXIST
INCLUDING THE RIGHT TO BASIC
SERVICE.
AND IT REQUIRES THAT IT
COMPLAINTS FROM WHITE CUSTOMERS
RECEIVE BY THE CPUC BE INCLUDED
IN A REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND REPORT TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR POSSIBLE ENFORCEMENT
ACTION.
IN TWENTY TWELVE THE LEGISLATURE
CODIFIED A POLICY RESERVING ANY
STATE REGULATION AVOID AN I. P.
ENABLE SERVICES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
SINCE IN CALIFORNIA'S HAVE
CONTINUED BENEFITING FROM THE
SERVICES WHICH OFFER INNOVATION
AND LOW PRICES. FOR COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE WERE CALLING HOME
MEANS PLACING A CALL TO A
FOREIGN COUNTRY I P. ENABLE
SERVICES ARE AN ESSENTIAL PART
OF STAYING CONNECTED WITHOUT
HAVING TO PAY COSTLY LONG
DISTANCE OR INTERNATIONAL
TELEPHONE BILLS.
HOWEVER THE CLARITY PROVIDE WITH
THE LEGISLATURE'S EXCLUSIVE
AUTHORITY OVER THE SERVICES WILL
SENSE THAT JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY UNLESS LEGISLATIVE ACTION
HAPPENS NOW.
THE LEGISLATURE'S ALSO BEST
POISED TO SET POLICY FOR THE
SERVICES WE THINK IT'S MUCH
BETTER THAN AN AGENCY THAT'S
PROVEN ITSELF TOO SLOW. TO ACT
IN A TIMELY MANNER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU AND JUST STOPPED
MEMBERS -- EVERY SINGLE MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE WAS PROVIDED
KIND OF AN ATTACHMENT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS SORT OF IN PERSON
PROPOSED -- THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS -- SO.
IF.
YOU HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO
REVIEW THEM WITH.
A WEEK WE CAN GO OVER THEM AT
THE REQUEST OF EVERY MEMBER I
KNOW SOME MEMBERS HAVE ALREADY
GONE THROUGH THEM.
WITH A FINE TOOTH COMB SO -- YOU
HAVE MEMBERS OF YOUR
PRESENTATION IF YOU CAN
[inaudible]
INTRODUCE THEM.
BUT SHEPHERD ON BEHALF OF THE
NONPROFIT ALLIANCE ARE PLEASE TO
SUPPORT AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX
LEGISLATION THAT MAINTAINS THE
LEGISLATURE'S CURRENT ROLE IN
PROTECTING CONSUMER SAFETY.
AND SHIELDS VULNERABLE NON
PROFITS FROM UNNECESSARY DATA
COST INCREASES AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
SIX IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL
THAT SIMPLY REMOVES THE SUNSET
ON A LAW THAT DISALLOWED THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
FROM REGULATING THE VOICE AND I
PEEN ABLE SERVICES SERVICES THAT
ARE VITAL TO NON PROFITS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX MAINTAIN
ALL CURRENT CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
AND EMPOWERS THE LEGISLATURE TO
TAKE FURTHER ACTION TO EXPAND
DIGITAL OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT
THE INTERESTS AND RIGHTS OF
CONSUMERS.
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY IS PARAMOUNT TO
KEEPING THE DOORS OF NON PROFITS
IN CALIFORNIA OPEN.
NONPROFITS RELY ON ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE DATA IF THE PRICE OF
DATA SKYROCKETS AS WE BELIEVE
WILL HAPPEN IF THE PC IS ALLOWED
TO REGULATE THE INTERNET.
CHARITIES WILL HAVE DIFFICULTIES
IN ABSORBING THESE COSTS WE IS
CONSUMER DATA AND THIRD PARTY
DATA PROVIDERS TO ANSWER ENSURE
MARKETING MESSAGES ARE DELIVERED
TO THOSE MOST LIKELY TO BENEFIT.
WITHOUT AFFORDABLE DATA COSTS
NONPROFITS CANNOT EFFECTIVELY
CONNECT WITH DONORS CURRENT LAW
HAS WORKED WELL ALLOWS FOR
CONSUMERS TO BE PROTECTED MEANS
MAINTAINS THE LEGISLATURE'S
POWER AND AUTHORITY.
AND SHIELDS VULNERABLE RATE
PAYERS LIKE CHARITIES FROM
UNNECESSARY COST INCREASES IF
THIS LAWS ALLOWED TO SUNSET
WITHOUT FURTHER LEGISLATIVE
ACTION -- THIS BILL THIS WILL
CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT OF
REGULATORY UNCERTAINTY AND
POTENTIAL FOR COSTLY LITIGATION
ON ALL SIDES POTENTIALLY
DELAYING FURTHER EXPANSION AND
INNOVATION OF THESE SERVICES AS
WELL AS CREATING LIFE.
REAL LIFE COST PRESSURES THAT
CAN CAUSE ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY
FOR THOSE WITH NO PROFIT MARGIN
TO ABSORB THE NEW COSTS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I
THOUGHT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS ON BURNS DEAN I COULD
PUT THE MICHAEL OF THE CLOSER SO
WE CAN CAN YOU HEAR ME YEAH I
MEAN I LOVE THE CLOSER WE CAN
HEAR YOU.
THANK -- AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE OVEN CHORUS SAN DIEGO
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX AT THE OPEN
CALL WE SERVE AS A BRIDGE TO A
BETTER LIFE FOR YOUNG ADULTS
AGED EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY SIX WE
PROVIDE PAID JOB TRAINING.
A SECOND CHANCE TO IN HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
AS I SAID OUR ORGANIZATION SAYS
IS A BRIDGE TO A BETTER LIFE FOR
YOUNG ADULTS THAT'S WHY I AM
HERE TODAY.
NEW INTERNET TECHNOLOGIES AND
SERVICES ARE HELPING CREATE THAT
FISH FOR THE YOUNG PEOPLE WE
SERVE.
AND I WANT TO SEE THAT CONTINUE.
ACCESS TO NEW TECHNOLOGIES IS
VITAL FOR THE YOUNG ADULTS WHO
SERVE IN SAN DIEGO I USED TO USE
THE INTERNET TO STAY CONNECTED
TO FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
ACCESS HEALTHCARE.
EDUCATION JOB OPPORTUNITIES AND
OTHER RESOURCES.
AND I KNOW THE POLICY IN PLACE
TODAY IS WORKING AND I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO EXTEND.
OUR CALL MEMBERS ONLY USE MOBILE
PHONES TABLETS AND OTHER
SERVICES THESE TECHNOLOGIES OF
VITAL AND PERHAPS MOST
IMPORTANTLY THAT POPULAR BECAUSE
THAT IS A FREE.
LOW LOW COST OVER THE AFFORDABLE.
THESE TECHNOLOGIES ARE IMPROVING
THE LIVES OF LOW INCOME AND
UNDERSERVED CALIFORNIANS.
WE'VE ALL HAD JUST SORT OF LESS
THAN PERFECT EXPERIENCES Và
SOME OF THE LARGER AGENCIES
MANAGING TECHNOLOGY -- AND TODAY
WE DON'T HAVE AGOVERNMENT
AGENCY PUTTING ITSELF BETWEEN
PEOPLE IN THESE AND THESE
CHOICES.
SO MY OPINION THIS IS A SUCCESS
ON MAKING THE MORE EXPENSIVE OR
HARD TO ACCESS WOULD BE A STEP
BACKWARD.
BECAUSE OF THIS I HOPE YOU WAS
SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION.
ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN FAVOR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BILL
DIVINE REPRESENTING EIGHTY ATI
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WANTED
WILLIAMS CENTER PROVIDERS AND
FAMILY LOCAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION WE ARE IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
GERRY PASSED MORE REPRESENTING
THE CONGRESS OF CALIFORNIA
SENIORS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES AND JONES
SERGEY TARP COUGH PRESIDENT OF
SLAVIC AMERICAN CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAROLINE
MCINTYRE BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
HEIDI PERSONALLY ON BEHALF OF
VERIZON AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS GLENN
FUJI NATIONAL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF A PAPA.
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS PRESSED IN
DICKINSON I'M THE OWNER OF
PRESTON'S TELECOM CONSULTING AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B..
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX GOOD
AFTERNOON STEVE TERRY I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
OROVILLE RESCUE MISSION.
WHICH IS A DONOR FUNDED NON
PROFIT I STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B..
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME SAID RINPOCHE
AND PROGRAM DIRECTOR OF THE
ORVILLE RESCUE MISSION.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX GOOD
AFTERNOON CHARLIE BORING WITH
FRONTIER COMMUNICATIONS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
IS THE JOHNSON WITH NIELSEN
MARKS TOMORROW BEHALF OF COMCAST
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON A DOLLAR -- SEE
SACRAMENTO'S CHAPTER PRESIDENT
AS STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JESSE BERMUDA'S
WITH ASIAN RESOURCES A LOCAL
NONPROFIT HEARING SACRAMENTO
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M EDWIN LOMBARD
THE INTERIM PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAME TO ME TRUTH
TECHNET IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON OF THESE A DAVIS
COINS PRESIDENT CEO FOR THE
SACRAMENTO BLACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DEEP
CARLSON -- FOR CTIA THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY TRADE ASSOCIATIONS.
AM LIMITS ON BEHALFOF
CONSOLIDATED COMMUNICATIONS IN
SUPPORT.
OPEN INTEREST ANDERSON WITH OUR
CAN YOU SEE P. CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
CHICAGO WITH **** COMMUNICATIONS
AND SUPPORT.
CORNELIUS BURKE WITH THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
CORNELIA FISHERMEN MEMBERS
MICHAEL DOUBLE THE CALIFORNIA
RANGE LAND TRUST ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
BUT SHEPHERD AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE CAL ASIAN CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF TO THE
BILL
.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN HOST AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
TOM RUNYON AND I'M PROUD TO
SERVE AS VICE PRESIDENT OF CW A
DISTRICT NINE REPRESENTING OVER
SIXTY THOUSAND MEMBERS.
IN CALIFORNIA.
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS OUR
WORKERS ON THE FRONT LINES OF
THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY.
HAVE BEEN HEARING DIRECTLY FROM
CONSUMERS REGARDING PROBLEMS
WITH THEIR PHONE SERVICE.
OUR MEMBERS OF ALSO WITNESS
SAFETY.
ISSUES WITH PHONE LINES THAT
HAVE BEEN NEGLECTED TO THE LACK
OF PROPER OVERSIGHT AND
REGULATION.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR WORKERS DO NOT
SEE THESE ISSUES GETTING ANY
BETTER.
WITHOUT THE STATE INTERVENTION
SOMETHING THAT CURRENT LAW
PROHIBITS.
THE DE REGULATION AVOID
TELEPHONE SERVICE UNDER SB
ELEVEN SIXTY ONE HAS LED TO
SIGNIFICANT CAPS IN CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS.
TRADITIONAL LANDLINE TELEPHONE
CUSTOMERS ARE ABLE TO FILE A
COMPLAINT WITH THE CP YOU SEE.
AND THE COMMISSION CAN TAKE
ACTION.
THEY CAN BE SURE THAT OUTAGES
WILL BE RETORED WITHIN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS.
THEY CAN ASSUME THEIR CALLS WILL
BE ANSWERED IN A REASONABLE TIME.
UNFORTUNATELY V<c.cyan> USERS HAVE</c>
NO SUCH ASSURANCES.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX ONLY
OFFERS LESSER OR NO PROTECTIONS.
CW A TECHNICIANS WORKING IN THE
FIELD SEE THE DISPARITY FIRST
HAND THEY PRIORITIZE RESTORING
TRADITIONAL PHONE SERVICE WALL
BOY CUSTOMERS ARE LEFT WAITING.
THIS IS FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING THAT MOST
CUSTOMERS HAVE NO IDEA THEY HAVE
BEEN SWITCHED TO AVOID.
SERVICE IN THE FIRST PLACE
UNLIKE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE THE MAJORITY OF HOME
PHONE SERVICE WOULD NOW BE
COVERED BY THE PROVISIONS OF AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX CW A HAS LONG
SUPPORTED POLICIES AND
PROTECTION OF CONSUMERS AND
WHOLE TELECOMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SERVICE.
BY EXTENDING THE PROVISIONS OF
SB.
ELEVEN SIXTY ONE UNTIL TWENTY
THIRTY AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX
WOULD ENSURE THAT MANY OF THE
ISSUES THAT ARE WORKERS HAVE
IDENTIFIED BECOME FURTHER
ENTRANCE.
THIS WOULD GIVE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES A
FURTHER REASON TO IGNORE THE
NEEDS OF THEIR CUSTOMERS.
NOW THAT THE MAJORITY OF PHONE
PHONE CUSTOMERS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE ON VOICE WITH SERVICE
PROVIDERS SWITCHING OVER MORE
PEOPLE EVERY DAY.
IT IS TIME THAT THE STATE ENSURE
THAT CONSUMERS DO NOT LOSE THE
PROTECTIONS THEY ENJOYED UNDER
THEIR PREVIOUS PHONE SERVICE.
THE DEFEAT OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
SIX WILL RESTORE CRITICAL
PROTECTION FOR CONSUMERS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY -- PROTECTIONS AS
WELL IF YOU PASS THIS BILL YOU
ARE TELLING MILLIONS OF
RESIDENTS THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL NOT PROTECT THEM.
E. W. A AND ITS MEMBERS HAVE
SEEN THE PROBLEMS FIRST HAND AND
BELIEVE IT IS TIME FOR THE C. P.
U. C. AND THE STATE TO TAKE BACK
THEIR AUTHORITY. TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS WE STRONGLY URGE
THAT YOU OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY SIX THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN WESSEL
SENATORS.
MY NAME IS MARTIN WAS MINUS
SEVEN ASSIGNMENT COMMISSIONER AT
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
AT OUR LAST PUBLIC MEETING THE
COMMISSION VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THE STATE HAS
AN ESSENTIAL ROLE IN ENSURING
ACCESS TO SAFE RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE COMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE REGARDLESS OF
TECHNOLOGY. FOR THE LAST TWO AND
A HALF YEARS THE TRUMP FCC HAS
ERODED ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE FAIR
AND EQUAL ACCESS TO THE INTERNET
AND COMMUNICATIONS SERVICES.
YET THIS BILL PROPOSES TO
ELIMINATE ALL STATE JURISDICTION
AND LEAVE THE PROVISIONS OF THE
CENTRAL ACCESS TO THE SEC AND
THE FREE MARKET.
AS YOU CAN SEE ON THE MAP THAT I
ASK -- THE SERGEANT TO HAND TO
YOU WE KNOW THAT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS DO NOT BENEFIT FROM
ANY COMPETITION IN THE
COMMUNICATIONS MARKET PLACE.
THAT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS HAVE
NO HIGH SPEED BROADBAND ACCESS
AND A THIRTY CALIFORNIANS
THIRTEEN MILLION APPROXIMATELY
DO NOT BENEFIT FROM ANY
COMPETITION.
THIS IS AN OLIGOPOLY IT'S NOT A
FREE MARKET.
THIS BILL PROHIBITS THE STATE
FROM GUARANTEE AN ESSENTIAL AND
RELIABILITY COMMUNICATION
SERVICES TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
SIMPLY BECAUSE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS BEEN UPGRADED.
IT WILL ELIMINATE PROGRAMS TO
ENSURE INFRASTRUCTURE ACCESS TO
RULE CALIFORNIANS TO THE DEATH
TO THE DISABLED AND TO THE POOR.
WITHIN IT COMES.
THE STATE IS NOT THIS THIS
BASICALLY IS ONLY BECAUSE
THEY'VE CHANGED INTERNET
PROTOCOL SERVICES IN THE STATE
IS NOT INTERESTED IN ENSURING
UNIVERSAL ACCESS.
THE BILL IS NOT ABOUT STIPPLING
INNOVATION OR APPS LIKE SKYPE.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT DEREGULATING
THE COMPANIES THAT OWN AND
MANAGE THE POLLS WIRES AND
RADIOS IN CALIFORNIA.
COMPANIES LIKE COMCAST IN
EIGHTEEN T. NOT THESE APPS.
UNDER THIS BILL THESE COMPANIES
WILL BE LEFT TO THEIR OWN SENSE
OF SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY NOT
GOVERNMENT OVERSIGHT.
THEIR OWN DECISION MAKING ON
WHAT THE CRITICAL ISSUES SHOULD
BE.
WHETHER THEY SHOULD PARTICIPATE
IN UNIVERSAL SERVICE PROGRAMS
LIKE LIFELINE. EIGHTEEN ANTI THE
STATE'S LARGEST CARRIER HAS
DECREASED ITS PARTICIPATION BY
90% IN THE LAST DECADE.
THEY'LL DECIDE WHICH COMMUNITIES
RECEIVE THE NEXT GENERATION OF
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE FIBER LIKE
FIVE G. LIKE TEN G..
THEY'LL DECIDE WHETHER OR HOW
QUICKLY INFRASTRUCTURE IS
REPAIRED OR UP CREATED IMPORT
COMMUNITIES AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
THEY'LL DECIDE WHETHER THE
ADDRESS COMPLAINTS FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND YOUR
CONSTITUENTS.
THEY'LL DECIDE WHERE THEY BUILD
WHILE FIRE PROOF AND DISASTER
RESILIENCY INTO THEIR CORE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEY WILL DECIDE WHETHER THE
SERVICE THEY PROVIDE IS RELIABLE
AND REDUNDANT SO ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN REACH NINE ONE
ONE DISPATCHERS AT ALL TIMES.
THEY WILL DECIDE WHETHER THEY
COORDINATE WITH THE I'LL USE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PREPARE FOR
DISASTERS TO RESPOND DISASTERS
TO RECOVER FROM DISASTERS.
THESE ISSUES ARE FUNDAMENTAL
THEY ARE TOO IMPORTANT FOR THE
STATE TO ABANDON ITS ROLE IN.
FIRE SEASON IS HERE AGAIN.
AND WHILE THE STATE HAS
SCRUTINIZED OTHER UTILITIES FOR
THE RELIABILITY DURING
INCREASINGLY DIM DEVASTATING
DISASTERS.
IT HAS NOT DONE SO FOR THE
COMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES.
YET WHILE FIRE ANOTHER DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE EVACUATION
AND RECOVERY HINGES ON A
RELIABLE COMMUNICATIONS GRID.
AND IT'S ESSENTIAL FOR ALL
UTILITIES IT'S THE BACKBONE FOR
POWER IT'S THE BACKBONE FOR
WATER AND OF COURSE FOR
COMMUNICATIONS.
THERE ARE TOO MANY COMMUNITIES
AND HIGH FIRE HAZARD ZONES WITH
REAL CONCERNS THAT THEY WILL BE
THE NEXT KOFI PARK OR PARADISE.
WE NEED TO KNOW IF THEIR
NETWORKS HAVE BACKUP POWER
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND REDUNDANT
BACK CALL.
THAT THERE ARE MERGING SEE
PREPAREDNESS PLANS THAT LOCAL
RESPOND TO RESPOND HERS KNOW
WHERE THEIR CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IS TO INCORPORATE
INTO THEIR RESPONSE PLANS
RECOVERY.
WE MUST IDENTIFY STRENGTHEN AND
PROTECT THE VULNERABLE PARTS OF
OUR NETWORKS BECAUSE BRINGING IN
TEMPORARY FACILITIES ON WHEELS
OR WINGS WILL ALWAYS BE TOO
LITTLE TOO LATE.
THE COMMISSION HAS LOOKED
EARNESTLY TO REPAIR CALIFORNIA
WHETHER WE SOUGHT TO ADOPT
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR VICTIMS
OF DISASTERS. TO REQUIRE
UTILITIES TO PREPARE FOR
DISASTERS IN RESPONSE OR TO
DEVELOP PROTOCOLS FOR D.
ENERGIES ATION EVENTS AND THIS
STATUTE HAS BEEN THE BARRIER TO
ENACTING UNIFORM PROCEDURES
ACROSS ALL UTILITIES.
WE KNOW THAT THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE IS FAILING WE
HAVE SEEN IN OUR SERVICE QUALITY
REPORTING.
WITH SADDAM SANTA ROSA AND IN
PARADISE AND IN OUR NETWORK EXAM
OF EIGHTEEN TO YOUR FRONTIERS
NOW QUIRK FROM.
TWENTY TEN TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THIS EXAM SHOWS.
WHETHER DELIBERATE OR NOT THE
EIGHTEEN ANTI INVESTMENTS
INVESTMENT POLICIES HAVE FAVORED
HIGHER INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
HAVE THUS HAD A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT UPON THE STATE'S LOWEST
INCOME AREAS.
WE FOUND A CLEAR INVERSE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN HOUSEHOLD
INCOME AND ALL THE PRINCIPLE
SERVICE QUALITY METRICS.
CNETRIC NETWORK HUBS.
WITH THE LOWEST HOUSEHOLD
INCOMES HAVE THE HIGHEST TROUBLE
REPORT RATES THEY HAVE THE
LONGEST OUT OF SERVICE DURATIONS
THEY HAVE THE LOWEST PERCENTAGES
OF OUTAGES CLEARED WITHIN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS.
THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE FOR THE
HIGHEST INCOME COMMUNITIES.
THIS LAW HAS CAUSED HARM BY
PREVENTING ACCESS TO GRADING THE
UNIVERSAL SERVICE PROGRAMS AND
PREVENTING PREPAREDNESS AND
RESILIENCY.
IT SHOULD SUNSET CALIFORNIANS
NEED THEIR GOVERNMENT TO ENSURE
THAT TEY HAVE RELIABLE
COMMUNICATIONS AND THIS LAW
PREVENTS THE MODERNIZATION AND
DEVELOPMENT OF THE PROTECTIONS
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS NEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
IS MIKE POWER THERE.
IS A BRONZE WITH THE GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
KARAGIAS SANDERS REPRESENTING
THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
FORMALLY THE OFFICER REPAIR
ADDICTS ADVOCATES WE REMAIN
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO HIS FELLOW
GIVEN THAT 50% OF THE POPULATION.
OF TELEPHONE CUSTOMERS ARE ON
VOICE AND IT SERVICES AND 53% IT
ADDED IS THAT OCCURRED ON WIFE I
WAS LAST YEAR WERE OVER BOY WHEN
I. P. NEEDLE SERVICES.
IF.
MARK TONY TURN STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL MAKE SURE WHEN IT
COMES TO WILDFIRES SAFETY WE
DON'T TIE THE HANDS NOT ONLY OF
THE PC.
BUT OF WE F..
CAL FIRE AND THE NEWLY FORMED
WILD FIRE SAFETY COUNCIL THANK
YOU.
RACHEL WALLACE WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
THE ONLY A SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR THE
COUNTIES OF HUMBOLDT AND MEN TO
SEE NO AS WELL AS THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THREE ZERO COUNTY
RIBS AS OF CALIFORNIA AND ON
BEHALF LEGAL CALIFORNIA CITIES
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
CHOI DEATH FROM BOB VOLUNTEER
FOR A A RP REPRESENTING THREE
POINT THREE MILLION OF OUR
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
IT'S BAD FOR CONSUMERS IT'S
GOING TO COST LIVES.
ENOUGH YOU'RE HERNANDEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION.
HELLO YOU'RE SORT OF OUR
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF AMERICA
AND POLITICAL DIRECTOR HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
I AM ALSO TECHNICIAN.
AND MORE FULLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL.
THE CZECHO CITY WITH ANY FOR
TWELVE HAYWARD HELP ASSERTION.
JOHN MERCHANT CW A NINETY FOUR
THIRTY THROUGH.
RURAL.
PLACERVILLE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION.
MORNING LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
ROGER DEAN COMMUNICATION WORKERS
OF AMERICA PRESIDENT LOCAL NINE
FOUR THREE ONE REPRESENTING.
PLACERVILLE.
NEVADA SIERRA YUBA.
COUNTIES -- THE RURAL AREAS
WHICH WILL BE HARMED BYTHIS
BILL.
STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
CHRISTOPHER ROBERTS PRESIDENCY
W. A. R. COMMUNICATION WORKERS
SAN DIEGO FOR ALSO OPPOSES BILL.
JUST SEND YOU CALIFORNIA -- CW A
NINE FIVE ONE NINE OPPOSE.
SHAWN HE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA NINETY FOUR
HUNDRED OPPOSED.
STANCE ON TO SOME OF THE
TECHNICIAN WITH EIGHTEEN TNC W.
EIGHT REPRESENTATIVE.
BUT I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY.
LARGE GROUPS OF FARMWORKERS IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES.
CAN BE AFFECTED VERY NEGATIVELY
BY THIS THANK YOU.
IF YOU'RE NOT BECAUSE THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF AMERICA
LOCAL.
NINE THOUSAND THREE AND ALSO
DISTRICT NINE OPPOSE.
ANY OTHER SPEAKERS OF THE WOULD
LIKE.
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN THIS BILL
SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION WINNERS [inaudible]
OKAY UP.
IN ON THIS BILL THERE ARE STRONG
ARGUMENTS ON BOTH SIDES -- BOTH
COMING FROM -- OUR STATES
REGULATORY AGENCIES AND CONSUMER
ADVOCATES BUT ALSO.
FROM THE INDUSTRY.
THAT MAKES CLAIMS THAT JOB THIS
IS CREATED MORE COMPETITION AND
OUR THAT OUR OUR REGULATORY
SYSTEM.
OFTEN TAKES.
YEARS TO DELIBERATE BECAUSE IN.
ENORMOUS HARM TO OF TO THE
INDUSTRY'S ABILITY.
TO STAY INNOVATIVE.
AND WE'RE THE INNOVATION STATE.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE FIND
INNOVATION.
I ALSO YOU KNOW IN IN THIS BILL --
THAT WAS ORIGINALLY.
PAST IT WAS A OF A REPORTING
REQUIREMENT THAT -- THE CPC THAT
REQUIRED THE CPUC REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON COMPLAINTS.
AND THAT HAS BEEN AN AREA WHERE
THE CQC ALSO HAS BEEN.
SOMEWHAT LACKEY IN REPORTING TO
THE THE LEGISLATURE AND THERE
ARE OF COURSE ARE A REGULATORY
AGENCY IN THAT IS -- FUNCTIONS
VERY IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY IN
GETTING US TO UNDERSTAND WHETHER.
THERE ARE A COMPLAINTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS PROGRAM.
AND SO WE THOUGHT IN IN IN.
IN HEARING KIND OF THE TESTIMONY
FROM THE OPPOSITION AND ALSO
FROM THE SUPPORTERS THAT WE FIND
A WAY TO STRIKE A HEALTHY
BALANCE THAT ADVOCATES FOR
CONSUMERS.
THAT ADDRESSES SOME OF OUR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE NEEDS.
THROUGH OUR DEPARTMENT -- YES WE
WE CONSULTED -- YES TO SEE HOW
WE CAN SOLVE THAT PROBLEM.
SHOW OF THE OUR OUR OUR OUR
AUTHOR HERE TODAY HAS AGREED TO
ACCEPT THESE AMENDMENTS.
THE AMENDMENTS WILL CLARIFY THAT --
YES HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
REGULATE THE TERMS AND
CONDITIONS OF NEXT GEN NINE ONE
ONE SERVICES AND THAT OF COURSE
IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
ESPECIALLY WITH THE STATE FACING
WILDFIRES AND AND AN INCREASED
NEED FOR EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
HOW WE -- WORKED WITH -- YES TO
DEVELOP.
THE THIS LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THAT
THEY HAVE.
AUTHORITY.
TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE.
ARE ARE PROVIDED WITH THE
ABILITY.
TO HOW TO RESPOND A IN CASE OF
EMERGENCIES.
ALSO OF WE AMENDED THE BILL
SUNSET DATE.
THE TWO FIVE YEARS AND HOPEFULLY
THAT WILL NOT IMPOSE AN UNDUE
BURDEN ON CPUC TO BE PART OF
THIS PROCESS.
TO REPORT COMPLAINTS -- WE WE
EXPANDED.
WE WHAT WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE I
WORKED A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
EXPANDING THE ANNUAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE WE ASKED OF
THE SEA OF PEACE.
A CPUC.
WHICH INCLUDE REQUIRE THE CPC
DUE TO REPORT COMPLAINTS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL REQUIRE THE CPC
TO ANNUAL REPORT.
ON THE NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS THE
NUMBER OF RESOLVE COMPLAINTS IN
THE AVERAGE DURATION. FOR
COMPLETE RESOLUTION BASED ON
REPORTS FROM TELECOMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS HAVING THIS
INFORMATION IT IS ESSENTIAL TO
ENSURE.
THAT THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES RESPOND ARE RESPONSIVE.
TO CONSUMER COMPLAINTS WE ALSO
HAVE A REPORTING REQUIREMENT
INFORMING CONSUMERS.
THAT IF THEY HAVE ANY COMPLAIN
ASSOCIATED WITH THEIR SERVICE
THEIR BILL THEIR QUALITY THAT
THEY SHOULD.
REPORT THAT TO THE C. P. YOU SEE.
THAT IS A REQUIREMENT THAT'S
INCLUDING THIS BILL.
THAT WILL INFORM PEOPLE WHAT
THEIR RIGHTS ARE ASKED CONSUMERS
AND TO WHAT MECHANISM THEY NEED.
TO FOLLOW THROUGH SO THEY CAN.
GET THERE ARE COMPLAINTS
RESOLVED.
THAT WILL OF HOPEFULLY BE OF A A
OF A VERY STRONG REQUIREMENT TO
ENSURE THAT THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES ARE.
ARE WORKING HARD TO SATISFY
THEIR CUSTOMERS.
IT ALSO RECALL.
BE SEATED IN FIND TRENDS IN
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS OF PROVIDE
THE LEGISLATURE.
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
ADDRESSING THESE.
THESE TRENDS SO WHERE WERE
ASKING TO SEE IF YOU SEE WE'RE
GONNA ASSN FOR THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS.
SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD
SHOULD BE ADOPTED INTO LAW. TO
WORK WITH US IN THE LEGISLATURE.
SHOULD WE SEE A RISE IN CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS OR TREND IN CERTAIN
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS.
OR CERTAIN TRENDS IN.
IN IN TELL ME ISSUE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS
AVOIDING SERVICE IN CERTAIN
AREAS.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO
KNOW THAT AND WE ARE WE ARE
PARTNERS IN THIS EFFORT WE ARE
PARTNERS IN REGULATORY EFFORT WE
DO.
WE DIDN'T WE NEED TO SEE IF YOU
SEE A PART BE A PARTNER IN
EFFORT TO PROVIDE.
THIS INFORMATION. TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
IT ALSO ARE THE BILL THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS WOULD REMOVE IT
EXEMPTIONS FROM AN ESTABLISHED
ENFORCEMENT REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
PORTIONS OF THE BILL.
ESTABLISHING BACK OF POWER
NOTIFICATION.
BILL CREDIT AND SERVICE
RESTORATION REQUIREMENTS.
AND THE FINAL ONE IS -- AN
AMENDMENT.
THERE'S TWO MORE WONDER LIMITS
CLASSIFICATION OF CERTAIN PASSED
CPUC DECISIONS AND ALSO.
A CLARIFICATION THE CDC HAS
AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH AN OF
COURSE KOHLER.
AND BASIC SERVICE REQUIREMENTS
ON THE TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL BASIS.
WE HAVE WORKED VERY HARD ON
THESE AMENDMENTS AND WORK VERY
HARD TO ENSURE THESE AMENDMENTS.
WILL HAVE THE TEETH NECESSARY TO
ADVOCATE FOR NOT ONLY
[inaudible]
V. THE THE CONSUMERS.
BUT OF FOR OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
PERSONNEL THAT ARE WORKING VERY
HARD. TO BE RESPONSIVE IN CASE
OF EMERGENCIES AND WE BELIEVE.
THAT UNLESS WE HAVE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE I
BELIEVE THIS IS A OF A REALLY
GOOD IT OF START TO CONTINUE ON
WITH.
OF PROGRAM THAT APPEARS TO HAVE.
BEEN WORKING IN.
A SO FAR.
AND STILL OF FIND THAT BALANCE
AS I MENTIONED ON FOR PROVIDING
THIS CONSUMER PROTECTIONS.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH CENTER
RUBIO.
IF YOU LIKE TO EXAMINE SORT OF
QUESTIONS WELL FIRST OF ALL I
WANT TO YOU KNOW COMMANDED THE
CHAIR BECAUSE I KNOW HIM AND I
SPEND A LOT OF TIME DISCUSSING
THIS ISSUE AND TO THE AUTHOR
ALSO BRINGING OF OVER.
FORWARD AND ACCEPTING IMMENSE --
I DID HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SIT
DOWN OR AT LEAST TALK VERY
BRIEFLY WITH COMMISSIONER WAS
MINE AND I HEARD HER CONCERNS AS
WELL AS ALL THE THE WORK -- CW A
AND I THINK THIS WAS A BILL THAT
WAS WASN'T EASY BUT I ALSO WANT
TO COMMEND THE INDUSTRY WHO SAT
WITH US I HAD A FEW PEOPLE LATE
LAST NIGHT IN MY OFFICE AND WERE
WILLING TO COME TO THE TABLE.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
ALLOW FOR INNOVATION AND GROWTH
AND BUT AT THE SAME TIME
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS WAS REALLY
AT THE HEART OF OUR DISCUSSIONS.
EVERY SINGLE DAY AND DIE WITH
ALL THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
READ RIGHT HERE I THINK THAT FOR
NOW IT STRIKES THAT MIDDLE
GROUND WHERE WERE ABLE TO AT
LEAST.
EXTENDED A FEW YEARS SO THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE IN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF YEARS MONITOR THE THE
INDUSTRY AND ENSURE THAT THOSE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS ARE WORKING
AND OUR ABLE TO TOPPLE THE
ISSUES THAT ARISE I KNOW
TECHNOLOGY IS MOVING.
BY FAST EXPONENTIALLY JUST AND
SO I THINK WE NEED TO TAKE POTS
ONCE IN AWHILE TO CHECK IN AND
MAKE SURE THAT THAT IT'S WORKING.
BUT FOR NOW I'M REALLY PLEASE
THAT THOSE AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN
AND CUTTING IT DOWN FROM TEN
YEARS TO FIVE I GET SIGNIFICAN
AND BOTH.
TRYING TO HELP THE INDUSTRY AS
WELL AS TAKING ALL THE CONCERNS
OF THE WORKERS AND CONSUMERS --
AND I ALSO WANT TO THINK THAT
CONSUMER ADVOCATES WILL ALSO SAT
WITH ME AND SPEND A LOT OF TIME
DISCUSSING THESE ISSUES -- I
THINK THAT WE HAVE AND THE CHAIR
HOUSE.
RELEASE CERTAINLY -- COME TO THE
MIDDLE AND I THINK IT'S A GREAT
BALANCE AND I WILL ALSO BE
SUPPORTING THE SPELL BUT I WANT
EVERYONE TO UNDERSTAND THE HOURS
THAT WENT INTO.
TRYING TO FIND THAT MIDDLE
GROUND AND TO SO THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR FOR BEING IN A FORD
AND TO THE CHAIR FOR FOR ALSO
ACCEPTING YOU KNOW CONCERNS AND
EVERYONE ELSE THAT GAVE HIM A
TOP AND WITH THAT I WILL ALSO BE.
SUPPORTING THE BILL THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WHICH ONE YEAH.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER SURE THANK
YOU SIMILAR FOR BRAINS FORD IBM.
THE STAFF THE LAST TIME THIS
BILL THE LEGISLATURE MISTER THE
AND THE WORLD'S CHANGED SOMEWHAT
SINCE THEN -- TECHNOLOGY YES BUT
THIS FIRE PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES
THE ESSENCE OF MY CONCERNED
THAT'S SORT OF WHERE I'VE BEEN
LASER FOCUS SO.
I'M REVIEWING THESE AMENDS IT IT
LOOKS LIKE WE'VE MADE.
SOME SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS ON
THAT FRONT BUT I I WILL.
TRYING TO GET A LITTLE MORE
CLARITY WHEN TURN TURN TESTIFIED
STILL WORRIED ABOUT WILDFIRE
ISSUES -- I DON'T KNOW IF.
IF IT'S THREE YOU OR THE CHAIR
OR TALKING EIGHTEEN TEA BAGS.
I JUST WANT TO GET A SENSE ON
THIS BACKUP POWER ISSUE
JURISDICTION ONLY WHAT.
YOU SEE WE THINK CAN DO OR WHAT
ROLE CARILLO YES MAY PLAY.
IN MAKING SURE THAT.
THE ENERGY IS ASIAN AND DURING
WILDFIRES VULNERABLE PEOPLE
DON'T GET.
STOCK IS THAT'S A LIFELINE AND
SO.
I'M I JUST I GOT TO GET SOME
REASSURANCE ON THAT AND MAY WE
CAN WALK THROUGH THE A MAN'S OR
HOWEVER YOU WANT TO AND I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT -- AND THIS
WAS OUR CONCERN.
FROM THE LOOK THIS WAS NOT EASY
BILL FOR ME TO TAKE IN THE FIRST
PLACE -- I HAVE NEVER.
THAT MAKES MY LABOR PARTNERS AND
THE BILL I'VE DONE.
WHAT I'M HOWEVER?
WE THINK THAT BY PROVIDING
EXPLICIT DIRECTIONS SO WITH --
YES BEING ABLE TO TO MAKE THE
NINE ONE ONE I'M CHANGES
ANYTHING TO NINE ONE ONE THAT
THAT'S GOOD THAT'S A START WHAT
WE ACTUALLY THINK.
WE'LL MOVE FASTER THAN IT WOULD
IF WE LEFT IT UP TO YOU SEE.
I'M WE ALSO THINK OF COURSE
WHERE WE'RE NOT GIVING UP THE
POWER THE LEGISLATURE TO MANDATE
ANYTHING AND I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT AS WELL.
AND THERE ARE CERTAIN PROVISIONS
ROUTE THIS BILL THEY THINK WILL
ACTUALLY MAKE IT.
I'M MUCH MORE CLEAR FOR
CONSUMERS THE FACT THAT THEY
WILL BE TOLD THEIR RIGHTS TO
HAVE BASIC LINE SERVICE -- WE
ARE NO WAY MOVING AWAY FROM
BASIC LINES SERVICE WERE
ACTUALLY GOING TO MAKE IT MORE
CLEAR.
I'M NOT ONLY THAT THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO BASICALLY IN SERVICE
THAT WITH BOYS IF THEY LOSE
THEIR POWER THE DATE WITHOUT
BACKUP GENERATION THEY WILL LOSE
THEIR TELEPHONE SERVICE.
SO THAT IS.
AN ADDITIONAL I THINK CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND A PROTECTION FOR
THOSE SPECIALLY WILDFIRE AREAS
TO UNDERSTAND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PGA OF COURSE TALK ABOUT --
PLANNED BLACKOUTS ARE IF YOU
WILL OR OR I I DON'T KNOW WHAT
ELSE TO COMBAT -- THREE THAT
THAT CONSUMER SHOULD UNDERSTAND
THAT MEANS YOUR PHONE WON'T WORK
UNLESS YOU HAVE BACKUP POWER I'M
IN AND I THINK THIS BILL
ACTUALLY DOES THAT EXTENDS THAT
IN A MUCH QUICKER WAY THAN IF WE
JUST SIMPLY LEFT IT UP TO THE UC
TO CREATE SOME -- NEW -- TO CALL
AND SO -- THOSE ARE THE THINGS
WERE SEEKING ANSWERS MORE THAT
YOU WOULD LIKE I'D BE HAPPY TO
WORK ITH YOU IS THIS MISS FORD
WE'VE BEEN ASKING ALONG THE WAY
WHAT ELSE IS IT BECAUSE WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS NOT.
THAT THEY SHOULD GO ON REGULATED
WE'RE SAYING THAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING THE REGULATION SO THIS
ACTUALLY GETS PUT IN PLACE IN
ENOUGH TIME TO AFFECT THOSE
CONSUMERS THAT WE KNOW -- NEED
TO BE EFFECTIVE NOW I'M REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THE SEVENTY TWO
HOUR RESTORATION -- SERVICE THAT
WAS ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS I
ASKED FOR BECAUSE THAT THAT
THAT'S ONE OF THINGS LACKING
WITH WITH -- VOICE OF COURSE YOU
KNOW WITH YOUR LAND LINE YOU
HAVE SOME SOME PROVISIONS THAT
THAT ENSURE YOU'RE GOING TO GET
YOUR LAND LINE BACK IF IT GETS
KNOCKED OUT WE HAVE THAT NOW SO.
WE'RE TAKING WHAT WAS THE STATUS
QUO MAKING IT MUCH BETTER AND
ALSO TAKING INPUT FROM FOLKS
LIKE YOU ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO
SAY WE NEED ADDITIONALLY -- THIS
INFORMATION IN THIS BILL I'M SO
THAT WE ARE.
DOING OUR PROPER ROLE I THINK IT
LEGISLATING THESE THINGS INTO --
INTO EXISTENCE RATHER THAN
WAITING FOR THE REGULATORY
SCHEME TO TAKE ITS TIME WHICH WE
ALL KNOW I I MEAN I HAVE A LIST
OF EXAMPLES OF HOW LONG THE P.
YOU SEE HAS TAKEN ON A NUMBER O
THINGS -- AND WE CAN'T WAIT
EIGHT YEARS WE CAN'T WAIT TEN
YEARS YOU KNOW SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE HOPING IF THERE'S MORE AS
YOU GO THROUGH IT IN AS THIS
GOES HOPEFULLY TOOK RELATIONS.
WERE WERE OPEN OKAY ADDING TO IT
HELPS -- WHEN YOU SAY?
MAYBE EVEN A PC I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY'VE REVIEWED THE A MAN'S OR
WHAT THEY THINK THEY CAN AND
CAN'T DO VERSUS CALLOW YES BUT
YOU'RE SAYING NOW WE HAVE.
TO THEY'D HAVE TO GO NOTIFY
CUSTOMERS THAT THEY'RE THEY
COULD LOSE POWER.
BUT DOES IT ACTUALLY AUTHORIZE
ANYONE EITHER CALLOW YES OR THE
P. YOU SEE TO MANDATE THAT THE
TELCOS OR THE CABLE FOLKS
ACTUALLY SUPPLY THAT POWER OR
DOES IT JUST SAY.
HEY HEADS UP POWER GOES DOWN
YEARS YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE A USE
THE PHONE IT JUST REQUIRES THE
TELCOS TO TELL THE CONSUMERS
THAT SO IF WE WANTED A MANAGED
EIGHTEEN OF BACK POWER THAT
SOMETHING WOULD HAVE TO ADD TO
IT. TWO CAN CAN I JUST GET A
QUICK PIECE OF FEEDBACK HERE DO
YOU MIND.
CHAIR JUST. TO BE CLEAR I JUST
GOT THE AMENDMENT I'M SO I'M
WRESTLING WITH THEM.
TOO I BELIEVE YOU CONCEPTUALLY
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO AND I
DON'T.
KNOW NOTIFICATIONS THE INTENT.
YOUR VIEW IS YOU NEED ME MORE
EXPRESSIVE STORY TO SAY NO YOU
YOU'VE GOT A BACK UP THESE
VULNERABLE THAT'S NOT IN THE
BILL CURRENTLY I GUESS -- YES
COULD DECIDE THAT WITH THEIR
NINE ONE ONE NEXT GEN BUT WE
WOULD ACTUALLY IF WE WANT THAT
WE NEED TO PUT IT IN THE BILL
OKAY.
WOULD YOU SEE THAT THE SAME ARE
NINE I ALSO JUST SAW THEM --
ELECTRONICALLY AS WELL BUT IN
YOUR UNFORTUNATELY IN OUR READ.
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH -- YES --
YES IS -- RESPONDED TO YOUR
MERGING SEIZE THEIR NINE ONE ONE
NETWORK IS FOR THE NINE ONE ONE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE NETWORK.
IS NOT FOR THE COMMUNITY
FACILITY IT'S NOT FOR THE
RESIDENT.
I SAW FOR THE RESILIENCY OF THE
ENTIRE COMMUNITY WHAT WE NEED IS
THE SAME SERVICE QUALITY
REQUIREMENTS AND RESILIENCY
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE CAN.
PROVIDE FOR THE OLD
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT'S NOT ANYTHING BEYOND THAT IS
BEING ABLE TO CALL I MENTIONED
TO YOU EARLIERTHAT WE HAVE
CALLED THE MEETING FOR THIS TYPE
OF PREPAREDNESS INTO PAYING A
CANYON.
WE COULDN'T EVEN CALL IT REQUIRE
ALL THE CARRIERS TO PARTICIPATE
IN THAT.
THIS IS A VERY BASIC
REQUIREMENTS IT'S BEYOND THE
NINE ONE ONE TERRACE THE NINE
ONE CHERUB IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND WE'RE VERY GLAD TO
SEE THAT BEING ADDRESSED.
WE NEED TO WORK ON THE NETWORK
STRUCTURE THERE IS RELIABLE
INCLUDING THE RESILIENCY OF
BACKUP POWER [inaudible]
SO.
IN A VERSION FROM YOU TO WORKING
ON THAT ISSUE.
I'M HERE I WILL WORK ON ANY
ISSUE -- I I THINK.
IN I MEAN WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
COMMISSIONER IT'S AT WE JUST
WANT TO ENSURE THAT WHAT WE DO
GETS DONE IT GETS DONE NOW IF
THAT MAKES SENSE -- AND AND I
YOU KNOW WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THESE FOR WHATEVER'S
NECESSARY.
I I REALLY -- PREFERRED I HAD
THE WELL I CAN SEE WHY YOU NEED
BACK UP POWER AS WELL BUT I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT.
I'M YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND
CONSTITUENTS IT LIVE IN AN AREA
THAT IS.
SUBJECT ALL THESE THINGS
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY STILL HAVE
A RIGHT TO BASIC SERVICE AND WHY
THAT THAT RIGHT IS SO IMPORTANT --
IN WHICH CASE IF THEY BASIC
SERVICE IT GETS BACK TO BEING
REGULATED OF COURSE -- BY THE PC
SO PART OF MY GOAL I THINK AND
ACCEPT DEAN -- THIS BILL TO TAKE
IT ON INTO AYE. TO EXTEND THE
SUNSET -- WIT WHICH IT IT'S NOT
A BILL I USUALLY WOULD DO IS TO
ENSURE THAT -- ON A VARIETY OF
GROUNDS I THINK IT'S IT'S M..
A CHANGE OF PACE OF HOW WE'VE
SEEN THE COMPANIES GO AWAY FROM
BASIC SERVICE IN -- MAYBE AT AN
UNDERSTANDING OF A NEW WORLD
WHERE CONSUMERS MADE ME THAT
EXPLANATION OF WHY THAT WOULD BE
SO IMPORTANT FOR THEM IN CERTAIN
AREAS OF THE STATE.
TO UTILIZE THAT BASIC SERVICE
RATHER THAN RELYING ON ON VOIGTS
FURTHER ON SERVICE.
SO ALL I WOULD JUST ASK FOR FOR
MEDIA COME THROUGH THE VOTE
TODAY IS.
I TRUST YOUR WORD I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING HARD ON THIS AND IT
IS A TOUGH ONE BUT JUST.
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESS NOT JUST
NOTIFICATION THAT A YOU MAY LOSE
SERVICE AND THE ENERGY IS ATION
EARN WILDFIRE BUT AN ACTUAL.
AUTHORITY AND WE CAN TALK ABOUT
ENTITY.
A WHETHER YOU SEE -- E. S. WHAT
THE RIGHT ENTITIES BUT A
REQUIREMENT TO DO THAT BACK UP
WORK NOT JUST SOMETHIN SAYING
HEY HE MAY FALL GOOD LUCK.
RIGHT RIGHT NOW ABSOLUTELY IF
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT YOU YOU
WANT MOVING FORWARD BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU ON THAT
AND I'M. TO TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
THE APPROPRIATE PLACE SAYS --
AND YOU KNOW OF COURSE WE HAVE
ENFORCEMENT WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SO THERE THERE'S A
NUMBER OF PLACES I THINK WE
COULD LOOK AT LEAST AMOUNT THANK
YOU THAT MEANS A LOT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO SEE
SOMEONE CAN ADDRESS THE ISSUE
ABOUT -- INVEST INVESTMENTS IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITY AND I ALSO
HEARD.
ADJOURNMENT TALK ABOUT THE RURAL
COMMUNITIES CAN.
CAN YOU SHARE A LITTLE BIT OF
HOW WE'RE GONNA TACKLE THIS
ISSUE IS TO ENSURE THAT THEY
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE BEING SERVICE.
AND THAT IS AN ISSUE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY THERE'S BEEN A
NUMBER OF BILLS OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS TO TO TRY TO GET AT
THAT.
AND I THINK THE RESPONSIBILITY
THAT WE HAVE -- IN ORDER TO AT
IT HASN'T HAPPENED WHAT'S
HAPPENED MORE THAN WE GIVE IT
CREDIT TO ACTUALLY -- ACCESS TO
SERVICES IS MUCH BROADER I THINK
AND THEN ALL OF US REALIZE BUT
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE HAVE
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON I I KNOW
I THINK BOTH OF US HAVE BEEN CO
AUTHOR SOME BILLS IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS. TO EXPAND THAT KIND
SERVICE IN TO WORK ON THAT
LEGISLATIVELY DOESN'T PREVENT US
FROM DOING THAT ANYWAY.
AND TOWN WELL LASTLY I'M I ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE BECAUSE I'M
HEARING IN YOUR CONCERNS BERMAN
IS -- GOES MAN AND I WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THE RESTORATION
GUARANTEE IS THERE THAT IT'S
SOLID AND THERE'S NO LOOPHOLES
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S BEEN A
CONCERN.
FOR SOME ODD CONSUMERS AS WELL
AS RELIABLE QUALITY SERVICE AND
SELL.
AND YOU CAN SURE THAT THIS IS
WHAT TO HAVE IT'S DEFINITELY
BETTER THAN THE CURRENT LAW SO
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT FOR US
RATE OF SERVICES CURRENTLY WE
PUT. FOR VOICE THERE IS NO
REQUIREMENT THAT WAS I HEARD
THAT LOUD AND CLEAR FROM FROM CW
A EMPLOYEES WHO AT THAT'S A
PROBLEM I MEAN YOU COULD CALL
AND CALL AND THERE IF YOU HAVE
NO.
DEADLINES RIGHT -- BUT THERE IS
FOR BASIC SERVICES SO WE DON'T
WANT TO DO THE EXACT TWENTY FOUR
HOURS BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME
DIFFERENCES IN THE TYPE IN AND
WHAT.
WHAT THEY HAVE TO FIND I'M SO WE
DID A SEVENTY TWO HOUR WITH
ENFORCEMENT BEING TO THE AG I'D
BE HAPPY -- TO STRENGTH AND THAT
I I I A WOULD BE AS I CONTINUE
AND I WORKED -- WITH WITH.
THE OPPONENTS AND CONTINUES A
WHAT ELSE IS IT THAT WE CAN DO
TO MAKE THIS BETTER WITH OUT.
I AM THE ONE THING WITH THAT IS
WE'RE NOT GIVING IT WE'RE NOT
SAYING OKAY FINE FORGET IT WILL
JUST GIVE YOU SEE ARE NOT
RUNNING THE BILL BASICALLY.
OUTSIDE OF THAT WHAT CAN WE DO
TO HAVE A FRAMEWORK THAT WORKS
FOR CONSUMERS PASSED IN SO I'LL
CONTINUE I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
TALK TO YOU -- ON SOME OF THOSE
THINGS IF YOU DON'T FEEL LIKE
IT'S STRONG ENOUGH.
THANK YOU AND AND AGAIN I THINK
THAT THE MORE WE TALK ABOUT THIS
THE MORE I SEE THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO TO SOLVE THIS ISSUE
AND THAT'S ALL THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING QUESTIONS REALLY
APPRECIATE IT.
IF POSSIBLE JUST ON THE
RESTORATION QUESTIONS THAT'S
SHOWING US YOUR NAME IS A WE
HAVE THE CONSUMER FEDERATION
CALIFORNIA ALSO.
SEE TO BE A DESERVE NINE AND AND
TURN ON THE RESTORATION IN THE
REVIEW OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE
SAW -- THIS MORNING OR THIS
AFTERNOON -- IT IS IMPORTANT
NOTICE THAT THERE IS LANGUAGE IN
THERE THAT APPEARS TO BE AN
EXEMPTION -- FORM THE THE TWENTY
FOUR HOUR NOTICE AND SEE TWO
HOURS OF RESTORING SERVICE --
WHAT IT STATES IS THAT IF THE
QUOTE PROVIDER IS ALREADY
SUBJECT TO A RESTORATION REQUIRE
THAT REQUIREMENT IS SIMILAR OR
THE SAME?
THEN THE REQUIREMENTS IN THIS
BILL DON'T APPLY.
THAT COULD BE READ TO MEAN THAT
A PROVIDER LIKE EIGHTEEN T.
WHICH IS ALREADY SUBJECT TO
RESTORATION FOR ITS COPPER LAND
LINES WOULDN'T THEN NOT BE
SUBJECT.
TO THIS LANGUAGE IT DOES NOT SAY
THAT THE STRONGER STANDARD
APPLIES.
BOARD SAY THAT THE STANDARD
APPLIES OF TECHNOLOGY SO WE
THINK THAT COULD ACTUALY BE A
PRETTY WIDE EXEMPTION FROM WHAT
WE THINK THE WHAT ARE INNER SENS
WHAT THE AUTHOR INTENDS. TO FOR
THAT TO APPLY WITHOUT EXEMPTION
SIMPLY BECAUSE EIGHTEEN T.
ALREADY HAS A REQUIREMENT FOR
COPPER LAND LINE -- WE'RE NOT
COMFORT CONFIDENT ON THAT BEING --
THAT RESTORATION REQUIRED
ACTUALLY BEING APPLICABLES
EIGHTEEN T..
I THINK THAT'S MORE OF A
DRAFTING ARE THAT WE'RE HAPPY --
TO CONFIRM THAT THAT WAS NOT OUR
INTENTION SEVEN IT'S NOT AND IT
WAS INTENDED NOT TO DUPLICATE
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS FOR
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS SO.
THAT'S EASILY ADDRESS MAYBE
THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS BUT YOU
KNOW RIGHT NOW -- FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THIS HEARING AND
WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE -- TO COME
TO AGREEMENT WITH THEM IN THESE
THESE.
AMENDMENTS WE THINK COVER.
ALL THE MOST IMPORTANT AREAS
UNLESS.
YOU DISAGREE DID ANYONE ELSE
HAVE ANY COMMENTS -- CENTER
BRADFORD THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I WANT TO WANT TO THANK ON
AUTHOR AND ALL THE WORK THAT HAS
BEEN DONE I FIND MYSELF IN A
VERY UNIQUE POSITION BECAUSE I
ALONG WITH -- CENTER PADILLA
AUTHORED THIS MEASURE TWELVE
YEARS I MEAN I SEVEN YEARS AGO
THE BRING US TO WHERE WE ARE
TODAY -- REVIEWING THIS AND I
CHOSE TO CARRY THIS.
LEGISLATION.
WHEN I WAS IN ASSEMBLY WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS WAS A
NEW TECHNOLOGY AND WE WANTED
THIS TECHNOLOGY TO OF ALL?
IN TAKE HOLD ANY PASS.
BUT 'M ALSO CONCERNED AS I
HEARD FROM CW A ABOUT.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND MAINTAINING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN A LOT OF TIMES
WE ARE.
ARE MISLED AT AS TO BELIEVE THAT
FIBER JUST BECAUSE WE PUT FIBER
WE CAN ABANDON THE COPPER AND
THEY HAVE CLEARLY ABANDONED
COPPER I STILL HAVE A LAND LINE
IN MY HOME TODAY.
I WILL AWAYS HAVE A LAND LINE
BUT EVERY TIME I GO OFF LOOK I
HAVE NOTHING BUT STATIC.
ON MY LINE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THIS COPPER
STEEL THE BACKBONE FOR VOICE IN
ORDER TO WORK.
STILL IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT ONLY
MAINTAINED BUT IT RESPONDED
QUICKLY -- YOU KNOW TO SERVICE
OUTAGES WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN WITH THE BAT
RAINS.
IN CALIFORNIA WHERE WE SAW
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CUSTOMERS THROUGHOUT -- WITHOUT
SERVICE FOR DAYS IN OUT AND YOU
WITHOUT SERVICE FOR SOME AS MUCH
AS A WEEK.
MY CONCERN IS THAT IF IT'S NOT
TO PAY YOU SEE AND THAT FOR
OVERSIGHT WHAT AGENCY SHOULD
THAT BE I DON'T NECESSARY
BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE AS YOU SAY
THE AVERAGE CONSUMER DOESN'T
KNOW HOW TO PICK UP THE PHONE
AND CALL THE P. YOU SEE.
THERE SURELY NOT CALLING THEIR
LEGISLATOR WHEN THEY SAY MY
PHONE SERVICE IS NOT WORKING SO.
WHO SHOULD BE MORE RESPONSIVE TO
THE CUSTOMER IF IN FACT THERE IS
AN OUTAGE AND I I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT SERVICE RELIABILITY IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT?
AND AGAIN IT'S I KNOW A LOT OF
OUR RESIDENTS WILL NEVER OUT OF
WHITE BUT I KNOW A LOT OF FOLKS.
HAVE WAY BECAUSE YOU'RE MY
GRADING BECAUSE OF GANT WERE NOT
MAINTAINING THE COPPER.
WIRE SO IT'S ALMOST A FORCED
MIGRATION TO AVOID.
SO HOW DO YOU RESPOND.
WELL THE ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IS
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IN THIS SO
THEY WILL BE.
I I KNOW THAT THE ADDING A LOT
OF WE WOULD IF THEY WOULD HAVE
THEY COULD STILL REPORTED TO THE
UC AND UC WILL REPORTED TO THE
AG YOU IS IMPORTANT MECHANISM.
AND I I WANT TO THANK YOU GUYS
AS THE CHAIRMAN STATED YOU'VE
TAKEN A LOT OF AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE BROUGHT.
ME A LITTLE CLOSER TO BEING
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS AGAIN MY
CONCERN IS THE INTERSTATE CALLS
AS IT RELATES TO OUR OUR FOLKS
SURE INMATES HOW DO WE ADDRESS
THAT BECAUSE THAT WAS NOT
ADDRESS AND I WAS ONE OF MY
CONCERNS AND I THINK IF WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT RATES WERE.
TALKING ABOUT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS WHY SHOULD WE
PROTECT PRE PROTECT THOSE FOLKS
I'M THAT IS AN ISSUE AS WELL AND
WE WERE LOOKING TO BE HONEST --
AT A BILL THAT WILL BE AN
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS BY MISS
MITCHELL -- AND WHEN IT HAVE
WANTED TO REACH OUT TO HER
BECAUSE IT HAS TO DO WITH THOSE
CALLS IN PARTICULAR AND SEEN --
MAYBE IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
PROCESS WHERE THAT.
WHERE THAT BELONGS IN THIS BILL
OR THAT BILL BUT ABSOLUTELY IT'S
ON OUR RADAR AND ONE THAT WE
KNOW NEEDS TO BE SO IS THERE A
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESS THAT
EITHER THROUGH THIS?
BILL ARE TO MISS MITCHELL'S BILL
BUT I THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED I AGREE
WITH YOU COMPLETELY AND WE HAVE
EVERY INTENTION OF DRESSING THAT
AND BACK TO RELIABILITY.
CALL -- CARRIER LAST RESORT.
WHERE DOES THAT FALL?
UNDER THIS MEASURE.
THAT STILL EXISTS.
I MEAN BUT I'M NOT SURE YOU KNOW.
WHERE THE OVERSIGHT AND WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT I MEAN --
IT'S STILL YOU SEE A STILL
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT THEY STOP
THE THE OVERSIGHT OF THE CARE OF
LAST RESORT SO MUCH BECAUSE WHEN
COULD YOU RESPOND TO THAT.
WELL THERE'S A COUPLE AGAIN AND
JUST SKIMMING NOT HAVING THE
AMENDMENTS IN FRONT OF ME I
THINK THAT'S A VERY CRITICAL
PROVISION THAT LEAVES ALL THOSE
RED AREAS THAT YOU HAVE ON YOUR
MAP WITH NOTHING.
IF WE DON'T HAVE THAT PROVISION.
AND I MISTER HERNANDEZ MENTION
SOME OF THE LANGUAGE THAT WAS
QUALIFYING THAT ASSEMBLY WOMAN
IS ALWAYS HAS AGREED TO A MAN.
WE NEEDED TO BE TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL THAT REGARDLESS OF THE
TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE THAT CARRIER
OF LAST RESORT WE HAVE THE
QUALITY SERVICE.
NOW.
OBVIOUSLY THE MAINTENANCE ISSUE
OF THAT OVERSIGHT IS CRITICAL WE
WE HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO DO
THAT SORT OF OVERSIGHT.
AND OBVIOUSLY THE LEGISLATURE'S
JURISDICTION HERE I NOT SURE
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
INTERESTED IN THAT TYPE RURAL
AND AND CENTER BRADFORD JUST TO
GO OVER THE AMENDMENTS AGAIN.
THE ONE THAT CLARIFIES THAT THE
CPC HAS THE AUTHORITY
ESTABLISHMENT FORCE COLOR AND
BASIC SERVICE REQUIREMENTS ON A
TECHNOLOGY KNOWN SHOULD CHECK I
I JUST THOUGHT THAT I'M SORRY
OKAY.
ART THANK YOU.
A SMALL MEMINTA WHAT I SAW ON
THAT WE WANT TO INCLUDE BASIC
SERVICE ON THAT.
WHEN I THINK YOU AND YOUR ON
STAFF FOR WORKING TO INCREDIBLY
HARD ON THIS BILL WE -- HAVE
BEEN SEEKING AND WELCOME WAYS TO
IMPROVE THIS AND ENSURE
CONSUMERS ARE PROTECTED -- WITH --
YOU KNOW A CENTRAL FEATURE OF
COURSE IS THAT THE COMPETITION
CONTINUES AND WE HAVE THE
ABILITY.
THE THINGS I'M SO PROUD OF AND I
THINK THE THE SENATOR HAVING A
SHARE DISTRICT UNDERSTANDS IS --
THE THE QUICK.
EXIT OF THE CALLING CARDS AT YOU
KNOW.
THE ESTABLISHMENTS IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT USED TO BE SO
EXORBITANT THE FACT THAT WE HAVE --
NEAR COMPLETE ACCESS FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO CALL HOME -- TO
FOREIGN COUNTRIES WITH.
NO COST -- HAS BEEN AMAZINGLY
HELPFUL THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF
INNOVATIONS WE WANT TO PROTECT
AND WE WANT TO CONTINUE WITH BUT
AT THE SAME TIME WE DON'T WANT
TO LEAVE ANYONE IN A RURAL AREAS
ARE WILD HIGHER AREAS ARE LOW.
INCOME AREAS -- HANGING AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO IMPROVE THE
SPELL AND MY COMMITMENT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN IF IF PEOPLE ARE NOT
SATISFIED ON THAT LAST VOTE I'M
ON THE FLOOR THE SENATE.
YOU KNOW.
THAT I I UNDERSTAND I MEAN I I I
THINK I'VE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH LOVE YOU LIKE
I UNDERSTAND I UNDERSTAND THIS
IS A TOUGH BILL.
AND SO -- AND YOU KNOW BUT FOR
CARRYING IT WOULD WOULD WOULD
FEEL THE SAME SO I THINK WE'RE
IN THE MIDDLE OF THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE IT BETTER WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE IT WORK -- WE
JUST AS YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT A BETTER WAY THAN
JUST HANDING SOMETHING THE PC
WHICH WOULD TAKE IT TEN YEARS TO
GET THE KIND OF PROGRESS WE'RE
MAKING RIGHT NOW WITH THIS BILL
SO WITH THAT I RESPECT LASSEN
ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WITH
THAT -- CAN WE TAKE A MOTION ON
THE BILL.
HAVE A MOTION CLERK.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SIXTY PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WEST
SO I WAS SO I AM MORE A LOT.
MORE LIKE I A BRADFORD.
BEDFORD I CHING CHING AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
HILL.
HILL NO MCGUIRE.
RUBIO.
PREVAIL I SKINNER.
STERN STERN AYE STONE STONE AYE
WIENER.
WIENER NOW.
OKAY THAT BILLS ENOUGH TO GET
OUT WILL KEEP THE ROLE OF THE
FRESH SCENT MEMBERS NOW WILL GO
THROUGH -- THE BILLS --
BEGINNING WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB. FIFTY SIX FIVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA.
THE CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible] FOUR ONE
NUMBER.
ONE I ITEM NUMBER ONE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ON YOUR CAL -- YOUR
RADIO AGENDAS I REMEMBER ONE AB
FIFTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA.
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AB FIFTY SIXTY PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE.
FOR ONE MORE LOT.
MORE LIKE NO CHANGE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
KILL.
KILL NO MCGUIRE [inaudible]
SKIN CAN YOU CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AGAIN PLEASE
[inaudible]
CHANGE.
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE.
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
KAMALA. TO LISTEN. THREE NINE
COOLEY HAVE A COURTESY VOTE HERE.
ACTUALLY.
ALL RIGHT ON THE LETTER TO THE
NAME OF THE ITEM TO A CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE MEMBERS.
I'M EIGHT I'LL SAY -- AND AN
EIGHT AB THREE EIGHT SIXTY
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE FIVE ONE MORE LOCK.
CHANG THIS CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AB TEN TWENTY SIXTY PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE.
SIX ZERO BRADFORD OUR RECORD I
CHIANG CHING AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL HILL AYE
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
SKINNER. ELEVEN ZERO WILL HOLD
THE ROLE PRESS MEMBERS CLERK --
THIS CALL THE ROLL ON NUMBER
ITEM NUMBER FOUR A. B. TEN
EIGHTY THREES SOMEONE NUMBER.
FOR AB KENNEDY THREE D. PASSES
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR KERN
VOTE SIX ZERO BRADFORD.
CHIANG AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER. ELEVEN OR
TWELVE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A THE
MAKER.
OF ENOUGH VOTES MEDICATION. ONE
OF THE ISSUE SHE WAS JUST.
WE JUST DIDN'T HAVE [inaudible]
SKINNER.
ALL THE ROLE OKAY SHE DOES COME
BACK -- WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX
GONZALEZ.
CLICK THIS CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
DO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE.
NINE TWO MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE NOW [inaudible]
SKINNER.
OKAY THAT EVERYBODY ON ITEM
NUMBER SIX A. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY
FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER BERMAN.
CLERK PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS.
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY FORTY PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
MORLOCK.
CHANG.
CHANG I'D DIED.
DIED I'M HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL HILL AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER.
WELL MOVED ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN BY
SOMEONE MEMBER FRIEDMAN CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE UPS MEMBERS.
DO YOU PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT THAT SIX ZERO BRADFORD.
REDFORD I CHING CHANG AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
HILL HILL AYE MCGUIRE.
WHERE I SKINNER?
VERY WELL I WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB SIXTEEN NINETY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE.
THIS CALL ABSENT MEMBERS DO
PASSES AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CURRENT VOTE FOUR ZERO
MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
HILL HILL AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
INNER.
STERN.
STERN AYE.
ITEM NUMBER NINE IS HERE SEVENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AT B. ADOPTED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE SIX ZERO
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG.
ACR. SEVENTY EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT
HERTZBERGAYE HILL HILL AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER.
LOW MULLIN TEN NUMBER ONE AB
FIFTY SIX CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
THIS IS. EIGHT AB FIFTY SIXTY
PASSED THE MILITARY PROGRAM
TRANSFERRING TO VOTE. FIVE THREE
CHANGE -- I LIKE IT WHEN YOU
MIKE WEIR [inaudible]
SHE SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible] THREE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE ON I REMEMBER --
ONE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB.
THREE EIGHTY SIX DO YOU HAVE TO
THE MENTOR APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE TEN OF ONE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
LIKE.
STAINS MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE.
THE BILL ITSELF CLOSER ROLE ITEM
NUMBER THREE CLICK PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AB TEN TWENTY SIXTY PASSED THE
MENTION PERFORATIONS CURRENT BUT
TEN ELEVEN ZERO MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
MCGUIRE AYE.
CLOSE ROLE ON THE BILL OF ITEM
NUMBER FOUR PLEASE KEEP ALL
SCANNING THE OPTION NUMBER.
AB [inaudible]
TEN EIGHTY THREE SKINNER.
WELL CALLED CLOSER ROLE IN THE
BILL.
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible] NINE
WE'LL CLOSE ROLE ON ITEM NUMBER.
NINE ITEM NUMBER SIX I'M SORT OF
THOSE AND FIVE YEAH.
NUMBER -- SIX PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CLOSE ROMAN.
NUMBER.
SIX NUMBER SEVEN WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE UNDER SEVEN I WILL CLOSE
FOR A LONG OF THE BILLS WILL
ADJOURN OUR COMMITTEE NOW THANKS
VERY MUCH LISTEN JOHN